welcome to this new cyber security
course for beginers 2023 by simply learn
in this course we will understand what
is cyber security reasons to learn cyber
security cyber security jobs and salary
we will also understand in detail about
ethical hacking while learning basics of
cyber security we will cover what is
firewall what is Ransom we what is
malware what is SQL injection what is
fishing and much more stay tuned with
the course if you are looking to learn
in-depth about cryptography K Linux
intrusion detection system or IDs by the
end of this course we will take you
through the most asked interview
questions in cyber security cyber
security is said to be one of the
promising career in the near future and
to open the door to such a successful
career simply learn offers postgraduate
program in cyber security this
comprehensive postgraduate program in
cyber security is taor made to equip you
with the essential skills needed to
excel in the rapidly expanding realm of
cyber security with the focus on the
latest industry Trends this program
ensures you to stay ahead of the curve
and become an expert in the dynamic
world of cyber security by the end of
this course you will be skilled with
Advanced hacking Concepts Network packet
analysis ethical hacking idas firewalls
and honey Bots security and risk
management network security and more
find the complete course details from
the link in the description box so
before we move ahead consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn so without any further
delay over to our tutors did you know
that Facebook removed 2.29 billion
content pieces from their website after
a record number of complaints regarding
hacked accounts even the mighty Facebook
cannot secure its systems 100% such is a
situation when it comes to cyber
security based on recent events and
future predictions cyber crimes will
cost organizations worldwide are
whopping $10.5 trillion coming from just
$3.5 trillion in 2050 so you can
understand why it should not come as a
surprise that professionals trained in
cyber security are in skyh high demand
and will be for the foreseeable future
so what's better than staying ahead of
the curve and getting Trad in cyber
security now there are several reasons
as to why you should learn cyber
security
here we have the top 10 reasons for the
same at number 10 the reason we have is
basic requirements there is a wrong
notion that building a career in cyber
security is daunting well it is not a
fancy college degree is not at all that
it takes to become a successful cyber
security professional you can Venture
into the domain of cyber security with
some basic knowledge of it and with an
authorized cyber security certification
the overall eligibility Criterion for
the cyber security domain is relaxing
across the world it professionals with
cyber security certifications are known
to receive higher salary packages
certifications are always given extra
vitage in the infosec field and it opens
doors to bigger
opportunities these cyber security
certifications can be opted by anyone as
the eligibility for these are very basic
cyber security certifications train
professionals and thus helps in Bridging
the Gap between the supply and demand of
skilled cyber security
professionals so don't take a step back
from learning cyber security thinking it
is a tedious process if you are a
fresher or a professional you can go
ahead with just these basic
requirements before moving on to our
next reason here is a question for you
all how many of you like mathematics
please let us know in the comment
section below I'm sure not everyone
loves mathematics and that is completely
okay when it comes to learning cyber
security
and our ninth reason is mathematics is
not a concern for learning cyber
security many of us find mathematics
challenging some have the aptitude for
dealing with numbers and some don't and
for those who don't they find it
difficult to proceed with a career that
has maths
involved however you can take your
decision without any worries when it
comes to cyber security as the domain of
cyber security does not involve
mathematics so if maths is not your
strong point then choosing to learn
cyber security is a great choice this
can definitely be a relief to many
instead you can get acquainted with
networking network security control and
coding to build a career in cyber
security our eighth reason is that cyber
security is a profession that helps
achieve the greater good cyber security
consists of a set of measures and
approaches that help companies and
individuals data from being compromised
and
stolen cyber Security Professionals have
defended organizations from several
deadly cyber attacks that aimed at
jeopardizing an organization's
confidentiality integrity and
availability cyber crimes are currently
on the rise with different types of
cyber attacks the threat to
organizations and individuals alike is
only growing by the day government
agencies police forces and cyber crime
cells are tackling this threat however
there is more requirement for skilled
cyber security professionals who can
protect data and work for the greater
good therefore if you want to bring
about a positive impact and a meaningful
difference to the society we live in
then learning cyber security is a great
choice our seventh reason is that you
get to travel the world who doesn't love
to travel the globe learning cyber
security is a great reason especially
for those of you who aspire to travel
the world with the lack of cyber
Security Professionals in the world
there are plenty of opportunities for
skilled exper fors to travel overseas to
Showcase their cyber security skills
which are in high demand The increased
demand for cyber Security Professionals
is not just restricted to one area but
to the entire world there are several
employment opportunities for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
so learning cyber security can open new
doors for you overseas as well our sixth
reason is very interesting and that is
the fact that you get to work with
secret agencies and high-profile ones
like other
professionals cyber Security
Professionals also have the opportunity
to work with several prestigious
multinational companies and big giants
like Google Dell Accenture and others
however a cyber security professional's
career opportunities can go beyond mnc's
and they might get the opportunity to
work with top government secret agencies
like mosad NSA ni FBI and so on so what
are you waiting for become a cyber
security expert and showcase your skills
to grab the chance to work with these
top agencies our fifth reason is it is
never too late to begin with there are
very few professions that give you the
Liberty to begin late and one such
profession is cyber security it is never
too late to realize that you want to
become a cyber security expert many
people work as cyber Security
Professionals even after the retirement
if they have a good knowledge about
it you could also join cyber security
courses that train you irrespective of
your
age as long as you have good cyber
security skills there is no need to
worry about job security however late it
is our fourth reason is cyber security
is an evergreen industry cyber security
has gradually become an evergreen
industry in the current times with the
onset of the coid 19 pandemic businesses
are moving online and shifting to cloud
storage the demand for cyber security is
at its
peak there is a high demand for cyber
Security Experts who can Safeguard
Digital Data hence we can be rest
assured that cyber security is here to
stay and this domain is only going to
grow in the coming
years according to cyber security
Ventures the number of Internet users
will hit a whooping 6 billion by
2022 these numbers speak volumes and
this reveals the growing demand for
cyber Security Professionals across the
globe digitalization is taking place
across several
Industries a cyber security expert finds
opportunities in every field as every
organization wants to be secure on the
digital front so now is the right time
if you are looking to learn and start a
career in cyber security before moving
to our top three reasons to learn cyber
security here are some crucial
information for you
all as you know with relevant
certifications you can grow your cyber
security career and here we are to help
you with that
you can check out Simply learns cyber
security expert Masters program to equip
you with the necessary skills to become
an expert in this rapidly growing
domain training for highly short after
certifications like CompTIA Security
Plus CH cism and cissp is at the
Forefront of this course preparing you
for the industry's best jobs so what are
you waiting for get certified with
simply loan and grow your career in
cyber security
today so our third reason to learn cyber
security is because of the plenty of job
opportunities it offers according to the
US Bureau of Labor Statistics the
employment of information security
analysts is projected to grow 33% from
2020 to 2030 much faster than the
average for all
occupations with the world turning
digital there is a dire need for
companies to hire cyber Security Experts
who can protect and Safeguard sensitive
data as firms work to improve their
cyber security structure they are also
hiring several cyber Security Experts to
design Implement and maintain the Cyber
Security
Solutions cyber security jobs are not
limited to the it domain many security
positions are found at companies outside
of it including Industries like Media
Sports or Finance to name a few this
emphasizes on the fact that a cyber
security expert is exposed to several
job opportunities from different types
of companies across the
globe our second reason for you to learn
cyber security is the good salary
package it
offers salaries play a crucial part in
any job that you undertake isn't it
every individual likes to get duly
rewarded for their work and cyber
security is one such domain that
provides fat
paychecks cyber Security Experts are the
individuals who have come to the rescue
with the unprecedented rise in cyber
crimes across the world organizations
are willing to pay Skyhigh salaries for
these cyber security exports there is a
lack of skilled cyber Security
Professionals and this is another reason
cyber Security Experts are paid
well the salaries of cyber Security
Professionals are still expected to grow
in the coming times owing to the high
demand salaries in cyber security have a
high growth potential and if you are a
skilled cyber security professional you
can always negotiate your Sal
finally a top reason to learn cyber
security is that you will have a job
that never gets boring and a domain that
offers unlimited potential for personal
growth several times individuals find
themselves lost in their career due to
lack of challenges due to their mundane
work and also due to stagnation at work
these reasons play a major role when it
comes to a professional quitting their
job however a job role in cyber security
tackles these reasons to an extent and
that is why we have this reason at
number one cyber security is a domain
that is constantly evolving and so are
the nature of cyber attacks hackers are
always trying to develop new methods to
get to your data they develop new
exploits regularly and hence as a cyber
security professional you will face
interesting challenges to find Optimal
Solutions for new exploits you will have
new puzzles to solve a cyber security
career is not going to be
stale along with failures you will also
be exposed to new and interesting
discoveries to keep yourself updated in
this field and to tackle cyber attacks
you should be in a position to outsmart
the hackers being in the field of cyber
security allows you to constantly
upskill and enhance your knowledge and
experience it also ensures that your
Learning Journey will never stop with
the world turning virtual cyber attacks
are constantly flooding new headlines
Co 19 accelerated the current digital
transformation and the year 2020
witnessed several data breaches since
technology has become more intertwined
with our daily lives it is no surprise
that the need for skilled cyber Security
Professionals is increasing on that note
hey everyone welcome yet to another
exciting video by simply learn which
will take you through the top cyber
security career options available today
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit this subscribe button and that
Bell icon for interesting Tech videos
every day there is a significant lack of
skilled cyber security professionals who
can tackle the cyber security challenges
faced daily hence a career in cyber
security is demanding and equally
rewarding finding the right career path
in the cyber security industry isn't
always easy here we are here to help you
with that there are a few prerequisites
for a career in cyber security the basic
one being a bachelor's degree in a
subject where relating to cyber security
however if you don't have a relevant
degree you can always take up relevant
cyber security certifications and kick
start your cyber security Journey a few
other skills like networking knowledge
of operating systems and Cloud security
are required to start and grow your
cyber security career you can check out
our video on the top five cyber security
skills to know more cyber security jobs
vary from entry level to Executive
management and everything in between
there are several cyber security PS
available today it is best if you start
with entry level and then move on to the
next level with the help of
certifications and relevant experience
here let us have a look at the top five
cyber security job roles today the first
job roll is that of a network engineer
Network Engineers construct and
administer a company's computer networks
they are responsible for installing
configuring and supporting Network
equipment they also configure and
maintain firewalls switches and routers
this entrylevel cyber security job can
help you start your journey to become an
ethical hacker the annual average salary
of a network engineer in the US is
$85,900 and in India it is around
510,000
rupees second on our list is information
security analyst as an information
security analyst your primary duty is to
protect sensitive information
information security analysts create and
Implement plans for preventing cyber
attacks they monitor data access and
ensure compliance with policies
depending on the Cyber threat they
decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further in the US an
information security analyst earns
$89,100
annually and in India they earn
64275 rupees third on our list is
ethical hacker they're also known as
penetration testers they are Network
Security Consultants who identify and
exploit system vulnerabilities just like
how a hacker would do they probe and
test the network using various
penetration tools and software they also
design new penetration tools and
document the test results in the US a
certified ethical hacker earns around
$93,000 on an annual average basis and
in India they make around 5 lakh rupees
the fourth job rle that we are going to
talk about is security architect
security Architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organization ations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks a security
architect approves the installation of
routers VPN and firewalls their duties
go beyond just architecture building and
including formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides security
architects in the US make a handsome sum
of
$124,000 a year on an average and in
India they make nearly 21 lakh 80,000
rupees
and finally fifth on our list is Chief
Information Security Officer ciso they
are senior level officers in an
organization they ensure the safety of
the information they develop Implement
and maintain information security and
risk management programs they also
interact with stakeholders and regularly
brief them with information security
concerns the average annual salary of a
chief information security officer in
the states is a whopping
$165,000 annually
and in India it is 22 L
22845 rupees several companies are
looking for skilled cyber Security
Professionals Phillips seamons Google
Microsoft and GE to name a few with
passion the right amount of experience
and relevant certifications you can grow
your cyber security career you can check
out Simply learn cyber security expert
Masters program to equip you with the
necessary skills needed to become an
expert in this rapidly growing domain
this course will help you learn various
methods as to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more according to cyber crime magazine
by cyber security Ventures globally
there would be nearly 3.5 million
unfilled cyber security jobs by 2021 and
the number of Internet users will hit a
whopping 6 billion by
2022 these numbers speak volumes and
this shows the growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals across the
globe now that you know the high demand
for cyber Security Professionals let us
help you start your cyber security
career by bagging the right skill
set many of you out there might be
waiting to become a cyber security
professional but are unsure of how to go
about it and what skills you would need
to get a cyber security job not to worry
we are here to help you with that after
extensive research we have come up with
the top five skills at will help you get
into the field of cyber security let's
have a look at these skills
individually first we have networking
and system administration the number one
skill you need to have to enter the
field of cyber security is computer
networking networking is the backbone of
the internet it is imperative that you
have an in-depth understanding of
networking to start a career in cyber
security a network is a group of
interconnected devices and networking is
the lot of understanding how data is
sent transmitted and received amongst
these
devices you need to know various routing
protocols the tcpip and OSI models
govern networking The OSI model is
comparatively newer basically in these
models all the protocols are grouped
into layers and work together to help
you receive data on your device sent
from a server learning networking will
help you understand the technical
aspects of data transmission which will
help you secure your data you can take
up networking certifications like
Security Plus and Cisco CCNA to gain a
strong networking Foundation another
skill that we beneficial for you is to
Master System
Administration if you think about it all
of us are CIS admins at some
level system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features and settings
and play around a bit carry out a trial
and error method and give yourself small
tasks like recovering deleted files or
monitoring old viruses on a VM explore
new techniques put them into use and
expand your
knowledge let us now move on to our
second skill knowledge of operating
systems and virtual
machines to become a cyber security
professional you need to have a strong
knowledge of operating environments such
as Windows Linux and Mac OS cyber
Security Professionals largely use Linux
and it comes with several tools to learn
operating systems go ahead and set up
and use Virtual machines that is VMS and
play around with them this will help you
gain hands-on experience as a cyber
security expert you should be
comfortable working on any OS WMS allow
you to train and research in an isolated
environment and help you maximize your
skills the next point to remember is to
know Ki Linux it is the most widely
known Linux distribution for ethical
hacking and penetration
testing it comes with with several
hundred tools related to penetration
testing malware analysis security
research computer forensics and so on
Kali contains several projects and you
can learn a lot another good thing about
Kali is that it is free to use so what
are you waiting for download and start
right away remember that Linux is the
backbone of cyber security and a
commonly asked topic for cyber security
interviews especially for pentesting
roles moving on to our third thir skill
our third skill is network security
control it is another basic skill that
every cyber security professional should
have network security control refers to
the different measures which are
employed to enhance the security of a
network it is simple you can only
Safeguard your network if you know how
it works how routers firewalls and other
devices work a firewall is a hardware or
software that blocks incoming or
outgoing traffic from the internet to
your computer firewalls are required to
secure a network as a cyber security
expert you must be able to leverage a
firewall to filter and prevent
unauthorized traffic onto the network in
addition to that as a cyber security
expert you must know about intrusion
detection systems intrusion prevention
systems virtual private networks and
remote
access an intrusion detection system IDs
is designed to detect unauthorized
access to a system it is used together
with a firewall and a router
you should be able to operate the IDS
and recognize any security policy
violations and malicious traffic on the
network as many of you may have used a
VPN is a connection between a VPN server
and a VPN client it is a secure tunnel
across the
internet moving on next up we have an
interesting skill any idea what that is
if yes boss and leave a comment as to
what you think the next skill will be if
getting your learning started is half
the batt
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know
more and before we jump into this skill
if you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up fourth skill
on our list is
coding so you might be wondering if
coding is really required to become a
cyber security professional well it is
true that not all cyber Security
Professionals have or need coding
skills however having zero coding
knowledge May limit your opportunities
in the future knowing a couple of
programming languages will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking
techniques so as seen on your screens
these are the best programming languages
to learn to make your cyber security
career
worthwhile we have C and C++ the C
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems C and C++ are
low-level programming languages that you
need to know as a cyber security
professional on the other hand python is
a highlevel programming language that is
becoming popular among cyber Security
Experts today knowing python will give
you an upper hand in your career it will
help you identify and fix
vulnerabilities JavaScript is another
highlevel programming language that adds
interactivity to web pages a good
advantage of knowing JavaScript is that
you can prevent cross-side scripting
attacks from occurring as in these
attacks the attacker plants malicious
code in a web application speaking of
PHP because most of the websites are
created using PHP learning it will help
you defend against
Intruders similarly HTML is another
language cyber Security Professionals
should understand as most websites use
it and it is one of the easiest
languages to learn another programming
language that you can use is goang it is
great for cryptography you can solve
various cyber security problems with it
then we have SQL that is stru query
language attackers use this language to
damage the stored data one such example
is the SQL injection attack hence having
a good understanding of SQL will be
highly beneficial another Point we'd
like to highlight is to have knowledge
of Assembly Language this will help you
become a cyber security engineer
assembly will help you understand how
malware functions and thereby help you
defend against it in the cyber security
domain you can't just lock into a single
language and hence it is advised that
you're acquainted with with a couple of
them you can also do a crash course for
these languages and learn them hence
determine the best programming language
for your cyber security role and get
familiar with the
basics moving on our fifth skill on the
list is cloud security there is a
growing demand for cyber Security
Professionals with Cloud security skills
in the coming
years companies are on the lookout for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public and hybrid Cloud
platforms such as Amazon web services
and aure
more organizations look to Cloud
infrastructure to store data and run
applications this includes the
implementation of policies and
technologies that protect cloud-based
systems and
devices just like application
development security Cloud security also
involves building secure systems from
the start companies want professionals
who can manage the cloud security tools
to identify and prevent any Cloud
breaches people with experience and
knowledge in managing big platforms such
as micro Microsoft Azure AWS and the gcp
are in high demand now that we have seen
the top five cyber security skills let
us go through a set of additional skills
that can help you get into the cyber
security field remember that to become a
successful cyber security expert you
must process a rich and diverse skill
set so in a list of additional skills
first we have risk
analysis identifying risks even before
their arrival is a great skill cyber
Security Professionals are required to
identify manage and mitigate risks risk
management and mitigation is a skill set
that is going to be highly in demand in
the coming
years next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized taxes here in demand
skills are authentication authorization
malware analysis and data
recovery next on our list is security
incident handling and
response as a cyber security expert you
must be prepared to handle any any
forthcoming threat of violating an
organization security policy by
following an updated incident response
plan your team can proactively protect
your data and minimize the
damages in security Incident Management
you are required to identify manage
record and analyze security threats in
real time a security incident can be an
active threat or a successful compromise
of data or an attempted intrusion it can
also be incidents like dos attacks
fishing APS Ransom where many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and event management S tools
and
services moving on we have security
audit security auditing is an internal
check that is carried out to find flaws
in the organization's information system
you must be able to conduct a review of
the organization's adherence to
regulatory guidelines security audit and
compliance knowledge are very very
crucial as any Mysteria of Regulatory
Compliance could lead to Hefty penalties
soon organizations will need people who
are more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations if you are good at
paperwork you can capitalize on this
skill companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to file and
which security protocols to use to
comply with the
regulations finally we have laws and
regulations and often overlooked cyber
security aspect there are several cyber
security laws and regulations and if you
break these laws intentionally or not it
doesn't matter as you will still be
charged these laws Define how you can
use the internet and it also defines how
people can be protected from becoming
the victims of cyber crimes knowing
these laws and regulations and following
the best practice will make you ethical
at your job and this will in turn be
good for your organization so those were
our list of additional skills apart from
these make sure you stay updated with
new hacks and learn new tools as cyber
security is ever evolved in another
important skill apart from these
technical skills is your soft skills
having a set of good soft skills will
help you bag your dream job we have a
video on the top five soft skills that
will help you grow in your career do
watch that and incorporate those skills
as
well when it comes to web app hacking It
generally refers to the exploitation of
applications by HTTP which can be done
by manipulating the applications via its
graphical user interface this is done by
tampering with the uniform resource
identifier also known as a URI or
tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be
compromised anyone who uses a computer
connected to the internet is susceptible
to the threats that computer hackers and
online Predators post these online vain
typically use fishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to your
computer and compromise your computer
security computer hackers can also try
to access your computer and private
information directly if you're not
protected by a firewall they can monitor
your conversations or produse the back
end of your personal website usually
disguised with a bogus identity
Predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive person and financial
information a web server which can be
referred to as the hardware the computer
or the software which helps to deliver
content that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertext transfer protocol or
HTTP so hackers attack the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like DS
attacks Sy YN flooding ping flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other
end although wireless networks offer
great flexibility they have their own
security problems a hacker can sniff the
network packets without having to be in
the same building where the network is
located as wireless networks communicate
through radio waves a hacker can easily
sniff the network from a nearby location
most attackers use Network sniffing to
find the SSID and hack a wireless
network an attacker can attack a network
from a distance and therefore it is
sometimes difficult to collect evidence
against the main
hacker social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer systems now that
we learn about the different types of
tools that can be used when conducting
an ethical hacking audit let's learn
about some potential benefits of such
campaigns and why organizations prefer
to pay for such
audits being able to identify defects
from an attacker's perspective is
game-changing since it displays all the
potential Avenues of a possible hack one
can only prepare for the known
vulnerabilities as a defensive
specialist but proactively trying to
breach a network or device can make
hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for this
kind of unpredictability goes a long way
in securing a network against malicious
actors
another advantage of hiring ethical
hackers is the ability to preemptively
fix possible weak points in a company's
Network infrastructure as seen on many
occasions a real breach will cause loss
of data and irreparable damage to the
foundation of an
organization being able to gauge such
shortcomings before they become public
and can be used exploited is a benefit
most organizations make use
of this is not to imply that such
security order are only beneficial to
the organization paying for it when
coming across companies that provide
certain Services a reliable third party
security audit goes a long way in
instilling trust and confidence over
their craft if the ethical hackers
cannot find any major vulnerabilities
that can be leveraged by hackers it just
accentuates the technical brillance of
the organization and its Engineers
thereby increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount with the next
generation of Internet exchanges focused
on maximum privacy and security a
variety of ways have been enforced to
maintain them as such censorship has
been shifted from the streets to the
digital domain forces the standard
citizen to derive alternative ways to
maintain anonymity a major weapon in
this battle for privacy and security is
the to browser an independent browser
meant to browse the internet while
relaying information through the Tor
Network it serves as a meaningful
alternative to the standard internet
browsing habits to better understand the
purpose of this browser and such we must
learn about the work of the T Network
featuring its own routing protocol the
to browser is an easy way to maintain
anonymity while browsing without
emptying On's wallet let's take a look
at the topics to be covered
today we start at the explanation of
what is the T Network and its
significance in the working of the to
browser we take a look at the onion
routing protocol and how it transmits
the data from the client devices to the
Tor directories in order to circumvent
government
censorship moving on we learn a few
features of the to browser and the
distinct advantages the to network
provides next we learn the difference
between using a VPN and a t to anonymize
internet usage and finally we have a
live demonstration of the T browser
anonymization features in
action let's move on to learning about
the T
Network T short for the onion router
it's an open-source privacy Network that
permits users to browse the web
anonymously the tour was initially
developed and solely used by the US Navy
to protect sensitive government
Communications before the network was
made publicly available the digital era
has disrupted the traditional way of
doing things in every sector of the
economy the rapid Rising development and
innovation of digital products has given
way to frequent data breaches and cyber
thefts in response consumers are
increasingly opting for products that
offer data privacy and cyber security
Tor is one such such underground Network
that was implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the to
network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security
concerns the T Network intercepts the
traffic from your browser and bounces a
user's request of a random number of
other user IP addresses then the data is
passed to the user request Final
Destination these random users are
volunteer devices which are called as
nodes or relays the T Network disguises
your identity by encrypting the traffic
and moving it across different T relays
within the network the T Network uses an
onion routing technique for transmitting
data hence the original name of onion
router to operate within the T Network a
user has to install the T browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the T
Network it has its own feature set which
we will be covering over later in this
video
as we discussed already the data passing
through the to network must follow a
unique protocol known as The Onion
routing protocol let us learn more about
its unique
characteristics in our normal Network
usage the data is transmitted directly
the sender has data package to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind however
since the data can easily be captured
while being transmitted the the security
of this exchange is not very reliable
moreover it becomes very easy to trace
the origin of such requests on many
occasions websites with questionable and
controversial content are blocked from
the ISP this is possible since the ISP
is able to detect and spy on user
information passing through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
Network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the
Internet however in the onion routing
protocol things take a longer route we
have a sender with the to browser
installed on the client system the
network sends the information to node
one's IP address which encrypts the
information and passes it on to node 2's
address which performs another
encryption and passes it on to node 3
address this is the last address which
is also known as the exit node this last
node decrypts the encrypted data and
finally relays the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user the to network
obfuscates user IP addresses from
unwanted surveillance by keeping the
users's request untraceable with
multiple servers touching the data it
makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious attackers
now that we understand the way T Works
let us learn more about the T
browser the to browser was developed by
a nonprofit organization as a part of
the Tor project in 2008 and its first
public release was announced the to
browser is a browser Fork from the
popular Firefox that anonymizes your web
traffic using the to network if you're
investigating a competitor researching
an opposing litigant in a legal dispute
or just think it's creepy for your ISP
or the government to know what websites
you visit the to browser might be the
right
solution before the toall browser were
developed using that Network to maintain
anonymity was a huge task for everyday
consumers starting from the setup to the
usage the entire process demanded a lot
of knowledge and practice the to browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers in tour and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange a major feature of the T
browser is the ability to delete all
browser history cookies and tracking
data the moment it is closed every new
launch of the browser opens an empty
slate having a usage habits from being
tracked and singled out a major feature
that is the highlight of the Tor Network
is the availability of onion links only
a small portion of the worldwide web is
available to the general public we have
the Deep Web that contains links that
are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
to browser gives you access to these
onion websites which are only available
within the T Network onion is a special
used top level domain which designates
an anonymous onion service which is also
known as a hidden service similar to The
Links of the Deep Web these onion links
provide services like online shopping
cryptocurrency and many other products
not available in the consumer Internet
space often being considered as a Haven
for illegal activities and sales onion
links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by
authorities browsing the web over T is
slower than the clear net due to the
multiple layers of
encryption some web services also block
to users to browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously journalist
and dissidents around the world have
embraced t as a Cornerstone of democracy
and researchers are hard at work at
improving SS anonymity
properties let us take a look at some of
the advantages of using the T browser
over standard web
browsers the highlight of using the T
browser is to maintain anonymity over
the Internet the cause for such requests
can differ from person to person but all
of these concern are answered by the to
network routing the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the ISP to keep a
track of usage
data
the entire to project is designed to be
completely free and open source allowing
the code for the browser to be inspected
and audited by Third parties helps in
the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile
devices a number of websites are blocked
by governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via T usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the T browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive
circumstances many people believe that a
VPN offers the same benefits as the top
browser let's put both of them to the
test and see the differences between
them coming to the first point of
difference T is completely free and open
source all of the code for the browser
and the network can be audited and has
been cleared for security concerns when
it comes to VPN there are many different
brands which have open-source clients
but the same cannot be said for their
counterparts some have partly open
source while some have completely locked
up their code so that they cannot be
stolen
further moving on T has multiple relay
points in his data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different IP nodes that
number can increase but it'll always be
more than two once the data is passed
from the sender it goes through all of
those relay points while in the case of
a VPN the connection is made from the
client device to the VPN server and then
to the requested destination there is no
other IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one: one
between the client and a
VPN as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes
through similarly the multi-layer
encryption of to is consistent if you
use T browser every single request
passes through the same layer of
encryption and follows the same routing
protocol in the case of a VPN different
companies offer different levels of
encryption some have multihop some
prefer a single onetoone connection and
these kind of differences make the
choice much more
variable finally the nodes and relays
being used in the Tor Network are
volunteer there is no company holding
over them so jurisdiction becomes
relatively straightforward when in the
case of VPN many such VPN are hosted by
adware companies or are being monitored
by Central governments to note the usage
information now that we have a better
understanding of the Tor Browser and its
routing let us take a look at how the T
browser can anonymize and protect our
internet
usage on opening up the T browser for
the first time this is the page that
you're going to be welcomed with you
have the option of connecting to the to
network before we start our
browsing so let's press
connect and we can see that it is
connected coming to the
anonymization let's check my current
location on Google
Chrome currently is showing as Navi
Mumbai in
Maharashtra if you check the same link
on the tour browser we should get a
different
address now every link that we open in
the tour browser will be little delayed
and the speed will be hampered because
of the multiple layers of encryption
like we discussed now as you can
see it's showing a German IP and the
state of
Bavaria this is how the anonymization
works there is no VPN configured there
is no proxy attached it's straight up
the out of the box settings that come
inbuilt with the tour browser similarly
we have an option of cleaning up the
data let's say if you want to refresh
your location and you want to use a
different ID for the next browsing
session if you just restart it once and
we can have to check it
again we should be seeing a different
country this
time as you can see we have Netherlands
right now
so this is how you can keep refreshing
your address you can keep refreshing
your host location so that you cannot be
tracked when in browsing the internet
like we discussed we have some onion
links that can only be used on the tour
Network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the Google Chrome
browser but once we copy these over to
the Tor
Browser as you can see we have opened
the hidden wiki which is available only
on the tour Network this is kind of an
alternative Wikipedia website where we
can find articles to read and more
information to learn similarly we have
another onion link over
here which is once again available only
for the toall
browser now these kind of delays are
expected but they are a valid compromise
because they maintain the anonymity that
many people desire similarly we have
found a hidden wallet which is a
cryptocurrency wallet which is
specifically for dark web
members this operates over the toor
network and this is used by mostly
journalists and people who want to
anonymize their internet transactions
when it comes to dealing
money all of the transactions that occur
over the Tor Network are almost
impossible to track therefore these kind
of cryptocurrency wallets are very big
on the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available malware is a malicious
software that is programmed to cause
damage to a computer system Network and
Hardware devices many malicious programs
like prion viruses bombs and Bots which
cause damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive
data let's take a look at the
introduction for two different types of
malware virus
Androgen firstly let's take a look what
exactly is a virus
program a computer virus is a type of
malicious program that on execution
replicates itself they get attached to
different files and programs which are
termed as host programs by inserting
their code if the attachment succeed
seeds the targeted program is termed as
infected with a computer virus now let's
take a look at the Trojan Horse Trojan
Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms a system on installation they
hide within the attachments and emails
then transfer from one system to another
they create back doors into a system to
allow the cyper criminal to steal our
information let's take a look how they
function after getting install into our
system firstly we have virus programs
the computer virus must contain two
parts to infect the system first is a
search routine which locates new files
and data that is to be infected by the
virus program and the second part is
known as the copy routine which is
necessary for the program to copy itself
into the targeted file which is located
by the search routine now let's take a
look at the troan house functioning
for troan horses entry way into our
system is through emails that may look
legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the tro
program gets installed and infects the
system they also infect the system on
the execution of infected application or
the executable file and attacks the
system now that we understand what virus
and rions are let's understand different
types of virus and rosion
let's take a look at different types of
viruses the first one is known as the
boot sector virus this type of virus
damages the booting section of the
system by infecting the master bot
record which is also known as MBR this
damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the
system then we have the macro virus
microvirus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale and lastly we have the
direct action
virus this type of virus gets attached
to executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed they exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus let's take a look
at different types of
troan the first type of troan is the
back door troan they are designed to
create a back door in the system on
execution of an infected program they
provide remote access of a system to the
hacker this way the Cyber criminal can
steal our system data and may use it for
illegal activities next we have cricu
verion they enter the system by clicking
the random popups which we come across
on the internet they ATT the user to
give their personal details for
different transactions or
schemes which may provide remote access
of a system to the Cyber
criminal and the last troan type is
Ransom troan this type of troan program
after entering the system blocks the
user from accessing its own system and
also affects the system
functioning the Cyber criminal demands a
ransom from the targeted user for the
removal of the Trojan program from the
device now that we understand some
details regarding viruses and Trojan
let's solve a
question the question is Jake was denied
access to his system and he wasn't able
to control the data and information in
his
system now the actual question is what
could be the reason behind this system's
problem option a macr virus option b
Ransom troan option C backd troan give
your answers in in the comment
section now let's understand how to
detect the activity of viruses and troan
in our
system to detect virus or Troon activity
in our system we can refer to the
following points for viruses we have
slowing down of the system and frequent
application freeze shows that the
infection of the virus is present in the
system then we have the viruses can also
steal sensitive data including passwords
Account Details
which may lead to unexpected log out
from the accounts or Corruption of the
sensitive data and lastly we have
frequent system crashes due to virus
infection which damages the operating
system for Trojan we have frequent
system crashes and system also faces
slow reaction time then we have there
are more random popups from the system
which may indicate prion activity and
lastly we have modification in the
system applic application and change of
the desktop appearance can be also due
to the infection of a troan
program next let's take a look at a
famous Cyber attack for virus and a
trojan
horse for virus we have the maom virus
which was identified in the year 2004
which affected over 50 million systems
by creating a network of sending spam
emails which was to gain back door
access into our systems
next for the troan horse we have the
emot troan program which is a
specifically designed for financial
theft and for stealing Bank related
information next we have few points for
how to prevent virus entry or Tran
attack for a
system the most basic way of virus
protection is to using antivirus and due
regular viruses SC this will prevent
virus entry in the system and also
having more than one antivirus virus
provides budge better
protection then avoid visiting
uncertified websites can also prevent
virus entry into our
system then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry for rosion we have using
certified softwares from legal sites to
prevent any troen activity in our
system and also avoid clicking random
popups that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and Fireballs
for protection against troan horses is a
good
habit now that we have reached the end
of the video Let's Take a look what we
learned for the first part we saw the
main objective of the virus is to harm
the data and information in a system
whereas for the troan we have stealing
of the data files and information effect
of viruses is more drastic in comp
comparison to the Trojan
horses then we have viruses which are
non- remote programs whereas trojen
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files where as
Trojan does not have the replication
ability so let's begin with what is SQL
injection as the name suggest SQL
injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL state M so SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with a database now normally
this attack is targeted towards a
database to extract uh the data that is
stored within however the vulnerability
does not lie in the database itself the
vulnerability will always lie in the
application it is the developers
prerogative of how to develop the
application how to configure it to
prevent SQL injection queries from
happening a database is created to
answer questions and if a question is
asked it is supposed to answer it
database needs to be configured for some
amount of security but the vulnerability
the flaw here for SQL injection will
always lie in the application itself it
is how the application interacts with
the database that needs to be modified
that needs to be maintained by the
developer rather than just configuring
the database itself so the attacker at
this point in time when they send a
query to the application will form a
malformed query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language and if
that operator is passed through the
application to the database then the
database uh basically gets cracked or
does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in so this
character needs to be filtered at the
application Level itself now let's look
at a quick demo so what we have done
here is I have this virtual machine
called oasp broken web applications
virtual machine version 1.2 I'm going to
power this
on till this PO is on I'm going to show
you where we can download this uh
utility from so you can just look for
oasp broken web application project
download you'll find it on Source
for.net click on the
link you can download the broken web
appc ation project from here this is a
1.9gb download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or V Oracle
virtual box now this is an application
that has been developed by oasp which
stands for open web application security
project which is a not for-profit
organization and uh periodically uh
releases the most top 10 risks that an
application uh will face for that
particular
year so they have given a web
application uh with inbuilt
vulnerabilities for professionals like
us to practice upon to develop a our
skills upon because doing this in the
real world is illegal I cannot go onto a
website to demonstrate how a SQL
injection attack Works uh neither should
you try your hands on it till you become
very well rehearsed with it so till to
up upgrade your skills to upskill
yourself please download this machine
hosted in a VM Workstation or Oracle
virtual box and you can uh then try your
skills on it right so uh just going back
to the browser here if I open up uh a
new tab you'll see that this machine has
booted up and has an IP address called
71. 132 so if I just go on to that IP
address and I type in 192 168
7132 and you'll see the OAS broken web
application project and there are lot of
training application ations realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications inbuilt over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the ovas mutil over here uh
this gives you the uh o top 10 risks for
2010 2013 2017 is the latest one so far
uh but the difference between 2013 and
2017 is that some of these have changed
but not all of them uh the order has
changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection uh attacks blind
SQL injection and then there is a tool
called SQL map which is available freely
on your Linux machines Ki Linux or parro
Linux whichever you want to use
uh for your practice targets and so on
so forth so if I just take you here for
bypass
authentication and this is a regular
login page that an application may have
right you look at a username you look at
password you type that in and you log in
so let's say I don't know a password
here I'm just going to type in the
username test password is
pswd I try to log in and it shows me
that the account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work the I
did try type in a username and password
it wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to uh dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single
quote or
1 equals 1 space hyphen hyphen space and
I'm going to click on login now right
now I'm not logged in at all and we
tried our username and password and we
weren't able to log in so now if I log
in you will see that it give me a status
update saying the user has been
authenticated and I'm logged in as admin
got root so that is what the SQL queries
can achieve I'm going to log out right
now and uh we're going to look at the
basics of SQL injection so looking at
that small demo looking now let's look
at what types of SQL injections are
available so the first is inband SQL
injection the there are two subtypes
within inband error based injection
attack and a union based injection
attack the second type is blind SQL
injection attack where there's a Boolean
based and a Time based attack and the
third one is out of bound SQL injection
attack now what is inband SQL injection
attack inband is where we either
attempting the error based or the union
based what is error based uh we send a
query to the database we craft a query
to the database and uh it generates an
error M message and it dumps the error
message right in front of us on the
screen that uh makes us realize that
there is a flaw and there there is some
information that is dumped on the screen
which we can then further utilize to
craft our further queries as we go ahead
whereas Union base is the it is where we
combine multiple statements at the same
time so if you look at the URL earlier
in the URL uh you would see a large
structure in that URL uh we can try to
add more two or more statements within
the URL itself to combine them and then
confuse the database into executing both
the statements together and giving a
data dump at the same time right so what
would a error based uh SQL injection
look like if if I go back to the same
database uh which is here right and if
you remember in the username we gave it
a single quote or 1 equals 1 space
hyphen hyphen space we gave it the
condition right so basically what it did
was this a single code is an operator
that goes to the database selects the
default uh table uh in the user tables
in this database column and then
Compares it to the condition that is
given so the condition that we gave was
one equals 1 which is always true so
what it did was it selected the default
uh user table that was available in the
database and instead of comparing it to
a password it compared it to the
condition so if I give it 1 equals 2
where the condition is false and if I
log in you will see that the account
doesn't exist comes back again because
the condition was false and instead of
comparing the user account to the
password it basically uh compared the
user account to the condition so if I
give it a single quote or 1 equal 1
hyphen hyphen space uh and log in you
can see that this is a correct condition
and thus we are able to log in now
before we even go to that extent if I
just forget the condition over here and
I just give it a single code the
operator and I send this operator to the
database and I click on login you will
see that it generates an error which is
right on top and it tells us the line
the uh file where the error happened and
you can see it happened in the MySQL
handler. PHP file right and then it give
us the message you have an error in your
cql syntax check the manual that
corresponds to your MySQL server version
for the right syntax to use now why
would a hacker want to do this in the
first place because there are different
types of databases so there is a MySQL
Ms SQL or Microsoft SQL Oracle SQL IBM
db2 all of these are variations of the
SQL database uh they use the SQL
language however every database has its
own Command right they they have their
own syntax they have their own uh
specific commands that are utilized for
the database so in this scenario the
hacker wants to identify what database
is being currently utiliz so they can
craft those particular queries so now
with this injection with just me sending
the quote and the error getting
generated I now come to know that we are
using a MySQL server and the version of
that server is
5173 and uh the rest of the information
about uh where the handlers are located
and so on so forth right this gives the
information to the hacker of how they
want to proceed next what kind of
queries they want to create what kind of
syntax they want to utilize so error
based attack is where you generate these
kind of Errors uh and you get this
information the union base is where you
craft your queries within the URL or you
can try to combine multiple statements
within the input fields and try to
generate a response from that then we
come to Boolean based SQL injection uh
sends a SQL query to the database which
forces the application to return a
different result depending on whether
the query returns a true or a false
result so basically if the input is
false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false uh
there's one input that is false the
other input that is true input B the
output would be true and so on so forth
right so depending on the result from
the inputs the attackable will come to
know which input is true with this he
can then access the database of the
website so you're trying to figure out
by sending out multiple inputs uh and
then analyzing the output to see what
exactly uh which command exactly worked
what was the resultant output of that
command thus from this kind of an
information the hacker can infer their
next step forward then you have time
based SQL injections uh now there are
times when a database administrator an
application administrator has done some
security configuration and does have
disabled verbos error messages now what
is a verbos error message the error
message that we saw right here is a
verbos error message that means that the
message gives out details the message
gives out details about what the
database is the version and whatnot so
if they have sanitized these
errors and you no longer can generate
these errors and thus you cannot figure
out what database is then what do you do
right for example if I just take you to
Simply
learn
and
take you to a URL that is supposedly not
accessible you can see that it gives a
generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbose error that we saw
here so this gives us a detail error of
what went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
uh where the query went wrong and etc
etc etc whereas on this side where
there's some there's a lot of security
that goes in here so you can see that it
doesn't generate a error it just get a
generic page in front of you so in that
case what does a hacker do so the hacker
then injects a
time-based uh query in the URL which
allows us to verify whether the command
is being executed or not so uh we put in
a time
weit let's say 10 seconds of time weit
so if we the moment we inject the query
if the query times for 10 seconds and
then gets executed that means that the
SQL injection is possible however if we
inject the query and uh it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled on the database management
system that is being used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error
uh by the database administrator where
you have enabled functions and not
sanitized them so you have not done in
access controls properly you have not
given account control so queries should
never be executed at an administrative
level they should always be uh executed
at a user level with minimum privileges
that are required for that query to be
executed now if you're allowing these
kind of functions to be uh to be enabled
at the dbms and there's an
administrative account that can have
access to them at that point in time an
outof bound injection attack is possible
so let's look at how a website works
right uh how SQL works on a website now
the website is constructed of HTML
hypertex markup language uh which would
include javascripting for functionality
cascading stylesheet for the mapping of
the website right and then reactjs and
whatnot uh for further functionality now
when we send a query to the website it
is normally using the HTTP protocol or
https protocol when the query reaches
the application the application would
then go ahead and generate the SQL query
uh at the client side you'll have uh all
these scripting languages coming in uh
on the front end uh that we can utilize
to craft queries and then send them
across at the server side you'll have uh
databases like Oracle MySQL Ms SQL and
so on so forth that will then execute
those qu queries right so just to give
you an example if I use a tool called
Postman what we generally do uh when we
craft a query is we send out a uh get
request to the website and then we
receive a response from the site uh with
the HTML code and everything so this is
a tool that is utilized by software
testers to test the responses that
you're going to get from various
websites so as on the left hand side you
can see I've uh used it on quite a bit
uh here we have a example for gmail.com
so let's continue with that so this is a
get request being sent to Gmail the
moment I send it it's going to create an
HTTP request and send it across the
response that I get is this this is the
HTML code for
gmail.com right these are the cookies uh
these are the headers uh that include
information so you can see this is a
text HTML character set utilized is
utf8 and the conf configuration uh that
has been done with the application right
so this is where uh everything comes in
this is the cookie that has been sent
with that particular uh request that I
had sent out now if you Analyze This
query right so when we went onto this
application and I typed in that single
quote and we generated this error right
uh you can see that the application
converted this into a SQL query so the
query was select username from accounts
where the username in quotes single
quotes and we use the quote right the
single quote right there so uh that's
where we use that operator and that's
where the exception error occurred so
these are the kind of queries that are
structured by the application and then
taken on to the database for execution
when we type in uh it is a HTTP get
request with the username and password
within that query uh that is sent to the
application the application converts it
into a SQL query sends it to the
database and the database responds with
the appropriate response so how do we
prevent SQL injection in the first place
use prepared statement and parameterized
queries uh these statements make sure
that the parameters passed into SQL
statements are treated in a safe manner
so for example we saw that the single
code was an operator this shouldn't be
allowed to be utilized in the first
place right so here what we are doing
here is a secure way of running a SQL
query in the jdbc using a parameterized
statement Define which user we want to
find so there's a string the email comes
in connection to the database we are
going to figure out how the connection
is going to be passed how it is going to
be created construct the SQL statement
we want to run specifying the parameter
right so we Define how is it going to be
uh created what is going to be created
what can be passed to the database and
what should not be passed to the
database so that is one way of uh
utilizing prepared statements and
parameterized queries then we have
object relational mapping most
development uh teams prefer to use OB
object relational mapping Frameworks to
make the translation of SQL results set
into code objects more seamless so this
is an example of object relational
mapping uh where we map certain objects
and allow that to be executed and then
escaping inputs it a simple way to
protect against most squal injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions to achieve this right so you
need to be very be careful while using
Escape characters in your code base when
a SQL statement is constructed not all
injection attacks rely on abuse of code
characters so you need to know what
characters are being utilized uh in the
configuration that you have created in
the structure that you have created in
the code that you have created uh which
characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are they
feed out by the application and they
never reach the database other methods
of preventing SQL injection are uh
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use o
or some other service for a single sign
on mechanism does uh you rely on a third
party to maintain the security of
authentication and uh what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook logins
right for the Layman you normally go on
to Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you start playing
a game you're allowed to log into the
game using your Facebook credentials or
your Google credentials now that is not
just for ease of use but the game user
the developer has outsourced the
authentication mechanisms to third party
such as Facebook or Google because they
understand that that authentication
mechanism is as safe as can be Facebook
and Google are wealthy organizations uh
hire a lot of Security Experts and the
development for their authentication
mechanisms is topnotch small
organization cannot spend that kind of
money on security itself right so you
use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and conf
configuring it properly uh for SQL
injection attacks is one of the sure
short method of uh mitigating or
minimizing the uh threat in the first
place so at this point in time you have
realized that the application has some V
abilities for SQL injection and instead
of recoding or restructuring the
application uh you want to take the
easier way out or the cheaper way out so
what you do is you uh you install a web
application firewall and you configure
the web application firewall to identify
malicious queries and stop them uh at
the firewall level itself so they never
reach the application and thus the
vulnerabilities on the application don't
get
executed buy better
software and keep on updating the
software so it's not necessary that once
you have a software you install it it's
going to be safe for Life new V
abilities are discovered every day every
hour and it may so happen what is secure
today maybe completely insecure tomorrow
or the day after right so you need to
keep on upgrading the software if there
are no upgrades available and the VAB
still exist you might want to migrate to
a better software and does uh ensure
that you don't get hacked right always
update and use patches organizations
keep on sending out updates and patches
as and when they are released you need
to install them to uh enhance your
security postures and then continuously
monitor SQL statements and databases use
protocol monitors uh use different
softwares use the firewalls to keep on
monitoring what kind of queries you're
uh getting and based on those queries
you want to ensure the inputs and the
queries that are creating U are not
detrimental to the health of the
software that you have simply learn
offers post graduate program in cyber
security find the complete course
details from the link in the description
box cross-site scripting from a Layman's
perspective cross-site scripting also
known as xsm is a type of code injection
attack that occurs on the client side
the attacker intends to run harmful
scripts in the victim's web browser by
embedding malicious code in a genuine
web page or online application the real
Attack takes place when the victim hits
the malicious code infected web page or
online application the web page or
application serves as a vehicle for the
malicious script to be sent to the users
browser forums message boards and online
pages that enable comments are
vulnerable vehicles that are frequently
utilized for cross scripting
assaults a web page or web application
is vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then pass this
user input in VB script ActiveX Flash
and even CSS cross-side scripting
attacks are conceivable they are
nevertheless most ous in JavaScript
going to the fact that JavaScript is
most important to most browser
experiences nowadays
the main purpose of this attack is to
steal the other users identity be it via
cookies session tokens and other
information in most of the cases this
attack is being used to steal the other
person's cookies as we know cookies help
us to log in automatically therefore
with the stolen cookies we can log in
with other identities and this is one of
the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the riskiest
attacks it can be performed with
different client side programming
languages as well
well crosss side scripting is often
compared with similar client side
attacks as client side languages are
mostly being used during this however an
xss attack is considered riskier because
of its ability to damage even less
vulnerable
Technologies most often this attack is
performed with JavaScript and HTML
JavaScript is a programming language
that runs on web pages inside your
browser the client side code adds
functionality and interactivity to the
web page and is used extensively on all
major applications and CMS platforms
unlike serers side languages such as PHP
JavaScript code runs inside your browser
and cannot impact the website for other
visitors it is sandboxed to your own
Navigator and can only perform actions
within your own browser window while
JavaScript is client site and does not
run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
aonly the manner of attack can range in
a variety of ways it can be a single
link which the user must click on to
initiate a JavaScript piece of code it
can be used to show any piece of images
that can be later used as a front end
for malicious code being installed as
malware but the majority of Internet
users unaware of how metadata works or
the ways in which web requests are
called the chances of victims clicking
on a redirecting links is far too high
cross-side scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the
client's side using a fake page or even
a form that is displayed to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim these attacks occur when the
malicious user finds the vulnerable
parts of the website and sense it as
appropriate malicious
input now that we understand the basics
of cross-side scripting let us learn
more about how this kind of attack
works in the first place we have the
website or the web browser which is used
to show content to the victim or which
is the user in our case whenever the
user wants to grab some content from the
website the website asks the data from
the server the server provides this
information to the website and the web
browser which ultimately Rees the
victim how the hacker comes into play
here it passes on certain arguments to
the web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting attack Vector means sending
and injecting malicious code or script
this attack can be performed in
different ways depending on the type of
attack the malicious script may be
reflected on the victim's browser but
stored in the database and executed
every time when the user calls the
appropriate function the main reason for
this attack is inappropriate users input
validation where the malicious input can
get into the output a malicious user can
enter a script which will be injected
onto the website's code then the browser
is not able to know if the executed code
is malicious or not therefore this
malicious script is being executed on
the victim's browser or any faked form
if that is being displayed for the users
there are many ways to trigger an xss
attack for example the execution could
be triggered automatically when the page
loads or when user hovers over specific
elements of the page like hyperlinks
potential consequences of cross-site
scripting attacks include capturing key
strokes of a user redirecting a user to
malicious websites running web browser
based exploits obtaining cookie
information of a user who is logged into
a website and many more in some cases
cross-side scripting attack leads to
complete compromise of the victim's
account attackers can trick users into
entering credentials on a fake form
which can then provide all information
to the attacker with the basic working
of a cross-side scripting attack out of
the way let us go over the different
ways hackers can leverage vulnerable web
applications to gather information and
eventually breach those
systems the prime purpose of Performing
xss attack is to steal the other
person's identity as mentioned it may be
cookies session tokens
Etc xss may also be used to display
faked Pages or forms for the victim
however this can be performed in several
ways we have a reflected attack this
attack occurs when a malicious script is
not being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected xss code is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result the attack code can be included
in the faked URL or in the HTTP
parameters it can affect the victim in
different ways by displaying faked
malicious page or by sending sending a
malicious email in a reflected
cross-side scripting example the input
of a search form is reflected on the
page to show what the search key was an
attacker May craft a URL that contains
malicious code and then spread the same
URL via email or social media a user who
clicks on this link opens the valid web
application which then runs the
malicious code in the browser this
script is not stored in the web
application and malicious code is shown
only to one user the user that opens the
link executes the stript and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app owner
itself the next variant is a stored
cross-side scripting attacks this occurs
when a malicious script is being saved
on the web server
permanently this can be considered a
riskier attack since it has leverage for
more damage in this type of attack the
malicious code or script is being saved
on the server for example in the
database of the website it is executed
every time time the users call the
appropriate
functionality this way stored accss
attack can affect many users also as the
script is being stored on the web server
it will affect the website for a longer
time in order to perform stored xss
attack the malicious scripts should be
sent through the vulnerable input form
for example can be a comment field or a
review
field this way the appropriate script
will be saved in the database and
evaluated on the page load or
appropriate function
calling in a stored xss example the
script might have been submitted via an
input field to the web server which did
not perform a sufficient validation and
stores the script permanently in the
database the consequence of this might
be that this script is now being
delivered to all users visiting the web
application and for example able to gain
access to the user session
cookies in this attack the script is
permanently St in the web app the users
visiting the app after the information
Mission retrieve the script the
malicious code then exploits the flaws
in the web application and the script
and the attack is visible on the server
side or to the app owner as
well the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks this type
of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change when
the Dom environment is being modified in
the victim's browser the client side
code executes differently in order order
to get a better understanding of how xss
stor attack is being performed Let Us
analyze the following example if there
is a website called texting.com we know
default is a parameter therefore in
order to perform xss Dom attack we
should send a script as
parameters a Dom based accss attack may
be successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client side JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree of the web page it
can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be
executed the malicious code that
exploits flaws in the browser on the
user site and the script and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app
owner by now it is clear that cross-side
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of PHS one can
Safeguard against such attacks let's go
through some of these preventive
measures like mentioned earlier excesses
attacks are sometimes difficult to
detect however this can be changed if
you get some external help a way to
prevent excesses attacks is using
automated testing tools like crash test
security suit or a kinetic security
suit still man manual testing is highly
time consuming and costly and therefore
not possible to be done for every
iteration of your web
application consequently your code
shouldn't be untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-side
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
application live version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature input fields are the most common
point of entry for xss attack script
therefore you should always screen and
validate any information input into data
fields this is particularly important if
the data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected accss
attacks validation should occur on both
the client side and server side as an
added precaution this helps validating
the data before it's being sent to the
servers and can also protect against
persistent xss scripts this can can be
accomplished using JavaScript xss
attacks only appear if any user input is
being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible if you
need to display user data restrict the
places where the user input might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the HTML body
protecting against accesses
vulnerabilities typically requires
properly escaping user provided data
that is placed on the page rather than
trying to determine if the data is user
provided and could be compromised we
should always play it safe and Escape
data whether it is user provided or not
unfortunately because there are many
different rules for escaping you still
must choose the proper type of escaping
before settling on a final
code encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context sometimes
you'll need to apply multiple layers of
encoding in the correct order for
example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First
Unicode Escape the input and then HTML
encoded content security policy or CSP
is a computer security standard
introduced to prevent cross-site
scripting clickjacking and other code
injection attacks resulting from the
execution of malicious content in The
Trusted web page context it is a
candidate recommendations of the w3c
working group on web application
security it's widely supported by modern
web browsers and provides a standard
method for web website owners to declare
approved origins of content that browser
should be allowed to load on that
website HTTP only is an additional flag
included in a set cookie HTTP response
header using the HTTP only flag when
generating a cookie helps mitigate the
risk of client side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client side script again this is if the
browser supports this flag as a result
even if a cross-side scripting flaw
exists and a user accidentally accesses
a link that exploits this flop the
browser will not reveal the cookie to a
third
party if a browser does not support HTTP
only and a website attempts to set an
HTTP only cookie the HTTP only flag will
be ignored byow the browser thus
creating a traditional script accessible
cookie as a result the cookie becomes
vulnerable to theft of modification by
any malicious script next on our docket
is a live demonstration where we solve a
set of cross side scripting problems
starting from the basic level to the
topmost level six we're going to start
at level
one in this web application it
demonstrates the common cause of cross
side scripting where user input is
directly included in the page without
proper
escaping if you interact with a
vulnerable app application window here
and find a way to make it execute
JavaScript of our choosing we can take
actions inside the vulnerable window or
directly edit its URL bar this task
needs only basic knowledge let's see why
the most primitive injections work here
right away let's do a simple query and
inspect the resulting HTML
page I'm going to use this
phrase with a single code as a special
character we can now inspect the HTML
page we can see here in this
line the special character single code
appears in the result over
here the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected EX into
the web application because they are
nonpersistent xss attacks and the pad
should be included in the URL to perform
successful
exploitation we can use any payload but
we're going to use the simple one to
perform an alert in this web application
it's simple and can be shown
easily we just going to write the script
over
here
and we going to press
search as you can see we have
successfully launched our first
cross-site scripting attack we can see
an alert box pop up with the necessary
message and a similar process can be
used to steal browser cookies and
passwords allbe it with different
commands now we have the option to move
to level
two in this web application it shows
that how easily xss bugs can be
introduced in complex chat
applications chat app conversations are
stored in a database and retrieved when
a user wants to see the conversation
therefore if a malicious user injects
some JavaScript code all visitors will
be infected this kind of cross site
scripting attack is more powerful and it
is more riskier than deflected crossed
scripting attacks and that's why is
known as stored
xss I posted my
query with a special character of a
single quote and this is what I
get whatever I typed in simply appeared
on the page right after I click on share
status let's see the
source you can see here the text I
posted seems directly put inside a block
code tag so even a simple script tag we
used in level one should work here but
it will not let us examine the code to
understand
why we're going to toggle the code of
here and check the index.html
file important
part is line
the generated HTML fragment which is the
HTML variable in the code is added to
the male HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that HTML
fragment HTML parer will not execute a
script tag when it passes htmls via this
method this is why the script tag like
we used in level one is not going to
work here our solution is to use events
events will execute the defined
JavaScript we're going to use an image
over
here
and when we press on share
status in the above injection we are
loading an image that doesn't exist
which causes to trigger an on error
event in on error event the it will
execute our alert
method with that we are able to beat
level two and we can now move up to the
next level in our
challenge as you can see
clicking on any tab causes the tab
number to be displayed in the URL
fragment this hints that the value after
the hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable to
confirm let's analyze the
code as you can see in line 43 inside
the event
handling the value provided after the
hash in the URL
is directly passed onto the chw tab
method no input validation is being
performed the value passed to the choose
tab method is directly injected into the
IMG tag in line
17 this is an unsafe assignment and it
is the vulnerable part of the code now
all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute our JavaScript remember the
script tag from level one would not work
here since the variable HTML is used to
add the Dom dynamically hence the events
are ases here once again I will choose
to use the existing IMG tag and change
the source to something that doesn't
exist hence forcing it to fall into to
execute an on error even which I will
pass the
URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
our Java popup has opened up here with
the same message of xss level 3 has been
completed with this we can now move on
to level four which is going to present
a different kind of
attack in this of application there is a
timer on the page that means whatever
numbers we put in the Box a countdown
starts and then when it finishes the
application alerts that the countdown is
finished
and we can see the time is a popup
appearing over here and this resets the
timer again now it is obvious that the
value entered in the text box is
transferred to the server over the timer
parameter in the
URL let us examine the code to see how
the timer parameter is being
handled we're going to visit timer. HTML
over
here and we're going to check over
here in line
21 the start timer method is being
called in the onload event however the
timer parameter is being directly passed
to the start timer method we need to
perform a popup Alert in the web
application which escapes the content of
the function start timer without
breaking the JavaScript code the
parameter value is directly added to the
start timer method without any filtering
what we can try to do here is to inject
an alert function to be executed inside
the on loone event along with the start
timer method
we're going to remove this
argument and put our script over
here now when me press on create
timer and we have a popup with the xss
level 4
completed we can now move on to level
five
in this web application this application
xss is different cuz this challenge
description says cross-side scripting
isn't just about correctly escaping
data sometimes attackers can do bad
things even without injecting new
elements into the Dom it's kind of open
redirect cu the attack payload is
executed as a result of modifying the
Dom environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the client
side code runs in an unexpected manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the signup page is
inspected the href attribute value of
next link is confirm which is exactly
the value of the next URL query
parameter as you can see over here this
means using the next query parameter can
be used to inject a JavaScript code to
the href attribute of the next link the
following is the best way to do it as
soon as the user clicks on the link the
script will be
triggered
going to press anything random and now
that we click next we can see the xss
level 5 that we had provided in the URL
as a parameter to the next
variable since the value of next
provided appears on a popup we can
consider the attack a success and move
on to the final level six
in this sub application it shows some of
the external Javascript is
received if you analyze the URL you can
see that the script is loaded already
the vulnerability lies within how the
code handles the value after the
hashtag if you check on line 45 the
value right after the hashtag is taken
as the gadget name and then in line
48 the value is directly passed on to
the include Gadget method and the
include Gadget method that we can see
over
here you can see in line
18 a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line
28 this means we can completely control
the source attribute of the script tag
that is being created
that is with this vulnerability we can
inject our own JavaScript file into the
code we can inject a URL of our own
hosted JavaScript into the web
application's URL after the hashtag and
the URL should not be using https but
anything like that to bypass the regular
expression for security
checking going to remove the prored
URL and we're going to load our own
Javas script
file finally we have reached the end of
our
challenge we completed six different
varieties of cross scripting attacks and
use different solutions for all of the
six questions with work from home being
the norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without specific measures
to ensure a secure session apart from
individuals organizations worldwide that
host data and conduct business over the
internet are always at the risk of a DS
attack these DS attacks are getting more
extreme with hackers getting easy access
to botet farms and compromised devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest DDOS attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020 lately
cyber criminals have been actively
seeking out new services and protocols
for amplifying these DS attacks active
involvement with hacked machines and
botet allow further penetration into the
consumer space allowing much more
elaborate attack campaigns apart from
General users multinational corporations
have also had their fair share of
problems GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DS attack
in 2018 widely suspected to be conducted
by Chinese authorities this attack went
on for about 20 minutes after which the
systems were brought into a stable
condition it was the strongest Doos
attack to date at the time and made a
lot of companies reconsider the security
practices to combat such attacks even
after years of of experimentation Doos
attacks are still at large and can
affect anyone in the consumer and
corporate space hey everyone this is B
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video on what is a Dos attack let's
learn more about what is a DS
attack a distributed denial of service
attack or dos is when an attacker or
attackers attempt to make it impossible
for a service to be delivered this can
be achieved by thating access to
virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications in a Dos attack it's one
system that is sending the malicious
data or requests a DS attack comes from
multiple systems generally these attacks
work by Drowning a system with requests
for data this could be sending a web
server so many requests to server a page
that it crashes under the demand or it
could be a database being hit with a
high volume of queries the is result is
available internet bandwidth CPU and RAM
capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control center the thoughts
in the network attack a particular
Target thereby hiding the original
perpetrator of the DS campaign but how
do these devices come under a botnet and
what are the requests being made to the
web servers let's learn more about these
and how DS attack
work a DS attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
bot net of devices simply put a vast
network of computers are hacked via
malware ransomware or just simple social
engineering these devices become a part
of the botn net which can be triggered
any time to start bombarding a system or
a server on the instruction of the
hacker that created the botn net the
devices in this networks are called Bots
or zombies in the second phase a
particular Target is selected for the
attack when the hacker finds the right
time to attack all the zombies in the
botnet network send these requests to
the Target thereby taking up all the
servers available bandwidth
these can be simple ping requests or
complex attacks like SN flooding and UDP
flooding the aim is to overwhelm them
with more traffic than the server or the
network can accommodate the goal is to
render the website or service
inoperable there is a lot of wiggle room
when it comes to the type of Dos attack
a hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of Dos
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amount of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
resource it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks the size of volume
based attack is measured in bits per
second these attacks focus and clogging
all the available bandwidth for the
server thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate
users next we have the protocol level
attacks these attacks are meant to
consume essential resources of the
target server they exhaust the load
balancers and firewalls which are meant
to protect the system against the dors
attacks these protocol attacks include s
in floods and Smurf DDOS among others
and the size is measured in packets per
second for example in an SSL handshake
server replies to the Hello message sent
by the hacker which will be the client
in this case but but since the IP is
poofed and leads nowhere the server gets
stuck in an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application L attacks are
conducted by flooding applications with
maliciously crafted requests the size of
application layer attacks is measured in
request per second these are relatively
sophisticated attacks that Target the
application and operating system level
vulnerabilities the prevent the specific
applications from delivering necessary
information to users and hog the network
bandid up to the point of a system crash
examples of such an attack are HTTP
flooding and bgp hijacking a single
device can request data from a server
using HTTP post or get without any
issues however when the requisite botnet
is instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about the reasons for
such an attack there are multiple lines
of thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a Doos attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them the first option is to gain a
competitive Advantage many ds attacks
are conducted by hacking communities
against rival groups some organizations
hire such communities to stagger their
Rivals resources at a network level to
gain an advantage in the playing field
since being a victim of a DS attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some
ground secondly some hackers launch
these DS attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom the resources are
jammed and the only way to clear the way
is if the target company agrees to pay a
designated amount of money to the
hackers even a few minutes of inactivity
is detrimental to a company's reputation
in the global market maret and it can
cause a spiral effect both in terms of
market value and product security index
most of the time a compromise is reached
and the resources are freed after a
while DS attacks have also found use in
the political segment certain activists
tend to use DS attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
Forum primarily political these attacks
also focus on online communities ethical
dmas or even protest against
corporations let's take a look at a few
ways that companies and individuals can
protect themselves against redos
attacks the company can employ load
balancers and firewalls to help protect
the data from such attacks load balances
reroute the traffic from one server to
another in a DS attack this reduces the
single point of failure and adds
resiliency to the server data a firewall
blocks unwanted traffic into a system
and manages the number of requests made
at a definite rate it checks for
multiple attacks from a single IP and
occasional slowdowns to detect a DS
attack in
action early detection of a DS attack
goes a long way in recovering the data
lost in such an event once you've
detected the attack you will have to
find a way to respond for example you
will have to work on dropping the
malicious DS traffic before it reaches
your server so that it doesn't throttle
and exhaust your bandwidth here's where
you will filter the traffic so that only
legitimate traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by your cluster
resources the most important stage in
DOS mitigation is where you will look
for patterns of DS attacks and use those
to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first
step Cloud providers like Amazon web
services and Microsoft azzure who offer
high levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandd than most private networks
so it is likely to fail if under the
pressure of increased TS
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable to du
to a Dos attack you can switch to a
secure access on backed up versions
without missing a beat one can also
increase the amount of bandwidth
available to a host server being
targeted since DS attacks fundamentally
operate on the principle of overwhelming
systems with heavy traffic simply
provisioning extra bandwidth to handle
unexpected traffic spikes can provide a
measure of protection this solution can
prove expensive as a lot of that
bandwidth is going to go unused most
most of the
time a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates dos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular CDN include acomi
CDN Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc
let's start with our demo regarding the
effects of DS attacks on a system for
our demo we have a single device that
will attack a Target making it a Dos
attack of sorts once a bot net is ready
multiple devices can do the same and
eventually emulate a DS attack to do so
we will use the virtualization software
called VMware with an instance of parot
security operating system running for a
Target machine we will be running
another vmw instance of a standard l
Linux distribution known as Linux light
in a Target device we can use wire shark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly this is Linux light which is
our Target machine and this is parad
security which is used by the hacker
when trying to launch a DS attack this
is just one of the dros that can be
used to launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the
terminal we use the command if
config and here we can find the IP
address now remember we're launching
this attack in VMware now the both the
instances of parro security and Linux
light are being run on my local network
so the address that you can see here is
19216 68.
72129 which is a private address this IP
cannot be accessed from outside the
network basically anyone who is not
connected to my Wi-Fi when launching
attacks with public servers or public
addresses it will have a public IP
address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool
called hpin
hping 3 is an open-source packet
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol to check what are the effects
of an attack we will be using wire shark
wire shark is a network traffic analyzer
you can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the Linux light drro is
being displayed over here with the IP
address the source IP and the
destination IP as to where the request
is being transferred to once we have the
Dos attack launched you can see the
results coming over here from The Source
IP which will be par security Now to
launch the hping 3 command we need to
give pseudo access to the console which
is the root
access now we have the root access for
the console the hp3 command will have a
few arguments to go with it which are as
you can see on the screen
minus s and a
flood a hyphen
V hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is2 168
72129 in this command we have a few
arguments such as the minus s which
specifies syn packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the SN request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection The Hyphen flood
aims to ignore the replies that the
server will send back to the client in
response to the SN packets here the
parent security OS is the client and
Linux slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent the hyphen
p80 stands for Port 80 which we can
replace the port number if we want to
attack a different port and finally we
have the IP address of our
Target as of right now if we check wire
shockk it is relatively clear and there
is no indication of a DS attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over
here we can see the request coming in
from this IP which is 192 168 72.1 128
till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux
light the requests keep on coming and we
can see the
HTTP flooding has started in flood
mode after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a back end
now remember Linux light is a drro and
such Linux dros are served as backend to
many servers across the world for
example a few seconds have passed from
the attack now the system has become
completely irresponsive this has
happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from par
security you can see whatever I press
nothing is responded even the wi shock
has stopped capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100 % and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux drro or
where this Linux drro is being used as a
backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely stopped responding and
any request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to settle
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a DS attack comes into play what we did
right now is a to attack as in a single
system is being used to penetrate a
Target server using a single request now
when a Dos attack multiple systems such
as multiple parro security instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a botet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and
inoperable as a final note we would like
to remind that this is for educational
purposes only and we do not endorse any
attacks on any domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as Brute Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key ring and eventually
finding the right one Brute Force
attacks are simple and reliable there is
no prior knowledge needed about the
victim to start an attack most of the
systems following prey to Brute Force
attacks are actually well
secured attackers let a computer do the
work that is trying different com
combinations of usernames and passwords
until they find the one that works due
to this repeated trial and error format
the strength of password matters a great
deal although with enough time and
resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
begin with learning about Brute Force
attacks in
detail a Brute Force attack also known
as an exhaustive search is a
cryptographic hack that relies on
guessing possible combinations of
targeted password until the current
password is discovered it can be used to
break into online accounts encrypted
documents or even Network peripheral
devices the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be timec
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data aisc are used and
at times downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take seconds with
hardly any effort dictionary attacks are
an alternative to Brute Force attacks as
the attacker already has a list of
usernames and passwords that need to be
tested against the target it doesn't
need to create any other combinations on
its own dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general
population there is a three-step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in
detail in step one we have to settle on
a tool that we are going to use for
brute forcing there are some popular
names on the market like
hashcat Hydra and John the Ripper while
each of them has its own strength and
weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that came to
penetration testers and cyber security
analysts like K Linux and parro
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six-digit password will create 900,000
passwords with only digits involved add
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific 8-digit word containing only
letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to get the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones they omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time in the
final step we run these combinations
against the file or service that is
being broken we can try and break into a
specific encrypted document a social
media account or even devices at home
that connect to the internet let's say
there is a Wi-Fi router the generated
passwords are then fed into the
connection one after the other it is a
long and harders process but the work is
left to the computer other than someone
manually clicking and checking each of
these passcodes
any password that doesn't unlock the
router is discarded and The Brute Force
tool simply moves on to the next one
this keeps going on until we find the
right combination which unlocks the
router sometimes reaching the success
stage takes days and weeks which makes
it cumbersome for people with low
computing power at their disposal
however the ability to crack any system
in the world purely due to bad password
habits is very appealing and the general
public tends to stick with simple and
easy to use
passwords now that we have a fair idea
about how Brute Force Works let's see if
we can answer this question we learned
about how complex passwords are tougher
to crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next
week let's move on to the harmful
effects of getting a system system
compromised due to Brute Force
attacks a hacked laptop or mobile can
have social media accounts logged in
giving the hackers free access to the
victim's connections it has been
reported on multiple occasions where
compromised Facebook accounts are
sending malicious links and attachments
to people on their friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute forced A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via FTP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plane format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to imp personate the victim
regarding Bank verification among other
things once a system is hacked it can
also be used as a mail server that
distributes spam across lists of victims
since the Hacked machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
general public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the ways
we can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of with standing
Brute Force attacks thanks to the sheer
number of combinations they can produce
the longer the password the less likely
it is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them having
alpha numeric passwords also allows the
user to keep different passwords for
different websites this is to ensure
sure that if a single account or a
password is compromised due to a breach
or a hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the
incident two-factor authentication
involves receiving a one-time password
on a trusted device before a new login
is allowed this OTB can be obtained
either via email SMS or specific tofa
applications like Ai and Aegis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for 2A course
are much more reliable and
secure captures are used to stop Bots
from running through web pages precisely
to prevent brute forcing through their
website since boot Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of Brute Force
considerably a definite rule that locks
the account being hacked for 30 minutes
after a specific number of attempts is a
good way to prevent Brute Force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the website
let's look at a demonstration of how
Brute Force attacks work in a real world
situation the world has gone Wireless
with Wi-Fi taking the re in every
household it's natural that the security
will always be up for debate to further
tou the security index and understand
Brute Force attacks you will attempt to
break into the password of a Wi-Fi
router for that to happen you first need
to capture a handshake file which is a
connection file from the Wi-Fi router to
a Connect in device like a mobile or a
laptop the operating system used for
this process is parot security a Linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more to start our demo we're going to
use a tool called air gedon which is
made to hack into wireless network
specifically at this point it's going to
check for all the necessary scripts that
are installed in the
system to crack into a Wi-Fi and to
capture the handshake file we're going
to need an external network card the
significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode
for now the WL X1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select to be able to capture data
over the air we're going to need to put
it in monitor mode as you can see above
it's written it is in managed mode right
now so we're going to select option two
which is to put the interface in monitor
mode and it name is now w0 monitor the
monitor mode is necessary to capture
data over the air that is the ne
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which is the handshake
tools
menu in the first step we have to
explore for targets and it is written
that monitor mode is necessary to select
a Target so let's explore for
targets and press
enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network go24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example the station that you can see
5626 this is supposed to be the MAC
address of the device that is connected
to a router this BS ID is supposed to be
which wi-fi it is connected to for
example 5895 d8 is this one which is the
go24 router so we already know which
router has a device connected to it and
we can use our attack to capture this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C we will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture
handshake it says we have a valid WPA
WPA2 Network Target selected and that
the script can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a do
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they configured that way
that when a client is disconnected it
tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's go with the
second option that is the do Air
replayer
Attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script we can see it capturing data from
the ge24 network and here we we go we
have the WPA handshake
file once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a to cap file for the
path we can let's say we can keep it in
a
desktop okay we give the
path and the Hand Shi file is generated
we can already see a Target over here
same go24 router with the BSS
ID now if we return to its main
menu we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is of an encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will will
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option
one now to run the Brute Force tool we
have two options either we can go with
the air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with airack plus crunch
which is a Brute Force attack against a
handshake file we can go with option two
it can already detect the capture file
that we have generated so we select
yes the BSS ID is the one which denotes
the go24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA2 psk key
will always be more than 8 digits and
Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10 and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as
20 the character set that we going to
use for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if we already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has only numbers and symbols then
we can choose accordingly let's say if
you go with only uppercase characters
and numeric
characters go with option
seven and it's going to start
decrypting so how aircrack is working
right here you can see this pass phrase
over here the first five or six digits
are a it starts working its way from the
end from the last character it keeps
trying every single combination you can
see see the last the fourth character
from the right side the D it will
eventually turn to
e because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end this will
keep going on until all the single
characters are tested and every single
combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the WPA2 key of the
router whichever pass phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key completely
will be the key of the Wi-Fi router this
is the way we can Brute Force into Wi-Fi
routers anywhere in the world simple
learn offers postgraduate program in
cyber security find the complete course
details from the link in the description
box internet is an endless source of
information and data still in some cases
we come across some occurrences like
cyber attacks hacking force entry which
may affect a Time on the web hi everyone
and welcome to the simply La Channel
today we will discuss a topic that
secretly records our input data that is
known as key loggers but before we begin
if you like watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an
update to understand the key logging
problem better let's take a look at an
example this is June she works in a
business firm where she manages the
company's data
regularly this is Jacob from the
information Department who is here to
inform her about some of the security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
her system was facing with which
included slow reaction speed and unusual
internet
activity as Jacob heard about the
problems with the system he thinks of
the possibility what could be the reason
behind these problems her system was
facing
with the conclusion that he came across
was the key logging
issue unknown to the problem her system
was facing with she asked him about some
of the details regarding
it for today's topic we learn what
exactly key loggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effects that key logging can bring into
the system to begin with we learn what
exactly the key logging program
is as the name suggests key logger is a
malicious program or a tool that are
designed to record key strokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a lock file then the same program
secretly sends these log files to its
origin where they can be used for
malicious acts by the
hacker now that we know what the key
logging program is let's take a look how
they enter into the
system searching for a suitable driver
for a system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then
if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key logging issue entering
into the system and lastly there are
often cases where different popups that
we often see on social sites or
different media sites can lead to the
installation of key loging program into
our
system now that we know how the problem
gets into the system let's take a look
how to identify whether the system is
infected by the key logging
issue the key logging issue can be
identified if there are often cases when
a keyboard lags behind the system the
data that we enter sometimes is stuck in
between when we type through the
input then there are cases when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction
times for different applications that
run on the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present on the net which can harm our
system
differently the first problem that key
loggers arounds is API based the most
common key logging case which uses apis
to keep a log of the type data and share
it to its origin for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and logs it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggests they are a based
key loggers that store the form data
that is if we often use web forms or
different kinds of forms to enter
different data they can be recorded into
the system by the program and send it to
its
origin then we have kernel based key
loggers these key loggers are installed
deeply into the operating system where
they can hide from different antivirus
if not checked properly and they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
and send it to its
origin and lastly we have Hardware Key
loggers these key loggers are present
directly into the hardware that is they
are embedded into system where they
record the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit
them when hackers receive information
about the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related issues
then in case of company data that is
recorded by the key logging program can
also affect the economic value of the
company in the market which may lead to
the downfall of the
company also in some cases the key
logging program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country now now let's take a look
whether mobile devices get infected with
the key logging issue or
not in the case of hand devices
infection of key loggers are low in
comparison to the computer systems as
they use onscreen keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different kindes of malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is
infected with the key logging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to the exploitation of data
that includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the
system now to prevent a system from
getting infected by the key locking
program let's take a look at different
points
the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering of
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good
habit and lastly using virtual keyboard
to input our sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic for the first step we have to
download some of the important libraries
that are required into the
system which
is this library now we'll run
it the system says the library is
already installed into the
system now let's take a look what
exactly
modules are required from the particular
library from this Library we'll
import the keyboard module which will
help us to record the data that we type
on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module and also
the logging module which will help us to
record the data into a log
file for the next part we'll write a
piece of code that will allow us to save
the data that is recorded by the program
into a text file that will be named as
keor log text file along with the date
and time stamp let's take a
look
now we'll provide it with the file
name that will be given
as key log do txt
file and also so the part where the
format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given
as the format would be the message and
the time stamp which would be given
as
along with the time
stamp as
percentage and ending it with the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design two of the functions that will be
used into the program that will be
termed as while press function and while
release function
let's take a
look while press
function would be a function that will
come into play when the keyboard key has
been
pressed
is
pressed and
this would go for the format that we
designed in the above
line
and
logging the Press
key
info or string file to be
recorded into the lock file now
now we'll design a function that is
while
release that will come into play
when the Escape key has been pressed
that is the program will terminate
itself and the program will stop from
running and in the
end we require for the functioning of
the program to Loop these functions that
is while press and while release to
continue its
cycle
that will be going for while press
and
on release will contain while
release
function
as listen
now and now
this part would join the different
threads and store them into the loog
file now that we have completed the code
for the program let's run
it we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to verify the program let's open
Notepad
and on the notepad we'll
write hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not let's take
a
look and we'll go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page go
to the
bottom over here we see the key lock
text that is a text file that we created
let's open it
and over here we have the data that is
created as we started with Note then
this is the hello world part that we
created just
now which shows that the program we
created is working properly now that we
have reached the end of the module let's
take a look at the summary firstly we
learn what exactly key logos are then we
understood what different modes are
present how the system get infected with
the key loging problem then we learned
how to detect the problem into our
system then we learned what different
types of key loggers are present on the
net we also understood how hackers use
the recorded data from the program and
we also learned whether mobile devices
get infected with the key logging
problem or not and lastly we understood
what different points can be taken to
prevent the entering of the key logging
problem into the system before we learn
about the Pegasus platform let us
understand what spyware is and it's
working spyware is a category of malware
that can gather information regarding a
user or a device straight from the host
machine it is mostly spread by malicious
links via email or chat applications
when a link with the malware is received
clicking on this link will activate the
spyware which allows the hacker to spy
on all our user information with some
spy systems even clicking on the link
isn't necessary to trigger the malicious
payload this can ultimately cause
security complications and further loss
of privacy one such spy system that is
making the rounds in the tech industry
today is Pegasus the Pegasus is a
spyware system developed by an Israeli
company known as the NSO group it runs
on mainly mobile devices spanning across
the major operating systems like the
Apple's IOS on iPhone and the standard
Android versions this is not a newly
developed platform since Pegasus has
existed since as early as 2016 a highly
intricate spy program that can track
user location read text messages scan
through mobile files access device
camera and microphone to record voice
and video Pegasus has all the tools
necessary to enforce surveillance for
any client that wishes to buy it
Services initially the NSO group had
designed the software to be used against
terrorist factions of the world with
more and more encrypted communication
channels coming to the Forefront Pegasus
was designed to maintain control over
the data trans mission that can be a
threat to National Security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had complete control over who
how and up to what level they can put
surveillance limits on eventually the
primary clients became Sovereign Nations
spying on Public Information that is
supposed to stay private became really
easy with the service multiple devices
can be affect With the same spyer system
to create a network information this
network keeps feeding data to the host
to understand how a Network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all
communicate with friends and family over
instant messaging applications and email
in some instances if you check your
inbox on a regular basis you must have
noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages
bypass this filter and make their way
into a person's inbox they look like
generic emails which are supposed to be
safe the p spyware targets such
occurrences by passing malicious
messages and links which install the
necessary Spy software on the user's
mobile device be it Android or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS text WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threa once the malicious
links are clicked a spyware package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after the spyware is successful
successfully installed the perpetrator
who sent the payload to the victim can
monitor everything the user does Pegasus
can collect private emails passwords
images videos and every other piece of
information that passes to the device
Network all this data is transmitted
back to the central server where the
primary spying organization can monitor
the activities at a granular level this
is not even surface level since complex
py software like Pegasus can access the
root files on our mobiles these root
files hold information that is crucial
to the working of the Android and iOS
operating systems leaking such private
information is a massive blow to the
security and the privacy of an
individual the information that may seem
trivial like the name of your Wi-Fi
connection or the last time you ordered
an item from Amazon are indeed all
valuable information this exploitation
is primarily possible due to the zero
day vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits these exploits are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the
Gateway for spyware to enter into the
system you can never be 100% safe but
you sure can give it all in protecting
yourself the one thing where Pegasus
stands out is a zero click action
feature usually in spam emails the
malicious code is activated when the
user clicks the malware link a user
doesn't need to click the link in the
new new version of the Pegasus and a few
other spyware programs once the message
arrives in the inbox of WhatsApp Gmail
or any other chat applications the
spyware gets activated and everything
can be recorded and sent back to the
central server the primary issue with
being affected by spyware as a victim is
detection unlike Crypt Miners and
Trojans spying Services usually do not
demand many system resources which makes
them tough to detect after they have
been activated since many devices slow
down after a couple of years any kind of
Performance Set due to such spyware is
often attributed to poor software
longetivity by the users they do not
check meticulously for any other causes
that is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if you are
well aware of the causes of such attacks
how do users fall free to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software B by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages C by
not keeping the apps and phones updated
or D all of the above let us know your
answers in the comment section below and
we will rev the correct answer next week
but what about the unaffected devices
the vulnerable ones while we cannot be
certain of our security there are a few
things we can do to boost our device be
it against Pegasus or the next big SP on
the market let's say we are safe now and
we have the time to take the necessary
steps to prevent a spyware attack what
are the things we can go for a primary
goal must always be to keep our apps and
the operating system updated the latest
security patches the vulnerabilities
that the exploits Target are often
discovered by developers from Google and
apple which send the security patches
quickly this can be done for individual
apps as well so keeping them updated is
of utmost importance while the most
secure devices have fallen pre to
Pegasus as well a security patch from
developers may help in minimizing the
damage at a later stage or maybe negate
the entire spy platform altogether
another big factor is the spread of
malware is the trend of sideloading
Android applications using do APK files
downloading such apps from a thirdparty
website have no security checks involved
and are mostly responsible for adware
and spyware invasions on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into a
device we should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains spy is a controversial segment
in governance while the ramifications
are pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false veil of democracy
altogether
even if our daily life is rather
simplistic we must understand that
privacy is not about what we have to
hide instead it portrays the things we
have to protect it stands for everything
we have to share with the outside world
both rhetorically and literally hey
everyone today we look at the hack which
took the World by storm and affected
multiple governments and corporations
the solar winds attack the global
statistics indicate that upward of
18,000 customers have been affected
potentially needing billions to recover
the losses incurred before we have a
look at this hack Make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hit the notification
Bell to never miss an update from Simply
Le the date is December 8th 2020 fire a
global leader in company specializing in
cyber security released a blog post that
caught the attention of the entire it
Community a software known as Orion
which was developed by solar wind
Incorporated had become a victim of a
remote access Trojan or a rat the breach
was estimated to be running running
since the spring of 2020 and went
virtually unnoticed for months the
reveal sent the developers of the Orion
software into a frenzy as they quickly
released a couple of hot fixes for their
platform in order to mitigate this
threat and prevent further damage but
how did this come into existence we
first need to understand the platform
which was responsible for this breach
soloin a software company based in Texas
United States had developed a management
platform known as Orion cering to
corporations and governments worldwide
Oran was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organization Network infrastructure that
bought the platform solar wind claims
they have more than 300,000 clients
including US government agencies and
several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are prefer liy services
rendered by a third party since there is
no direct jurisdiction over it in this
case the Orion platform was the primary
target the culprit however was software
updates the update server for solarin
Orion had a malicious version attached
with malware or a trojen to be precise
this was made possible since the code
repository that handled these software
updates was breached once the update
server repository was compromised the
source code of the applications became
open to modification and and malicious
code found its way onto the software the
remote access troen was attached to a
potential update nicknamed the Sunburst
update this update gave hackers back
door access to any client that uses the
correct version on its release many
clients believ the update to be
legitimate since it came from the right
source and they had no reason to believe
otherwise American government agencies
were supposedly hit the hardest as the
list of victims included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issued
quick updates to fix this
vulnerabilities introduced by the
software while the actual perpetrators
have never been found it is believed
that this was an act of crossborder
corporate Espionage conducted by state
sponsored hackers either from Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned what
category of malw was responsible for the
solar wind hack was it one a virus a
remote access Trojan a spyware or a worm
let us know your answers in the comment
section right away and we will reveal
the correct answer in a week coming to
possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
through the worldwide web using a
password manager is highly recommended
which can generate secure alpha numeric
passwords you must also use different
passwords for different accounts thereby
reducing the chances of a single point
of failure should one of those accounts
get breached usage of two-factor
authentication applications is also
encouraged since it acts as a safety net
if hackers directly get a hold of our
credentials clicking on unknown links
transmitted via emails is also a strict
no as is installing applications from
unverified sources the solar wind hack
is estimated to cost the parent company
nearly $8 million as reparations making
it one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history as recently as of
July 2021 the hackers access some us
attorneys Microsoft 365 email accounts
as part of the attack criminal
organizations like the FBI and CIA are
determined to figure out the culprits
responsible for this debacle however the
intricacy and the full extent of the
breach makes it a way more complicated
job than it looks on paper Dees
algorithm stands for for data encryption
standard it is a symmetric key Cipher
that is used to encrypt and recpt
information in a blogby block manner
each block is encrypted individually and
they're later chained together to form
our final Cipher text which is then sent
to a receiver DS takes the original
unaltered piece of data called the plain
text in a 64-bit block and it is
converted into an encryptor text that is
called the cipher text it uses 48 bit
Keys during the encryption process and
follows a specific structure called the
fistal Cipher structure during the
entire process it is a symmetri key
algorithm which means DS can reuse the
keys used in the encryption format to
decrypt the cipher text back to the
original plain text once the 64-bit
blocks are encrypted they can be
combined together before being
transmitted let's take a look at the
origin and the reason thees was
founded DS is based on a fistal block
Cipher called Lucifer developed in 1971
by IBM cryptography researcher host
fistal Dees uses 16 rounds of this
fistal structure using a different key
for each round it also utilizes a random
function with two inputs and provides a
single output variable DS becames the
organization's approved encryption
standard in November 1976 and was later
reaffirmed as a standard in 1983 1988
and finally in 1999 but eventually thees
was cracked and it was no no longer
considered a secure solution for all
official roots of
communication consequently triple Ds was
developed triple Ds is a symmetri key
block Cipher that uses a double Ds
Cipher encrypt with the first key delete
encryption with the second key and
encrypt again with a third key there is
also a variation of the two keys where
the first and second key are duplicate
of each other but triple Ds was
ultimately deemed too slow for the
growing need for fast communication
channels and people eventually fell back
to using DS for encrypting messages in
order to search for a better alternative
a public wide competition was organized
and helped cryptographers develop their
own algorithm as a proposal for the next
global standard this is where the rile
algorithm came into play and was later
credited to be the next Advanced
encryption standard for a long time DS
was the standard for data encryption for
data security its rule ended in 2002
when finally the Advanced encryption
standard replace Dees as an acceptable
standard following a public competition
for a
place to understand the structure of a
fistal Cipher we can use the following
image as a reference the block being
encrypted is divided into two parts one
of which is being passed onto the
function while the other part is exor
with the function's output the function
also uses the encryption key that
differs for each individual round this
keeps going on until the last step unto
where the right hand side and the left
hand side are being swapped here we
receive our final Cipher text for the
decryption process the entire procedure
is reversed starting from the order of
the keys to the block sorting if the
entire process is repeated in a reverse
order we will eventually get back our
plane text and this Simplicity helps the
speed overall This was later detrial to
the efficiency of the algorithm hence
the security was
compromised
a fistal block Cipher is a structure
used to derive many symmetric block
ciphers such as Dees which as we have
discussed in our previous
comment pistol Cipher proposed a
structure that implements substitution
and permutation alternately so that we
can obtain Cipher text from the plane
text and vice versa this helps in
reducing the redundancy of the program
and increases the complexity to combat
Brute Force
attacks the fistal Cipher is actually
based on the Shannon structure that was
proposed in 194 45 the fistel cipher is
the structure suggested by horse feistel
which was considered to be a backbone
while developing many symmetric block
ciphers the Shannon structure highlights
the implementation of alternate
confusion and diffusion and like we
already discussed the fistal Cipher
structure can be completely reversed
depending on the data however we must
consider the fact that to decrypt the
information by reversing the fal
structure we will need the exact
polinomial functions and the key orders
to understand how the blocks are being
calculated we take a plane test which is
of 64bit and that is later divided into
two equal halves of 32 bit each in this
the right half is immediately
transferred to the next round to become
the new Left half of the second r the
right hand is again passed off to a
function which uses an encryption key
that is unique to each round in the
fistal Cipher whatever the function
gives off as an output it is passed on
as an exor input with the left half of
the initial plane text the next output
will become the right half of the second
round for the plane text this entire
process constitutes of a single round in
the fistal
Cipher taking into account what happens
in the polinomial
function we take one half of the block
and pass it through an expansion box the
work of the expansion box is to increase
the size of the half from 32bit to
48-bit text this is done to make the
text compatible to a 48 bit Keys we have
generated
beforehand once we pass it through the
EXO function we get a 48-bit text as an
output now remember a half should be of
32-bit so this 48-bit output is then
later passed on to a substitution box
this substitution box reduces its size
from 48 bit to 32bit Output which is
then later exort with the first half of
the plain
text
a block Cipher is considered the safest
if the size of the block is large but
large block sizes can also slow down
encryption speed and the decryption
speed generally the size is
64bit sometimes modern block ciphers
like AES have a 128bit block size as
well the security of the block ciper
increases with increasing key size but
larger key sizes may also reduce the
speeds of the process earlier 64-bit
keys were considered sufficient modern
ciphers need to use 128bit Keys due to
the increasing complexity of today's
computational
standards the increasing number of
rounds also increase the security of the
block Cipher similarly they're inversely
proportional to the speed of
encryption a highly complex round
function enhances the security of the
block ciper Al we must maintain a
balance between the speed and
security
the symmetric block Cipher is
implemented in a software application to
achieve better execution speed there is
no use of an algorithm it it cannot be
implemented in a real life framework
that can help organizations to encrypt
or decrypt the data in a timely manner
now that we understand the basics of FAL
ciphers we can take a look at how Dees
manages to run through 16 rounds of the
structure and provide the cipher text at
the end now that we understand the
basics of Fel ciphers we we can take a
look at how DS manages to run through 16
rounds of this structure and provide a
cipher text in simple terms DS takes the
64-bit plain text and converts it into a
64-bit Cipher text and since we are
talking about asymmetric algorithms the
same key is being used when it is
decrypting the data as
well we first take a 64bit key plane
text and we pass it through an initial
permutation function the initial
permutation function has the job of
dividing the block into two different
parts so that we can perform fistal
Cypher structures on
it there are multiple rounds being
procured in the DS algorithm namely 16
rounds of FAL Cipher structure each of
these rounds will need keys initially we
take a 56-bit cipher key but it is a
single key we pass it onto a round key
generators which generates 16 different
keys for each single round that the
fistal Cipher is being run these keys
are passed on to the rounds as 48 bits
the size of these 48 bit case is the
reason we use the substitution and
permutation Bongs in the polinomial
functions of the faal
ciphers when passing through all these
rounds we reach round 16 where the final
key is passed on from the round key
generator and we get a final permutation
in the final permutation the rounds are
swapped and we get a final Cipher text
this is the entire process of Dees with
16 rounds of hisel cyers encompassed in
it to decrypt a cipher text back to the
plain text we just have to reverse the
process we did in the DS algorithm and
reverse the key order along with the
functions this kind of Simplicity is
what gave Dees the bonus when it comes
to speed but eventually it was
detrimental to the overall efficiency of
the program when it comes to security
factors DS have five different modes of
operation to choose from this one of
those is electronic code book each
64-bit block is encrypted and DEC Ed
independently in the electronic code
book format we also have Cipher block
chaining or the CBC method here each
64bit block depends on the previous one
and all of them use an initialization
Vector we have a cipher feedback block
mechanism where the preceding Cipher
text becomes the input for the
encryption algorithm it produces a sud
random output which in turn is exor with
the Plaine
text there is an output feedback method
as well which is the the same as Cipher
feedback except that the encryption
algorithm input is the output from the
preceding
d a counter method has a different way
of approach where each PL text block is
exor with an encrypted counter the
counter is then incremented for each
subsequent block there are a few other
alternatives to these modes of operation
but the five mentioned above are the
most widely used in the industry and
recommended by cryptographers worldwide
let's let take a look at the future of
Dees the dominance of Dees ended in 2002
when the advanced encryption standard
replac the DS encryption algorithm as
the accepted standard it was done
following a public competition to find a
replacement nist officially withdrew the
global acceptance standard in May 2005
although triple Ds has approved for some
sensitive government information through
203 n also had to change the DS
algorithm because its key length was too
short given the increased processing
power of the new computers encryption
power is related to the size of the key
and DS found itself a victim of ongoing
technological advances in Computing we
have received a point where 56-bit was
no longer a challenge to the computers
of cracking note that because DS is no
longer the nist federal standard it does
not mean that it is no longer in use
triple Ds is still used today and is
still considered a legacy encryption
algorithm to get a better understanding
of how these keys and Cipher text look
like we can use an online tool for our
benefit as we already know to encrypt
any kind of data a key is mandatory this
key can be generated using mathematical
functions or computerized key generation
program such as this website offers it
can be based on any piece of text let's
say the word is simply
[Music]
learn in our
example once the key is settled we
provide the plain text or the clear text
that needs to be encrypted using the
aforementioned key suppose a sentence
for this example is this is my first
message we have satisfied two
prerequisites the message and the key
another variable that goes into play is
the mode of
operation we have already learned about
five different modes of operation while
we can see some other options here as
well let us go with the CBC variant
which basically means the cipher block
chaining method
one of cbc's key characteristics is that
it uses a chaining process it causes the
decryption of a block of Cipher text to
depend all on the preceding Cipher text
blocks as a result the entire validity
of all the blocks is contained in the
previous adjacent blocks as well a
single bit error in a cipher text block
affects the decryption of all the
subsequent blocks rearrangement of the
order of these for example can cause the
decryption process to get corrupted
regarding the manner of displaying
binary information we have two options
here we can either go with base 64 or
the heximal format let's go with the
base 64 right
now as you can see the cipher text is
readily available b64 is a little more
efficient than hex so we will be getting
a smaller Cipher text when it comes to
b64 Alit the size of both the formats
will be the same the hex has a longer
size for text since Bas 64 takes four
characters for every three bytes while
hex will take two characters for each by
hence B 64 turns out to be more
efficient now to decut the cipher text
we go by the same format we choose base
64 we copy the cipher text onto a
decryption tool and we have to make sure
that the key we are using is exactly the
same we choose similar mode of operation
and and we choose the correct encoding
format as well which is BAS 64 in this
case as you can see the decryption is
complete and we get a plain text back
even if you keep everything the same but
we just change the encoding format it
will not be able to decrypt
anything unfortunately DS has become
rather easy to crack even without the
help of a key the advanced encryption
standard is still on top when it comes
to symmetric encryption security and
we're likely stay there for a
while eventually with so much computing
power growth the need for a stronger
algorithm was necessary to saveguard our
personal data as solid as Dees was the
computers of today could easily break
the encryption with repeated attempts
thereby rendering the data security
helpless to counter this dilemma a new
standard was introduced which was termed
as the advanced encryption standard or
the AES
algorithm let's learn what is Advanced
encryption standard
the AES algorithm also known as the
reile algorithm is a symmetric block
Cipher with a block size of 128 bits it
is converted into Cipher text using keys
of 128 192 or 256 bits it is implemented
in software and Hardware throughout the
world to encrypt sensitive data the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology also known as n started
development on AES in 1996 7 when it was
announced the need for an alternative to
the data encryption standard the new
internet needed a replacement for Dees
because of its small key size with
increasing computing power it was
considered unsafe against entire key
search attacks the triple Ds was
designed to overcome this problem
however it was deemed to be too slow to
be deployed in machines
worldwide strong cases were present by
the Mars rc6 Serpent and the two fish
algorithms but it was the rindal
encryption algorithm also known as AES
which was eventually chosen as the
standard symmetric key encryption
algorithm to be used its section was
formalized with the release of federal
information processing standards
publication 197 in the November of 2001
it was approved by the US Secretary of
Commerce now that we understand the
origin of AES let us have a look at the
features that make AES encryption
algorithm unique
the AES algorithm uses a substitution
permutation or SP Network it consists of
multiple rounds to produce a cipher text
it has a series of linked operations
including replacing inputs with specific
outputs that is substitutions and others
that involve bit shuffling which is
permutations at the beginning of the
encryption process we only start out
with a single key which can be either a
128bit key a 192bit key or a 256bit key
eventually this one key is expanded to
be used in multiple rounds throughout
the encryption and the decryption cycle
interestingly AES performs all its
calculations on bite data instead of bit
data as seen in the case of the dees
algorithm therefore AES treats 128 bits
of a clear text block as 16 bytes the
number of rounds during the encryption
process depends on the key size that is
being used the 128bit key size fixes 10
Rounds the 192bit key size fixes 12
rounds and the 256bit key holds 14
rounds a round key is required for each
of these rounds but since only one key
is input into the algorithm the single
key needs to be expanded to get the key
for each round including the round
zero with so many mathematical
calculations going on in the background
there are bound to be a lot of steps
throughout the procedure let's have a
look at the steps followed in
AES before we move ahead we need to
understand how data is being stored
during the process of AES
encryption everything in the process is
stored in a 4 into 4 Matrix
format this Matrix is also known as a
state array and we'll be using these
State arrays to transmit data from one
step to another and from one round to
the next
round each round takes straight array as
input and gives a straight array as
output to be transferred into the next
round it is a 16 by Matrix with each
cell representing one
bite with each four bytes representing a
word so every state array will have a
total of four words representing
it as we previously discussed we take a
single key and expand it to the number
of rounds that we need the key to be
used in let's say the number of rounds
are n then the key has to be expanded to
be used with n+1 rounds because the
first round is the key zero Z
round let's say n is the number of
rounds the key is expanded to n + 1
rounds it is also a state array having
four words in its vicinity every key is
used for a single round and the first
key is a used as a round key before any
round
begins in the very beginning the plane
text is captured and passed through an
exor function with a round key as a
supplement this key can be considered
the first key from the n+1 expanded set
moving on the state array resulting from
the above step is passed on to a bite
substitution
process beyond that there is a provision
to shift rows in the state arrays later
on the state array is mixed with a
constant Matrix to shuffle its column in
the mixed column segment after which we
add the round key for that particular
round the last four steps mentioned are
part of every single round that the
encryption algorithm goes through the
state arrays are then passed from one
round to the next as an input in the
last round however we skipped the mix
columns portion with the rest of the
process remaining
unchanged but what are these bite
substitution and row shifting processes
let's find out regarding each step in
more
detail in the first step the plane text
is stored in a state array and is exor
with the case Zer which is the first key
in the expanded key set this step is
performed only once on a block while
being repeated at the end of each round
as per iteration
demands the state array is exor with the
key to get a new state array which is
then passed of his input to the sub
bytes
process in the second stage we have by
substitution we leverage an Xbox called
as a substitution box to randomly switch
data among each element every single
single bite is converted into a heximal
value having two parts the first part
denotes the row value and the second
part denotes the column value the entire
State array is passed through the sbox
to create a brand new state array which
is then passed off as an input to the
row shifting process the 16 input bytes
are replaced by looking at a fixed table
given in the design we finally get a
matrix with four rows and four
columns when it comes to row shifting
each bit in the four rows of the Matrix
is shifted to the left an entry that is
a fall off is reinserted to the right of
the line the change is done as follows
the first line is not moved in any way
the second line is shifted to a single
position to the left the third line is
shifted two positions to the left and
the fourth line is shifted three
positions to the left the result is a
new Matrix that contains the same 16
bytes but has been moved in relation to
each other to to boost the complexity of
the
program in mixed columns each column of
four bytes is now replaced using a
special mathematical function the
function takes four bytes of a column as
input and outputs for completely new
bytes we will get a new Matrix with the
same size of 16 bytes and it should be
noted that this phase has not been done
in the last round of the
iteration when it comes to add adding a
round key the 16 bytes of the Matrix are
treated as 128 bits and the 128 bits of
the round key are exort if it is the
last round the output is the cipher text
if we still have a few rounds remaining
the resulting 128 bits are interpreted
as 16 bytes and we start another similar
round let's take an example to
understand how all these processes work
if our plane text is the string
2192 we first convert it into a
hexadecimal format as follows we use an
encryption key which is that's my K Fu
and it is converted into a hexadecimal
format as
well as per the guidelines we use a
single key which is then later expanded
into n+ one number of keys in which case
it's supposed to be 11 keys for 10
different
rounds in round zero we add the round
key the plane test is exort with the k0
and and we get a state array that is
passed off as an input to the
substitution byes
process when it comes to the
substitution bytes process we leverage
an sbox to substitute the elements of
each bite with a completely new bite
this way the state array that we receive
is passed off as an input to the row
shifting process on the next
step when it comes to row shifting each
element is shifted a few places to the
left with the first row being shifted by
zero places second row by one place
third row by two places and the last by
three the state array that we received
from the row shifting is passed off as
an input to mix columns in mixed columns
we multiply the straight array with a
constant Matrix after which I receive a
new Straight array to be passed on onto
the next
step we add the the new state array as
an exor with the round key of the
particular iteration whatever state
array we receive here it becomes an
output for this particular
round now since this is the first round
of the entire encryption process the
state array that we receive is passed
off as an input to the new
Round We repeat this process for 10 more
rounds and we finally receive a cipher
text once the final State aray can be
denoted in the hexadecimal format this
becomes our final Cipher text that we
can use for transferring information
from the sender and
receiver let's take a look at the
applications of AES in this
world AES finds most use in the area of
wireless security in order to establish
a secure mode of authentication between
routers and clients highly secure
mechanisms like WPA and WPA2 psk are
extensively used in securing Wi-Fi
endpoints with the help of Riles
algorithm it also helps in SSL TLS
encryption that is instrumental in
encrypting our internet browser sessions
AES Works in tandem with other
asymmetric encryption algorithms to make
sure the web browser and web server are
properly configured and use encrypted
channels for
communication AES is also prevalent in
general file encryption of various
formats ranging from critical documents
to the media files having a large key
allows people to encrypt media and
decrypt data with maximum security
possible AES is also used for processor
Security in Hardware Appliances to
prevent machine hijacking among other
things as a direct successor to the dees
algorithm there are some aspects that
AES provides an immediate advantage in
let us take a look
when it comes to key length the biggest
flaw in DS algorithm was that small
length was easily vulnerable by today's
standards eses has managed to NAB up 128
192 and 256bit key lens to bolster the
security further the block size is also
larger in AES owing to more complexity
of the algorithm the number of rounds in
Dees is fixed irrespective of the plain
text being used in AES the number of
round depends on the key length that is
being used for the particular iteration
thereby providing more Randomness and
complexity in the
algorithm the dees algorithm is
considered to be simpler than AES even
though AES beats Dees when it comes to
relative speed of encryption and
decryption this makes Advanced
encryption standard much more
streamlined to be deployed in Frameworks
and systems worldwide when it compares
to the data encryption standard hello in
our last video on cryptography we took a
look at symmetri Key cryptography we
used a single private key for both the
encryption and decryption of data and it
works very well in theory let's take a
look at a more realistic scenario now
let's meet Joe Joe is a journalist who
needs to communicate with Ryan via
long-distance messaging due to the
critical nature of the information
people are waiting for any message to
leave Joe's house so that they can
intercept it now Joe can easily use
symmetric cryptography fee to send the
encrypted data so that even if someone
intercepts the message they cannot
understand what it says but here's the
tricky part how will Joe send the
required decryption key to Ryan the
sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise Ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since a
third party can now decode all the
information EAS easily key sharing is a
risk that will always exist when
symmetric key cryptography is being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this problem this is B
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video on asymmetry key cryptography
let's take a look at what we are going
to learn today We Begin by explaining
what asymmetry key cryptography is and
how it works we take a look at its
application and uses we understand why
it's called publicy cryptography and
then learn a little a little bit about
RS encryption and then we learn about
the advantages of asymmetric key
cryptography over symmetric key
cryptography let's understand what
asymmetry key cryptography
is asymmetry encryption uses a double
layer of protection there are two
different keys at play here a private
key and a public key a public key is
used to encrypt the information
pre-transit and a private key is used to
decrypt the data post Transit the these
pair of keys must belong to the receiver
of the message the public keys can be
shared via messaging blog posts or key
servers and there are no restrictions as
you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the cipher text the cipher text
is then transmitted to the receiver
without any other key on getting the
cipher text the receiver uses his
private key to decrypt it and get the
plane text back there has been no requ
requirement of any key exchange
throughout this process therefore
solving the most glaring flaw faced in
symmetry key
cryptography the public key known to
everyone cannot be used to decrypt the
message and the private key which can
decrypt the message need not be shared
with anyone the sender and receiver can
exchange personal data using the same
set of keys as often as
possible to understand this better take
the analogy of your
mailbox anyone who wants to send you a
letter has access to the Box and can
easily share information with you in a
way you can say the mailbox is publicly
available to all but only you have
access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it this
is how the private key comes to play no
one can intercept the message and read
its contents since it's encrypted once
the receiver gets its contents he can
use his private key to decrypt the
information both the public key and the
private key are generated so they are
interl and you cannot substitute other
private keys to decrypt the data in
another example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob let's say Treads call me
today she must use Bob's public key
while encrypting the message upon
receiving the cipher message Bob can
proceed to use his private key in order
to decp the message and hence complete
Security is attained during transmission
without any need for sharing the
key since this type of encryption is
highly secure it has many uses in areas
that require High
confidentiality it is used to manage
digital signatures so there is valid
proof of a documents authenticity with
so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon thanks to asymmetric
cryptography senders can now sign
documents with their private Keys anyone
who needs to verify the authenticity of
such signatures can use the sender's
public key to decrypt the signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification with with duplicate Keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows the
similar
approach in blockchain architecture
asymmetry key cryptography is used to
authorize transactions and maintain the
system thanks to its two key structures
changes are reflected across the
blockchain's peer-to-peer Network only
if it is approved from both ends along
along with asymmetric key cryptography
stamp approve architecture its non-
repudiation characteristic also helps in
keeping the network
stable we can also use asymmetry key
cryptography combined with symmetry key
cryptography to monitor SSL or TLS
encrypted browsering sessions to make
sure nobody can steal up personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general it
plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity exchanging
the necessary encryption Keys required
and generating a session using those
keys to ensure maximum security instead
of the rather insecure HTTP website
format security parameters differ on a
session by session basis so the
verification process is consistent and
utterly essential to Modern data
security another great use of the
asymmetric key cryptography structure is
transmitting keys for symmetric key
cryptography with the most significant
difficulty in symmetric encryption being
key exchange asymmetric keys can help
clear the shortcoming
the original message is first encrypted
using a symmetry key the key used for
encrypting the data is then converted
into the cipher text using the
receiver's public key now we have two
Cipher text to transmit to the receiver
on receiving both of them the receiver
uses his private key to decrypt the
Symmetry key he can then use it to
decrypt the original information on
getting the key used to encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just asymmetric ke cryptography
alone symmetric encryption algorithms
are much more optimized for vast amounts
of data on some occasions encrypting the
key using asymmetric algorithms will
definitely be more memory efficient and
secure you might remember us discussing
why symmetric encryption was called
private key cryptography let us
understand why asymmetric falls under
the public key
cryptography we have two keys at our
disposal the encryption key is available
to everyone the decryption key is
supposed to be private
unlike symmetric key cryptography there
is no need to share anything privately
to have an encrypted messaging system to
put that into perspective we share our
email address with anyone looking to
communicate with us it is supposed to be
public by Design so that our email login
credentials are private and they help in
preventing any data mishandling since
there is nothing hidden from the world
if they want to send us any encrypted
information this category is called the
public key
cryptography there are quite a few
algorithms being used today that follow
the architecture of asymmetric
cryptography none more famous than the
RS
encryption RSA encryption is the most
widely used encryption or public key
encryption standard using asymmetry key
approach named after its Founders reest
Shamir and Adelman it uses block ciphers
to obscure the information if you are
unfamiliar with how block ciphers work
there are encryption algorithms that
divide the original data into blocks of
equal size the block size depends on the
exact Cipher being used once they are
broken down these blocks are encrypted
individually and later chained together
to form the final Cipher
text widely considered to be the most
secure form of encryption or bit
relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms it is widely used
in web browsing secure identification
vpns emails and other chat
applications with so many variables in
play there must follow teaches that give
asymmetrically cryptography an edge over
the traditional symmetric encryption
methodologies let's go through some of
them there is no need for any reliable
key sharing channel in asymmetric
encryption it was an added risk in
private key cryptography that has been
completely eliminated in public key
architecture the key which is made
public cannot recpt any confidential
information and the only key that can
decrypt doesn't need to be shared
publicly under any circumstance
we have much more extensive key lens in
RSA encryption and other asymmetric
algorithms like 248 bit key and 496 bit
Keys larger keys are much harder to
break into via brute force and are much
more
secure asymmetry key cryptography can
use as a proof of authenticity since
only the rightful owner of the keys can
generate the messages to be decrypted by
the private key the situation can also
be reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the
owner it also has a tamper protection
feature where the message cannot be
intercepted and changed without
invalidating the private key used to
encrypt the data consequently the public
key cannot equip the message and it is
easy to realize the information is not
100% legitimate when and where the case
requires now that we have a proper
revision let's understand what digital
signatures are before moving on to the
algorithm the objective of digital
signatures is to authenticate and verify
documents and data this is necessary to
avoid tampering and digital modification
or forgery of any kind during the
transmission of official
documents they work on the public key
cryptography architecture with one
exception typically an asymmetry key
system encrypts using a public key and
decrypts with the the private key for
digital signatures however the reverse
is
true the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key because the keys are ink
together decoding it with the public key
verifies that the proper private key was
used to sign the document thereby
verifying the signatures Provence let's
go through each step to understand the
procedure thoroughly in step one we have
M which is the original plane text
message and it is passed onto a hash
function denoted by H hash to create a
digest next it bundles the message
together with the hash digest and
encrypts it using the sender private
key it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
sender public
key once the message is decrypted it is
passed through the same hash function H
hash to generate a similar
digest it compares the newly generated
hash with the bundled hash value
received along with the message if they
match it verifies data
Integrity in many instances they provide
a layer of validation and security to
messages through non-secure Channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver reason to believe
that the message was sent by the claimed
sender digital signatures are equivalent
to traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects but properly implemented
digital signatures are more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type digital
signature schemes in the sense used here
are cryptographically based and must be
implemented properly to be effective
they can also provide non-repudiation
meaning that the signer cannot
successfully claim that they did not
sign a message while also claiming their
private key remains secret further some
non-repudiation schemes offer a Tim
stamp for the digital signature so that
even if the private key is exposed the
signature is
valid to implement the concept of
digital signature in real world we have
two primary algorithms to follow the RSA
algorithm and the DSA algorithm but the
latter is a topic of learning today so
let's go ahead and see what the digital
signature algorithm is supposed to
do digital signature algorithm is a fips
standard which is a federal information
processing standard for digital
signature
it was proposed in 1991 and globally
standardized in 1994 by the National
Institute of Standards and Technology
also known as the nist it functions on
the framework of modular exponation and
discrete logarithmic problems which are
difficult to compute as a force brute
system unlike DSA most signature types
are generated by signing message digest
with the private key of the originator
this creates a digital thumbprint of the
data since just the message digest is
signed the signature is generally much
smaller compared to the data that was
signed as a result digital signatures
impose less load on processors at the
time of signing execution and they use
small volumes of bandwidth DSA on the
other hand does not encrypt message
digest using private key or decp message
digest using public key instead it uses
mathematical functions to create a
digital signature consisting of two 160
bit numbers which are originated from
the message digests and the private key
DCS make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is much more
complicated when compared with RSA DSA
also provides three benefits which is
the message authentication Integrity
verification and non-
repudiation in the image we can see the
entire process of DSF validation a plain
text message is passed onto a hash
function where the digest is generated
which is passed onto a signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable g a
random variable K and the private key of
the
sender the outputs are then bundled onto
a single pack with a plain text and sent
to the receiver the two outputs we
receive from the signing functions are
the two 160 bit numbers denoted by S and
R on the receiver end we pass the plane
text to the same hash function to
regenerate the message digest it is
passed onto verification function which
has other requirements such as the
public key of the sender Global variable
G and SNR received from the
sender the value generated by the
function is then compared to R if they
match then the verification process is
complete and data Integrity is verified
this was an overview of the way the DSA
algorithm works you already already know
it depends on logarithmic functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next
section we have three phases here the
first of which is key generation to
generate the keys we need some
prerequisites we select a q which
becomes a prime divisor we select a
prime number P such that P minus 1 mod Q
equal to 0 we also select a random
integer G which must satisfy the two
formulas being mentioned on the the
screen right now once these values are
selected we can go ahead with generating
the keys the private key can be denoted
by X and it is any random integer that
falls between the bracket of zero and
the value of Q the public key can be
calculated as y = to G ^ x mod P where y
stands for the public key the private
key can then be packaged as a one bundle
which comprises of values of p q G and X
similarly the public key can also be
packaged as a bundle having the values
of p q G and Y once we're done with key
generation we can start verifying the
signature and this
generation repeat once the keys are
generated we can start generating the
signature the message is passed through
a hash function to generate the digest
Edge first we can choose any random
integer K which Falls under the bracket
of 0 and Q to calculate the first 160
bit number of a signing function of r we
use the formula g the^ k mod P into mod
Q similarly to calculate the value of
the second output that is s we use the
following formula that is shown on the
screen the signature can then be
packaged as a bundle having R and
S this bundle along with a plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver now with the third phase we
have to verify the signature we first
calculate the message digest received in
the bundle by passing it to the same
hash function we calculate the value of
w U1 and U2 using the formulas shown on
the screen we have to calculate a
verification component which is then to
be compared with the value of R being
sent by the sender this verification
component can be calculated using the
following formula
once calculated this can be compared
with the value of R if the values match
then the signature verification is
successful and our entire process is
complete starting from Key generation to
the signature Generation all the way up
to the verification of the
signature with so many steps to follow
we are bound to have a few advantages to
boot this and we would be right to think
so DSA is highly robust in the security
and stability aspect when compared to
Alternative signature verification
algorithms we have a few other ciphers
that aim to achieve the Simplicity and
the flexibility of DSA but it has been a
tough ask for all the other
suits the key generation is much faster
when compared to the RSA algorithm and
such while the actual encryption and
decryption process May falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
beginning is well known to optimize a
lot of
Frameworks
DSA requires Less storage space to work
its entire cycle in contrast its direct
correspondent that is RSA algorithm
needs a certain amount of computational
and storage space to function
efficiently this is not the case with
DSA which has been optimized to work
with weaker hardware and lesser
resources the DSA is patented but nist
has made this patent available worldwide
royalty-free a draft version of the
speculation fips 1865 indicates that DSA
will no longer be approved for digital
signature generation but it may be used
to verify signatures generated prior to
the implementation date of that
standard the RSA algorithm is a public
key signature algorithm developed by Ron
reest ADI Shamir and Leonard Edelman the
paper was first published in 1977 and
the algorithm uses logarithmic functions
to keep the working complex and enough
to withstand brute force and streamlined
enough to be fast post deployment RSA
can also encrypt and decrypt general
information to securely exchange data
along with handling digital signature
verification let us understand how it
achieve this we take our Plaine text
message M we pass it through a hash
function to generate the digest H which
is then encrypted using the senders
private key this is appended to the
original plane text message and sent
over to the receiver
once the receiver receives the bundle we
can pass the plane text message through
the same hash function to generate a
digest and the cipher text can be
decrypted using the public key of the
sender the remaining hashes are compared
if the values match then the data
Integrity is verified and the sender is
authenticated apart from digital
signatures the main case of RSA is
encryption and decryption of private
information before being transmitted
across communication challenge this is
where the data encryption comes into
play when using RSA for encryption and
decryption of General data it reverses
the key set usage unlike signature
verification it receives the receiver's
public key to encrypt the data and uses
the receiver's private key in decrypting
the data thus there is no need to
exchange any keys in this scenario there
are two broad components when it comes
to RSA cryptography one of them is key
generation key generation employs a step
of generating the private and the public
keys that are going to be used for for
encrypting and decrypting the data the
second part is the encryption and
decryption functions these are the
ciphers and steps that need to be run
when scrambling the data or recovering
the data from the cipher text you will
Now understand each of these steps in
our next
subtopic keeping the previous two
concepts in mind let us go ahead and see
how the entire process works starting
from creating the keeper to encrypting
and decrypting the
information you need to generate the
public and private Keys before running
the functions to generate Cipher text
and plane text they use certain
variables and parameters all of which
are explained we first use two large
prime numbers which can be denoted by P
and Q we can compute the value of n as n
= p into q and compute the value of Zed
as P -1 into Q
-1 a number e is chosen at random
satisfying the following conditions and
a number D is also selected at random
following the formula Ed mod Z equal to
1 and it can be calculated with the
formula given
below the public ke is then packaged as
a bundle with n and E and the private
key is packaged as a bundle using n and
D the sums of the key generation
process for the encryption and
decryption function we use the formula C
and M the cipher Tex can be calculated
as c = m ^ e mod n and the pl Tex can be
calculated from the cipher text as C
power D mod n when it comes to a data
encryption example let's take p and Q as
7 and 13 the value of n can be
calculated as
91 if we select the value of e to be 5
it satisfy all the criteria that we
needed to the value of D can be
calculated using the following function
which gives it as 29 the public key can
then be packaged as 91a 5 and the
private key can then be packaged as 91a
29 the plain text if it is 10 which is
denoted by m Cipher text can be
calculated the formula c = m^ e mod n
which gives us 82 if somebody receives
this Cipher text they can calculate the
plain text using the formula C to the^ D
mod n which gives us the value of 10 as
selected as our plane
text we can now look at the factors that
make the RSA algorithm Stand Out versus
its competitors in the advantageous
topic of this
lesson RSA encryption depends on using
the receiver's public key so that you
don't have to share any secret key to
receive the messages from others this
was the most glaring flaw faced by
symmetric algorithms which were
eventually fixed by asymmetric
cryptography
structure since the key pairs are
related to each other a receiver cannot
intercept the message since they didn't
have the correct private keys to decrypt
the information if a public key can
decrypt the information information the
sender cannot refuse signing it with his
private key without admitting the
private key is not in fact private
anymore the encryption process is faster
than that of the DSA algorithm even if
the key generation is slower in RSA many
systems across the world tend to reuse
the same keys so that they can spend
less time in key generation and more
time on actual Cipher text
management data will be tamper proof in
transit since meddling with the data
will alter the use M of the keys the
private key won't be able to decp the
information hence alerting the receiver
of any kind of manipulation in between
the receiver must be aware of any third
party who possesses the private key
since they can alter the data mid
Transit the cases of which are rather
low imagine creating an account on a new
website you provide your email address
and set a password that you are
confident and you would not forget what
about the website owner how securely are
they going to store your
password for website administrators they
have three Alternatives they can either
store the passwords in a plain text
format they can encrypt the passwords
using an encryption and decryption key
or they can store the passwords in a
hash value let's have a look at each of
these when a password is stored in
cleant text format it is considered to
be the most unsafe option since anyone
in the company can read your passwords a
single hack and a data server breach
will expose all all the accounts
credentials without needing any extra
effort to counter this owners can
encrypt the passwords and keep them in
the servers as a second alternative but
that would mean they also have to store
the decryption key somewhere on their
servers in the event of a data breach or
the server hack both the decryption key
and encrypted passwords will be leaked
thus making it a single point of
failure what if there was an option to
store the passwords after scrambling
them completely but with no way to
decrypt them
this is where hashing comes to play
since only the hashed values are stored
in the server no encryption is needed
with no plain text passwords to protect
your credentials are safe from the
website administrators considering all
the pros hashed passwords are the
industry standard when it comes to
storing credentials
nowadays before getting too deep into
the topic let's get a brief overview of
how hashing
Works hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of information or
data beyond recognition we can achieve
this by using hash functions which are
essentially algorithms that perform
mathematical operations on the main
plane text the value generated after
passing the plain text information
through the hash function is called the
hash value digest or in general just the
hash of the original data while this may
sound similar to encryption the major
difference is hashes are meant to be
irreversible no decryption key can
convert a digest back to its original
value however a few hashing algorithms
have been broken due to the increase in
computational complexity of today's new
generation computers and processors
there are new algorithms that stand the
test of time and are still in use among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification
Etc like we discussed earlier websites
use hashing to store the users passwords
so how do they make use of these hash
passwords
when a user signs up to create a new
account the password is then run through
the hash function and the resulting hash
value is stored on the servers so the
next time a user comes to log to the
account the password he enters is passed
through the same hash function and
compared to the hash stored on the main
server if the newly calculated hash is
the same as the one stored on the
website server the password must have
been correct because according to Hash
functions terminology same inputs will
always provide the same
outputs if the hashes do not match then
the password entered during login is not
the same as the password entered during
the signup hence the login will be
denied this way no plain text passwords
get stored preventing both the owner
from snooping on user data and
protecting users privacy in the
unfortunate event of a data breach or a
hack apart from password storage hashing
can also be used to perform Integrity
checks when a file is uploaded on the
internet the file's hash value is
generated and it is uploaded along with
the original information when a new user
downloads the file he can calculate the
digest of the downloaded file using the
same hash function when the hash values
are compared if they match then file
Integrity has been maintained and there
has been no data
corruption since so much important
information is being passed on the hash
function we need to understand how they
work
a hash function is a set of mathematical
calculations operated on two blocks of
data the main input is broken down into
two blocks of similar size the block
size is dependent on the algorithm that
is being
used hash functions are designed to be
one way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by Design some algorithms like the
previously mentioned md5 have been
compromised but more secure algorithms
are being used today like the sh F of
algorithms the Digest is also dependent
on the respective algorithm being used
md5 has a digest of 128 bits while sh
256 has a digest of 256 bits this digest
must always be the same for the same
input irrespective of how many times the
calculations are carried out this is a
very crucial feature since comparing the
hash value is the only way to check if
the data is untouched as the functions
are not
reversible there are certain
requirements of a hash function that
need to be met before they are accepted
while some of them are easy to guess
others are placed in order to preserve
Security in the long
run the hash function must be quick
enough to encrypt large amounts of data
at a relatively Fast Pace but it also
shouldn't be very fast running the
algorithm on all cylinders makes the
functions easy to boot force and a
security liability there must be a
balance to allow the hash function to
handle large amounts of data and not
make it ridiculously easy to Brute Force
by running through all the possible
combinations the hash function must be
dependent on each bit of the input the
input can be text audio video or any
other file extension if a single
character is being changed it doesn't
matter how small that character may be
the entire digest must have a distinctly
different hash value this is essential
to create unique digest for every
password that is being stor but what if
two different users are using the same
password since the hash function is the
same for all users both the digests will
be the same this is called a hash
Collision you may think this must be a
rare occasion where two users have
exactly the same password but that is
not the case we have techniques like
salting that can be used to reduce these
hash collisions as we will discuss later
in this
video you would be shocked to see the
most used passwords of 2020 all of of
these passwords are laughably insecure
and since many people use the same
passwords repeatedly on different
websites hash collisions risk are more
common than one would
expect let's say the hash functions find
two users having the same password how
can they store both the hashers without
messing up the original data this is
where salting and peppering come to
play salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function this random keyword is unique
for each user on the system and it is
called the salt value or just the salt
so even if two passwords are exactly the
same the solt value will differ and so
will the digest there is a small problem
with this process though since the salt
is unique for each user they need to be
stored in the database along with the
passwords and sometimes even in plain
text to speed up the process of
continuous verification if the server is
hacked then the hashes will need to be
brute forced which takes a a lot of time
but if they receive the salts as well
the entire process becomes very fast
this is something that peppering aims to
solve peppering is the process of adding
a random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case the pepper isn't
stored on the servers it is mostly
hardcoded onto the website source code
since it's going to be the same for all
credentials this way even if the servers
get hacked they will not have the right
pepper needed to crack into all the
passwords many websites use a
combination of salting and peppering to
solve the problem of hash collision and
bolster security since Brute Force takes
such a long time many hackers avoid
taking the effort the returns are mostly
not worth it and the possible
combinations of using both salting and
peppering is
humongous with the consensus aiming
towards an educated public on digital
privacy it's no surprise to see an
increasing interest in encryption
algorithms we have already covered the
major names like the dees and the AES
algorithm md5 algorithm was one of the
first hashing algorithms to take the
global stage as a successor to the md4
despite the security vulnerabilities
encountered in the future md5 Still
Remains means a crucial part of data
infrastructure in a multitude of
environments the md5 hashing algorithm
is a one-way cryptographic functions
that accepts a message of any length as
input and it returns as output a fixed
length digest value to be used for
authenticating the original messages the
digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective of the input the md5 hash
function was originally designed for use
as a secure cryptog hash algorithm to
authenticate digital signatures md5 has
also been depreciated for users other
than as a non-cryptographic check sum to
verify data integrity and detect
unintentional data
corruption Ronald dest founder of RSA
data security and Institute professor at
MIT designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm which was
the
md4 as already iterated before the
process is straightforward we pass up PL
text message to the md5 hash functions
which in turn perform certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data the 128bit
digest received from this is going to be
radically different from the plane text
the goal of any message digest function
is to produce digest that appear to be
random to be considered
cryptographically secure the hash
functions should meet two requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that Ma
is a specific hash value and second that
it is impossible for an attacker to
create two messages that produce the
same hash value even a slight change in
the plane text should trigger a drastic
difference in the two digest this goes a
long way in preventing hash collisions
which take place when two different PL
deex have the same
digest to achieve this level of
intricacy there are a number of steps to
be followed before we receive the diges
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plane text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when we receive the
input string we have to make sure the
size is 64 bits short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first followed by zeros to
round out the extra characters this
prepares a string to have a length of
just 64 bits less than any multiple of
512 here and out we can proceed On To
The Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total length of the bits in the
message was 64 bits short of any
multiple of 512 now we add the length
bits in such a way that the total number
of bits in the message is perfectly a
multiple of
512 that that means 64 bit lens to be
precise are added to the message our
final string to be hashed is now a
definite multiple of
512 The Next Step would be to initialize
the message digest buffer the entire
hashing plane text is now broken down
into 512-bit
blocks there are four buffers or
registers that are of 32 bits each named
a b c and
d these are the four words that are
going to store the values of each of
these
subblocks the first iteration to follow
these registers will have fixed
hexadecimal values as shown on the
screen
below once these values are
initial of these 512 blocks we can
divide each of them into 16 further
subblocks of 32 bits each for each of
these subblocks we run four rounds of
operations having the four buffer
variables a b c and and D these rounds
require the other constant variables as
well which defer with each round of
operation the constant values are stored
in a random array of 64 elements since
each 32-bit subblock is run four times
16 such subblocks equal 64 constant
values needed for a single block
iteration the subblocks can be denoted
by the alphabet M and the constant
values are denoted by the alphabet
T coming to the actual round of
operation ation we see our four buffers
which already have pre-initialized
values for the first iteration at the
very beginning the values of buffers b c
and d are passed on to a nonlinear
logarithmic function the formula behind
this function changes by the particular
round being worked on as we shall see
later in this video Once the output is
calculated it is added to the raw value
stored in buffer a the output of this
addition is added to the particular
32bit subblock using which we are
running the four
operations the output of this requisite
function then needs to be added to a
constant value derived from the constant
array K since we have 64 different
elements in the array repeat since we
have 64 different elements in the array
we can use a distinct element for each
iteration of a particular block The Next
Step involves a circular shift that
increases the complexity of the hash
algorithm and is necessary to create a
unique digest for each individual in
outut the output generated is later
added to the value stored in the buffer
B the final output is now stored in the
second buffer of B of the output
register individual values of c d and a
are derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in C value of C
gets stored in D and the value of D in a
now that we have a full register ready
for this subblog BL the values of a c d
are moved on as input to the next
subblock Once all 16 subblocks are
completed the final register value is
saved and the next 512-bit block begins
at the end of all these blocks we get a
final digest of the md5
algorithm regarding the nonlinear
process mentioned in the first step the
formula changes for each round it's
being run on this is done to maintain
the computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase r randomness
of the procedure the formula for each of
the four rounds uses the same parameters
that is b c and d to generate a single
output the formulas being used are shown
on the screen right
now algorithm unlike the latest hash
algorithm families a 32-bit digest is
relatively easier to compare when
verifying the digests they don't consume
a noticeable amount of disc storage and
are comparatively easier to remember and
reiterate
passwords need not be stored in plain
text format making them accessible for
hackers and malicious actors when using
digest the database security also gets a
boost since the sizes of all the hash
values will be the same in the event of
a hack or a breach the malicious actor
will only receive the hashed values so
there is no way to regenerate the plain
text which would be the user passwords
in this case since the functions are
irreversible by Design hashing has
become a compulsion when storing user
credentials on the server
nowadays a relatively low memory
footprint is necessary when it comes to
integrating multiple Services into the
same framework without a CPU overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string this helps in creating a low
requirement for computational power and
is much easier to run on older Hardware
which is pretty common in server farms
around the
world we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
Transit once the hash is match file
Integrity checks are valid and we can
avoid data
corruption hash functions will always
give the same output for the similar
input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the receiver of the message
we use our Wi-Fi everyday for work and
we use the internet for entertainment
and communication the dependency on
technology is at an all-time high thanks
to the radical developments and
innovation in these last two decades a
big portion of this belongs to ensuring
secure channels of communication and
data
transmission the secure hash algorithm
are a family of cryptographic hash
functions that are published by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology along with the NSA it was
passed as a federal information
processing standard also known as FPS it
has four different families of hash
functions ssj 0 is a 160 bit hash
function published in 1993 and it was
closed down later after an undisclosed
significant flaw sha1 is also a 160 bit
hash function which resembles the
earlier md5 algorithm this was designed
by the NSA to be a part of the digital
signature
algorithm S2 is a family of two similar
hash functions with different block
sizes known as the Sha 256 and the Sha
512 they differ in the word size sha256
uses 32 bit words while sha 512 uses
64bit words sha3 is a hash function
properly known as kak it was chosen in
2012 after a public competition among
non NS designers it supports the same
hash lens as H2 and its internal
structure differs significantly from the
rest of the sh family as we have already
iterated the process is straightforward
we pass a plain text message to the sh
hash function which in turn performs
certain mathematical operations on the
clear text to scramble the data the 160
bit digest received from this is going
to be radically different from the plain
text the goal of any hash function is to
produce Digest that appear to be random
to be considered cryptographically
secure the hash function should meet two
requirements first that it is impossible
for an attacker to generate a message
that matches a specific hash value and
second it should be impossible for an
attacker to create two messages
producing the exactly same hash value
even a slight change in the plane text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest this goes a long way in
preventing hash collisions which takes
place when two different plane text have
the same
digest the Sha family functions have
some characteristics that they need to
follow while generating the digest let's
go through a few of
them the length of the clear text should
be less than 2 the^ 64 bits in the case
of sh 1 and
s256 this is essential to keep the
Plaine text compatible with the hash
function and the size needs to be in
comparison area to keep the digest as
random as
possible the length of the hash digest
should be 256 bits in the Sha 256
algorithm 512 bits in the Sha 512
algorithm and so on bigger digest
usually suggests significantly more
calculations at the cost of speed and
space we typically go for the longest
diges to bolster security but there must
be a definite balance between the speed
and security of a hash function
by Design all hash function of the Sha
512 s256 are
irreversible you should neither get a
plain text when you have the digest
beforehand nor should the digest provide
the original value when you pass it
through the same hash function again
another case of protection is that when
the hash digest is passed into the Sha
function for a second time we should get
a completely different digest from the
first instance this is done to reduce
the chance of Brute Force
attacks to achieve this level of
intricacy there are a number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the Sha algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plain text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when you receive the
input string you have to make sure the
size is 64bit short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the mids
you must add one first followed by the
remaining zeros to round out the extra
characters this prepares our string to
have a length just 64 bits less than any
multiple of
512 here on out we can proceed to The
Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total number of bits in the
message was 64 bits short from becoming
a multiple of I 52 now we add the length
of bits in such a way that the total
number of bits in the message is a
perfect multiple of
512 that means 64 bits plus the length
of the original message becomes a
multiple of 512 this becomes a final
string that needs to be
hashed in the next step we have to
initialize this chaining
variables the entire plain text message
can now be broken down into blocks of
512 bits each
unlike other hash algorithms like md5
which use four registers or buffers sha
family use five buffers of 32 bits each
they are named a b c d and e these
registers go through multiple rounds of
operation where the first iteration has
fixed H decimal values as can be seen in
the
screen moving on we have to process each
of the 512-bit blocks by breaking each
of them into 16 subblocks of 32 bits
each
each of them goes through four rounds of
operation that use the entire register
and have the 512-bit block along with
the constant array out of those four
rounds each round has 20 iterations so
in general we have 880 rounds some
total the constant value of K is an
array of 80
elements of those 80 16 elements are
being used each round so that comes out
to 80 rounds for each of those elements
the value of T differs by the number of
rounds as can be seen in the table
below a single formula is necessary to
calculate the output of each round and
iteration the formula can be AB CDE e
registor is equal to e plus a nonlinear
process P along with a circular shift of
a plus WT + KT in this formula ABCD is
the register value of the chaining
variables as we discussed before p is a
logical process which has a different
formula for each round S5 is a circular
shift by five bits and WT is a 32bit
string derived from the existing
subblock this can be calculated
depending on the iteration at
hand KT signifies a single element of
the 80 character element array which
changes depending on the particular
round at hand for the values of WT the
first 16 values are the same as that of
the the subblocks so there is no extra
calculation needed for the next 64
elements the value of WT can be
calculated as shown in the formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have our initial
register using the five words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
register as the
output next we use a nonlinear process B
that changes depending on the round and
uses the values of b c and d as
input whatever output is generated from
the nonlinear process it is added with
the value of the E
registor next the value of a is circular
shifted by five bits and is added with
the output generated in the previous
step the next step is adding the value
of WT and the constant element of KT the
current output is then stored in the
registor a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each
subblock in the process once all the
registers are complete and all the
subblocks are joined together to form
the single Cipher text message we will
have our hash output regarding the
nonlinear process P that uses the values
of b c and d as input the formula
changes every round to maintain a
complexity of the program that can
withstand Brute Force attacks depending
on the round the values are pass through
a logical operation which is then added
with the values of WT KT and so on now
that we understand how to get our hash
digest from the plain text let us learn
about the advantages we obtain when
using the Sha hash algorithm instead of
relying on data in a plain text
format digital signatures follow
asymmetric encryption methodology to
verify the authenticity of a document or
a file hash algorithms like sh 256 and
the industry standard sha 512 go a long
way in ensuring the verification of
signatures passwords need not be stored
in a plain text format which makes them
accessible to hackers and other
malicious actors when using digest the
database security also gets a boost
since the size of all hash values will
be the same in the event of a hack or a
breach the malicious actor will only
receive the hash values with no way to
regenerate the plane text in this this
case the pl text would be user
credentials since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing passwords on the
servers the SSL handshake is a crucial
segment of the web browsing sessions and
it's done using sha functions it
consists of your web browsers and the
web servers agreeing on encryption keys
and hashing authentication to prepare a
secure connection it relies on a
combination of symmetric and asymmetric
algorithms which ensure the
confidentiality of the data transmitted
between a web server and a web client
like the
browsers you can monitor file corruption
by comparing hash values before and
after Transit once the hash is matched
file Integrity checks are valid and data
corruption is avoided hash functions
will always give the same output for the
same input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the receiver of the message
passwords are by far the most common
type of user authentication they are
popular because their Theory makes
perfect sense to individuals and is
reasonably simple to implement for
developers on the other hand poorly
constructed passwords can pose security
flaws a well-designed password-based
authentication process does not save the
user's actual password this would make
it far too simple for a hacker or a
malevolent Insider to access all of the
systems user accounts in this video you
will we learn how to crack passwords and
simultaneously try to make your
passwords as Brute Force resistant as
possible let's take a look at the topics
to be covered
today we start by learning about what is
password cracking in
general next we take a look at the
different techniques of password
cracking that hackers use in order to
generate user credentials for
hacking moving on we take a look at the
multiple tools that hackers can use to
generate these hashes and the passwords
finally we take a look at the steps and
the guidelines that users can follow to
prevent their passwords from being
cracked let's start by giving a basic
idea about password
cracking password cracking is the
process of identifying an unknown
password to a computer or a network
resource using a program code it can
also assist a threat actor in gaining
illegal access to resources malicious
actors can engage in various criminal
activities with information obtained
through password tracking the procedure
might entail comparing a set of words to
guess credentials or using an algorithm
to guess the password repeatedly
password cracking can be done for
several reasons but the most malicious
reason is in order to gain unauthorized
access to a computer without the owner's
awareness this results in cyber crime
such as stealing passwords for the
purpose of accessing banking information
other non-malicious reasons for password
cracking occur when someone has
misplaced or forgotten a password
another example of nor malicious
password cracking may take place if a
system administrator is conducting test
on password strength as a form of
security test this enables so that the
hacker cannot easily access protected
systems the best way that users can
protect their passwords from cracking is
to ensure that they choose strong
passwords typically passwords must
contain a combination of mixed case
random letters digits and
symbols strong passwords should never be
actual words in addition strong
passwords are at least eight characters
as long in many password protected
applications users are notified of the
strength of the password they've chosen
upon entering it the user can then
modify it and strengthen the password
based on the indications of its strength
now that we understand the basics of
password cracking let's go to the basic
techniques hackers use to retrieve
passwords from General
victims asking the customer for the
password is simple approach to hacking a
fishing email directs the unwar reader
to a counterfeit login page link with
whatever service the hacker wants to
access generally by demanding the user
fix some critical security flaw or Aid
in a database reset that page then
captures their password which the hacker
can subsequently exploit for their own
purpose social engineering influences
the victim to get personal information
such as bank account numbers or
passwords the strategy is popular among
hackers because they realize that humans
are the gateway to vital credentials and
information through social engineering
the employee tried and true tactics to
exploit and influence age-old human
Tendencies rather than devising novel
means to breach secure and Advanced
Technologies it has been demonstrated
that many firms either lack adequate
security or are overly friendly and
trustworthy when they should not be they
allow granting access to critical
facilities based on a uniform or a so
story a hacker searches a password
dictionary for the correct password in
the case of a dictionary attack
password dictionaries cover many themes
and of mixture of topics such as
politics movies and music groups users
failure to create a strong password is
why this approach efficiently cracks
passwords till today simply said this
assault employs the same terms that many
individuals use as passwords a hacker
can compare the password hash obtained
to hashes of the password dictionaries
to find the correct plain text
password now that the passwords have
been hashed the hackers attemp attempt
to achieve authentication by breaking
the password hash they accomplish this
by employing a rainbow table which is a
set of pre-computed hashes of portable
password
combinations hackers can use the rainbow
table to crack the hash resulting in
guessing your password as a result it
retrieves a password hash from the
system and eliminates any need to break
it furthermore it does not necessitate
the discovery of the password itself the
breach is accomplished if the hash
matches in a bro Force assault the
attacker attempts multiple password
combinations until the correct one is
identified the attacker uses software to
automate this process and run exhaustive
password combination in a substantially
shorter length of time with the growth
of hardware and technology in recent
years such programs have been
invigorated it won't be quick if your
password is more than a few characters
lengthy but it will eventually reveal
your password Brute Force assaults can
be sped up by throwing more processing
resources at
them with so so many different
techniques coming together to correct
passwords none of them are useful
without the right tools there are a prra
of scripts and Snippets of code that can
retrieve passwords from either encrypted
storage or from the hash digest let's go
through some of these
tools cane and able is a password
recovery tool for Microsoft operating
systems it allows easy recovery of
various kinds of passwords by sniffing
the network cracking encrypted passwords
using dictionary brute force and crypt
analysis attacks recording Vibe
conversations decoding scrambled
passwords recovering wireless network
Keys Etc are some of the other features
of K enable the latest version is faster
and contains a lot of new features like
ARP poison routing which enables
sniffing on switch Lance and man in the-
Middle attacks the sniffer in this
version can also analyze encrypted
protocols such as ssh1 and https while
containing filters to capture
credentials from a wide range of
authentication
mechanisms it also ships routing
protocol authentication monitors and
Route
extractors dictionary and boot Force
crackers are also present along with
common hashing algorithms and several
specific authentications password hash
calculators and other
features John the Ripper is a password
cracking application that was first
released in 1996 for unix-based
computers it was created to evaluate
password strength Brute Force encrypted
hash passwords and break passwords using
dictionary attacks it can use dictionary
attacks rainbow tables and other attacks
depending on the target
type Rainbow Crack is a password
cracking application that uses time
memory trade-off algorithm to crack
password hashes with rainbow tables
rainbow tables make password cracking
more easier and faster than traditional
Brute Force attacks it is like a
dictionary containing nearly every
possible password and the pre-calculated
hashes creating this kind of dictionary
takes much more more time than cracking
a single hash but after that you can use
the same dictionary over and over again
this procedure might take a long time
however once the table is ready it can
break passwords far quicker than Brute
Force
methods with so many tools ready to naab
our passwords there are certain set of
rules users can follow to protect their
credentials from being compromised let's
cover some of these
guidelines longer passwords are required
making the Brute Force mechanism tough
eff to implement longer passwords and
pass phrases have been demonstrated to
boost security significantly however it
is still critical to avoid lenier
passwords that have previously been
hacked or that feature often in cracking
dictionaries this password policy
encourages users to establish passwords
that do not contain personal
information as previously said most
users create passwords utilizing
personal information such as Hobbies
nicknames pet or family member names et
Etc if a hacker has access to personal
information about a specific user for
example via social media they will test
password combinations based on that
knowledge password regulations should
compel users to distinguish between
security and convenience users should be
prohibited from using the same password
for all services password sharing
between users including those who work
in the same department or use the same
equipment should be avoided a single
breached password doesn't ffect your
other accounts with this
policy some password regulations
necessitate the creation of a pass
phrase rather than a pass word while
pass phrases serve the same objective
the length make them more difficult to
break in addition to letters a good pass
should include numbers and symbols
passwords may be easier for users to
remember than pass phrases however the
latter is much more breach
resistant two- Factor authentication or
2fa can help secure an online account or
even a smartphone tofa does this by
asking the user to provide two forms of
information a password or a personal
identification PIN and a code texted to
the user smartphone or a fingerprint
before accessing whatever is secured
this helps discourage unauthorized
entries to an account without the
original owner's permission at this
point you may wonder why you need a
strong password in the first place even
if most websites are safe there is still
a danger that someone will try to access
or exploit you information a strong
password is among the most effective
ways to protect your accounts and
personal information from hackers you
should follow certain rules and
guidelines while creating a strong
password password managers are also
recommended to help remember the created
passwords for convenience of
usage with that being said let's take a
look at the topics we are covering
today we start by learning about the
state of password cracking in today's
world and why creating strong passwords
is an absolute must for every account
next we will look at some guidelines and
rules that help strengthen passwords and
make password cracking a daunting task
for hackers moving on we understand why
past faes have grown in popularity and
are being recommended for credential
protection over traditional passwords
and finally we take a look at how
password managers help alleviate the
problem of creating and remembering
complex passwords along with other
critical personal
information let's start by learning
about why strong passwords have become
an absolute
necessity one of the most common ways
that hackers break into computers is by
guessing passwords simple and commonly
used passwords enable Intruders to
easily gain access and control a
Computing device conversely a password
that is difficult to guess makes it
prohibitively difficult for common
hackers to break into a machine and will
force them to look for another Target
the more difficult the password the
lower the likelihood that once's
computer will fall victim to an unworn
wanted intrusion many individuals opt to
tie their websites to something they can
readily recall to generally easy
memorable combos however this does not
make the password unique in fact it's
the reverse passwords are handled by 53%
of individuals using their Recollections
and memory with modern computational
standards simple passwords take seconds
and a couple of minutes at worst to be
completely brute forced according to
Global surveys more than 60% of people
use the same passwords for the person
and job applications while this may
allow the user never to forget the
password it makes a single point of
failure the only pin to drop if one of
the accounts gets breached all
subsequent accounts are as good as
hacked to further elaborate on how you
can create strong passwords let's go
through some of the
guidelines let's go through some dos and
don'ts to understand how to create new
passwords for accounts it is recommended
to keep the password length at at least
12 characters to ensure brute forcing to
be
difficult a combination of upper and
lowercase alphabets is an absolute
necessity when creating strong
passwords it is also recommended to use
numerics along with those alphabets to
create a complicated
password finally special characters help
in making a password much more Brute
Force resistant than any number of
alphabets or letters can make move
moving over to the Don
section it's absolutely not recommended
to keep Simple dictionary terms such as
computer or even the word password as
your credential because those are very
easy to be brute forced and are usually
present in majority of the dictionary
attack word list similarly changing a
single alphabet or a single character in
a dictionary word does not make it brute
for instant considering there are
already algorithms present that can
counter this tactic
using the same character multiple times
in a password also reduces the strength
and makes it easier to crack for
hackers apart from using single
characters multiple times following
patterns that are present on the
traditional English keyboard such as e w
t y or the line below the main alphabet
such as the ZX c vbn m Etc make it
easier to guess since these are once
again common combinations that are
present in word list or
ready finally the most important part
being not using personal information
such as birthdays addresses and other
important information in the passwords
more often than not if a hacker is
trying to break into your account there
has been some amount of research done be
it via social media or any other medium
if they have already this information
present with them breaking into your
account becomes all the more
easier now that you understand how to
create strong password look at how pass
phrases have become prevalent as a
replacement for plain text
passwords a passphrase is a
sentence-like string of words used for
authentication that is longer than a
traditional password easy to remember
and difficult to crack typical passwords
range on an average from 8 to 16
characters while pass phrases can reach
up to 100 characters or more using a
long fast phrase instead of a short
password to create a digital signature
is one of the main any ways that users
can strengthen the security of their
data devices and accounts the longer a
passphrase is the more likely a user is
to incorporate bits of entropy or
factors that make it less predictable to
potential attackers as more websites
applications and services increase the
user security requirements a PPH is a
fast and easy way to meet these
criterias let's take a look at some of
the advantages that pass faes have over
common
passwords
past phases are simpler to remember than
just a random assortment of symbols and
characters it's easier to comprehend a
line from your favorite song or a
quotation than a short but difficult
password passwords are reasonably easy
for humans and robots to guess or crack
online thieves have also Advanced and
created Cutting Edge hacking tools to
crack even the most complex
passwords pass phrases are nearly hard
to crack since most efficient password
cracking programs fail at approximately
10 characters as a result even the most
sophisticated cracking tool will be
unable to guess brute force or
pre-compute these passwords complies
with password setting rules with E
passphrases the usage of punctuation and
upper and lowercase password satisfy the
password complexity criteria most
operating systems and apps support pass
phrases freezes of up to 127 characters
are permitted on all major operating
systems including windows Linux and Mac
as a result for optimal protection you
can use lengthier pass
phrases but when creating a strong
password the major problem people come
across is remembering these passwords or
the pass phrases this is where you can
find a use for a password
manager when you establish accounts or
change passwords password managers
generate new strong passwords and they
keep all of them in one place protected
by a single strong master password
if you maintain your master password the
manager will retain everything else
including your username and passphrases
and fill them in for you whenever you
sign on to a website or app on your
computer or phone there is no good
memory needed for this this implies that
everyone may use the most recent
suggestions for strong passwords such as
extended phrases symbols grammar and
capitalization password managers enable
consumers to write a single master
password and automatically F each
website with their own unique set of
credentials and not just passwords
credit card information may be stored
securely with several password managers
some others make multiactor
authentication or use a second test such
as answering a question once the correct
password is input which is a simple and
effective solution to verify legitimate
login
inputs among the global players in
password managers services like bit
Warden keas and Ashlin have been running
for years now and are very worthy
recommendations if you want to get
started with password management now
that we understand what is hacking let's
take a look at some points to know
whether our system is already haed or
not the first point regarding how to
check whether a system is hacked or not
can be cases where the system security
is Switched Off by unknown means and it
is not visible to the user this is one
of the most most primary checkpoint to
know if our system is hacked or
not next point to check whether a system
is hacked or not would be frequent
antivirus software failures which are
due to the interference from hacking
attempts performed by a professional
hacker or a cyber
criminal then we also face problems
regarding systems reaction speed which
is affected due to the execution of
unknown application ations in the
background of the
system which also affects the hardware
resources in the
device next we also face problems
regarding passwords which are no longer
working or are changed without the
user's Intervention which might indicate
that there was some unknown hacking
activity that took place in our
account let's take a look at some more
points regarding the
topic there are often cases when the
system's cursor move on its own and
perform task indicating that the system
is being used by someone else using an
illegal hacking method there are also
cases when we often see files and
folders being created in the storage
disk on the
system which is unknown to us to better
understand the points regarding how to
identify ify whether our system is
hacked or not let's take a look then
let's start with the first
point if we want to check whether our
system is haed or not the first point
would be to choose the settings
option and using privacy and security
and moving on to the Windows security
this option that is available on our
system allows us to see various
protection applications that are Avil
available on the
system if we see any problem regarding
any one of them for example apps and
browser control in my system it says
there's a problem with it which might be
due to hacking attempts that was done on
my
system now let's take a look at the
other option how we can check whether
our system is hacked or not that would
be checking the antivirus software that
is installed in our system
if you face problems regarding that this
might be the
issue according to my antivirus software
it says my computer is at risk this
might be due to the interference from a
cyber criminal or a hacker while using
different illegal softwares during its
hacking
attempt then there are also
cases where we see there are unknown
programs being executed in the
background of a system
which we can take a look using the task
manager software using the task manager
we can take a look at each and every
application that is being executed in
the system and see the
origin if we find any unknown program or
application we can assume that it might
be due to a hacking
attempt moving on if we want to check
further whether our system is hacked or
not we can check for files of folders
that are being created unknown to us for
example this unknown
folder which contains some security
details that are unknown to
me this might be also due to a hacking
attempt by a hacker or a cyber
criminal then there are also cases when
the system's cursor move on its own and
perform tasks that are not initiated by
us and performs copying of different
folders or data from one file to other
this is due to a hacking attempt that
was done on a system and the hacker has
taken control of a
system then there are also cases
regarding login issues or password
problem for
example if I want to access into my
account and there's a problem with the
password it might be due
to
the attempt of hacking into my account
by a professional
hacker seems like there's a problem with
the username which means there was a
hacking attempt by a professional
hacker we can further check hacking
attempts by accessing our web browser
and checking whether there's some extra
add-ons or unknown add-ons that wasn't
installed bias this might also indicate
a hacking attempt on the system now that
we are clear about how to check whether
a system is hacked or not let's take a
look at some of the counter measure
against hacking let's
begin the first point regarding how to
avoid hacking is do regular manual
Security checks and keep the system
security updated using certified
antivirus softwares is a basic counter
measure against hacking attempts
and if possible visit only secure
websites for surfing on the Internet or
use VPN or other Internet Security
applications to mask your systems
Network to avoid any hacking attempts
for the
device then we have avoid clicking on
random web popups and ads to avoid
Hackers from getting into a system and
accessing a device
data and lastly use strong password
passwords or complex passwords for your
login
details applying these counter measures
we can avoid hacking to a certain extent
the concept of instant messaging crossed
into the mainstream in the 1990s
allowing friends acquaintances
colleagues and like-minded thinkers from
all over the world to connect in real
time since then instant messaging has
evolutionized how we communicate and
today over a billion people are signed
up for at least one messaging app the
present instant messaging experience is
seamless and it intuitively integrates
features like video photos voice
e-commerce and gaming with plain or
messaging among these apps WhatsApp has
comfortably found its place among the
most popular messaging platforms like
everyone associated with the internet a
matter of security is never far away
considering the huge user base of this
messaging app hackers are always on the
lookout for compromised accounts to grab
today we are going to cover some of the
ways we can protect our WhatsApp account
from falling into malicious
hands we start by learning about the
importance of security when it comes to
WhatsApp and instant messaging apps in
general next we cover some of the most
important steps that should be followed
in order to protect our WhatsApp
accounts from
hackers finally we learn what we should
do when a WhatsApp account gets
compromised let's start by learning why
we need to focus on the safety of
WhatsApp in the year of 2020 the big
news was about Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos and
his phone being haed by Saudi Arabia a
report coming from the guardian
suggested that bezos's phone was hacked
via a video file sent on WhatsApp the
report said that bz's mobile phone was
hacked by Saudi Arabian prince in the
year 2018 and gigabytes worth of data
was stolen from the device while there
are some issues being raised about the
report which states with the medium to
high confidence that Jeff piz's phone
was hacked it does raise a security fear
for regular users after all if the phone
of one of the world's most powerful men
can be hacked the same can happen to any
one of us as
well when it comes to regular users we
exchange messages with our loved ones
regarding a paradigm of topics the
information which may seem trivial
initially can later function as
ammunition for a campaign regarding
identity theft basic information like
preferred Banks occasional dining places
can go a long way in Social Engineering
attacks further increasing the need for
secure messaging habits WhatsApp uses
endtoend encryption to protect all
communication on its platform these
encryption keys not only make it
impossible to decp messages but they
also prevent third parties and even
WhatsApp from accessing messages or
calls but not entirely although endtoend
encryption makes WhatsApp more secure
than other communication apps no app is
100% safe to use like any application or
digital device WhatsApp is often
targeted by Bad actors it also has
access to your contact taxs and tracks
where and how long you use it putting
your privacy and personal information at
risk we all have access to our cell
phones so it's no surprise that sms2
factor authentication is one of the most
widespread types of MFA available you
don't need any apps or digital keys and
it's not tied to a specific ecosystem
unfortunately it's also not a secure
multiactor authentication method the
nature of SMS itself opens up your
organization to a host of risk hackers
may have many ways to leverage SMS to
find a way into your accounts and
network be it via spoofed SIM cards or
message hijacking WhatsApp tofa using
SMS isn't a foolproof
solution now that we understand the
variety of reasons why WhatsApp needs
extra security let's go through some of
the ways we can achieve
this it is more than probable that one
fine day you might receive a WhatsApp
message or even an SMS that reads that
your order is delayed please check its
data here or your account is locked and
please unlock it here or even some
tempting messages like win free 3G and
movie tickets here some of them may
sound intimidating and some of them may
be lucrative but they all have one
purpose to trick you into clicking that
link and once you do that it's already
over it will install malware on your
phone and you won't have a clue about it
only when you start noticing that your
phone bills are abnormally high or your
bank account has been used without your
permission the realization will Dawn
upon on you that something is wrong with
your phone but by then it may be too
late WhatsApp in itself provides various
privacy options to users the messaging
platform provides users with option to
choose who they want to share their
profile photo status and other details
with it's a good idea to change the
settings to contacts only this means
only phone numbers that are saved on
your smartphone will be able to see your
profile photo status phone number and
autod delete status as well
make sure you enable the option to log
the screen every time WhatsApp is closed
this will ensure no one else but you can
open your WhatsApp account just head to
the settings menu privacy and select the
screen lock option you will then need to
register your fingerprint after the
process is completed you will have to
scan your fingerprint every time you
open the WhatsApp app this adds an extra
layer of
security
the two-step verification works as an
extra layer of security and helps
WhatsApp users to protect their otps and
documents shared through WhatsApp it's
very easy to set up a PIN to activate a
two-step verification users have to
enter it periodically once it is
activated WhatsApp will sometimes keep
asking users to enter the six-digit
passcode users cannot disable this
without disabling the two-step
verification feature all together in
case users do not provide WhatsApp with
an email ID and want to disable two step
verification ation then the number will
be permitted to
reverifying messages upon reverifying
we often have the tendency to log into
to Whatsapp web at the office and then
leave the account open on the desktop
this habit can actually create problems
for you someone else sitting on the same
PC can access all your chats without you
even realizing it it's a good practice
to log out from WhatsApp web before
leaving the office it just takes a few
seconds to log in again by just scanning
the code and you're
done all WhatsApp users should ensure
that the chats are end to end encrypted
to verify that a chat is end to- endend
encrypted open the chat tap on the name
of the contact to open the contact info
screen and then tap encryption to view
the QR code and a 60 digigit number
WhatsApp n2n encryption ensures that
only you and your contact can read the
messages that are being exchanged and
nobody in between not even WhatsApp
with the necessary guidelines out of the
way let us go to the recommended course
of action should our WhatsApp accounts
be
compromised the first and most important
thing that you need to do is report the
issue to the WhatsApp support team for
assistance make sure that you reach out
to the support team through its help
desk and Report the hacking attempt
WhatsApp help center will take the
shortest time to resolve your issue via
email or within the app itself this will
help you to take prompt legal action
against the hackers if you can't access
your email call the support team in some
cases the support will deactivate your
WhatsApp account and request you to
reactivate within 30 days if you don't
want it to be deleted
completely when someone compromises your
WhatsApp account they can now send
messages to your contact stating that
the company sent your verification code
and gain access to the account that's
why one of the first things you'll want
to do is send a message to your friends
and family letting them know that you've
lost access to your account this action
prevents further exploitation of your
account and others another reason you'll
want to let your contracts know you have
no access to your WhatsApp account is
that they may fish for personal
information from your banking number to
your email address hackers will cleverly
attempt to gain as much access to your
personal information as
possible WhatsApp web is an extension of
WhatsApp messenger over the web that
facilitates easy synchronization of our
smartphone and personal computer this is
the biggest security that hackers can
easily exploit to get into your personal
data over WhatsApp therefore it is
highly recommended that you use this
WhatsApp feature carefully once you
notice that your what messenger has been
hacked go to your WhatsApp web and tap
or click on the log out from all
computers option this will deactivate
all the web extensions of your
account under the unfortunate
circumstances where the account recovery
doesn't seem likely you can always ask
WhatsApp support to delete your account
permanently while well far from the
ideal solution it can act as a failsafe
option if you want to protect your
personal data at any cost possible you
can always open a new account later with
the security issues mitigated it's no
secret that the majority of our internet
usage is at the risk of being hacked be
it via unsafe messaging applications or
misconfigured operating systems to
counteract this void of digital security
penetration testing has become the norm
when it comes to vulnerability
assessment K Linux is an operating
system that has become a well-known
weapon in this fight against hackers a
Linux distribution that is made
specifically for penetration testers K
Linux has layers of features that we
will be covering in today's lesson let's
take a look at the topics to be covered
in this
video we start by learning about Ki
Linux and a basic explanation of its
purpose we take a look at the history of
K Linux from the story of its origin to
its current day
exploits next we learn a few dis
distinct features of Kali that make it
an attractive choice for penetration
testers
worldwide finally we take a look at the
multiple ways we can install K Linux to
start our journey in the world of
penetration testing let's start by
learning about K Linux in
general Kali Linux which is formerly
known as backtrack Linux is an open-
Source Linux distribution aimed at
Advanced penetration testing and
security
auditing it contains several 100 tools
that are targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering color Linux is a multiple
platform solution accessible and freely
available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop while the operating system is
capable of practically modifying every
single part of our installation the
networking components of Kali become
disabled by default this is done to
prevent any external factors from
affecting the installation procedure
which may pose a risk in critical
environments apart from boosting
security it allows a deeper element of
control to the most enthusiastic of
users we did not get K Linux since the
first day how did it come into existence
let's take a look at some of its
history K Linux is based on years of
knowledge and experience in building
penetration testing and operating
systems during all these project
lifelines there have been only a few
different developers as the team has
always been small the first project was
called wopex which stands for white hat
npix as can be inferred from the name it
was based on the npix operating system
as its underl L OS opics had releases
ranging from version 2.0 to
2.7 this made way for the next project
which was known as wax or the long hand
being white hat slacks the name change
was because the base OS was changed from
noix to slacks wax started at version 3
as a nod it carrying on from warix there
was a similar OS being produced at the
same time auditor security collection
often being shorted to just auditor
which was once again using knopic
its efforts were combined with wax to
produce backtrack backtrack was based on
slackware from version one to version
three but switched to Ubuntu later on
with version four to version 5 using the
experience gained from all of this K
Linux came after back truck in 2013 Ki
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when Ki Linux became a
rolling operating
system now that we understand the
history and the purpose of K Linux let
us learn a little more about its
distinct
features the latest version of Khali
comes with more than 600 penetration
tools pre-installed after reviewing
every tool that was included in
backtrack developers have eliminated a
great number of tools that either simply
did not work or which duplicated other
tools that provided the same or similar
functionality the Kali Linux team is
made up of a small group of individual
ual who are the only ones trusted to
commit packages and interact with the
depositories all of which is done using
multiple secure protocols restricting
access of critical code bases to
external asset greatly reduces the risk
of source contamination which can cause
K Linux users worldwide a great deal of
damage as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since Arm based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more and more prevalent and
inexpensive the development team knew
that Khali's armm support would need to
be as robust as they could manage with
fully working in installations K Linux
is available on a wide range of armm
devices and has armm repositories
integrated with the mainline
distributions so the tools for armm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the
distribution all this information is
necessary for users to determine if K
Linux is the correct choice for them if
it is what are the ways that they can go
forward with this installation and start
the penetration testing
Journey the first way to use scal Linux
is by launching the distribution in the
live USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the K Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with a
capacity of at least 8 GB some people
don't need to save their data
permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the cavar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently
some cases allow persistent usage in
live USBS but those require further
configuration than normal
situations but what if the user wants to
store data permanently in the installed
OS the best and the most reliable way to
ensure this is the full-fledged hardk
installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system in installed on the computer be
it windows or any other variant of
Linux the next alternative route for
installing K Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtual box the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and K Linux can
be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window the hardware
requirements will be completely
customizable starting with the allotted
Ram to the virtual hard disk capacity
the usage of both a host and guest
operating system like K Linux allows
users a safe environment to learn while
not putting their systems at risk if you
want to learn more about how one can go
forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where K Linux is being
installed on VMware while running on a
Windows 10 operating system you can find
the link in the description box to get
started with your very own virtual
machine the final way to install Kali
Linux is by using a dual boot system to
put it in simple simple words the K
Linux OS will not be overriding any
pre-installed operating system on a
machine but will be installed alongside
it when a computer boots up the user
will get a choice to boot into either of
these operating systems many people
prefer to keep both the windows and Kali
Linux installed so the distribution of
work and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system
now for the convenience of explanation
we're going to install K Linux today on
a virtual machine software known as
VMware VMware is able to run multiple
operating systems on a single host
machine which in our case is a Windows
system to get started with K Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image
file you go to get Kali and as you can
see the there are multiple platforms on
which this operating system can be
inverted as per our requirement we're
going to go with the virtual machine
section as you can see it is already
recommended by the
developers this is the download button
which will download a 64-bit ISO file we
can download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet after clicking on the
download button the you can see we have
a window archive which will have the ISO
files for now we have downloaded the ISO
file and it is already present with me
so we can start working on the VMware
side of things once the ISO file is
downloaded we open up VMware
Workstation go to file and we create a
new virtual
machine in these two options it is
highly recommended to go with the
typical setup rather than the custom one
the custom is much more advanced and
requires much more information from the
user which is beneficial for developers
and people who are well versed with
virtualization software but for 90% of
the cases typical setup will be
enough here we can select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later in some operating
systems we can use the ISO file here
directly and VMR will install it for us
but right now in the case of K Linux the
third option is always the
safest K Linux is a Linux distribution
so we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here it have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels every distribution has a a
parent distribution for example K Linux
has Debian and there are other
distributions which are based or forked
from some parent distribution kinx is
based of Debian so we can go with the
highest version of Debian which is the
Debian 10. X
64bit go on next we can write any such
name we can write K Linux so that it'll
be easier to recognize the virtual
machine among this list of virtual
machine instances the location can be
any location you decide to put by
default this should be the documents
folder but anywhere you put it will hold
up all the information of the operating
system all the files you download all
the configurations you store everything
will be stored in this particular
location that you
provide when we go next we are asked
about the dis capacity this dis capacity
will be all the storage that will be
provided to your virtual machine of K
Linux think of your Windows device if
you have a 1 TB of hard drive you have
the entirety of the hard disk to store
data on how much data you give here you
can only store up to that amount of data
not to mention some amount of capacity
will be taken up by the operator in
system itself to store its programs and
applications for now we can give around
let's say 15 GB of information or if a
recommended size for Dean is 20 you can
just go ahead at 20 it depends all on
the user case if you're going to use it
extensively you can even go as high as
50 or 60 GB if you have plans to
download many more applications and
perform multiple different tests another
option we get over here is storing
virtual dis as a single file or storing
them into multiple files
as we already know this virtual machine
run entirely on
VMware sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
we're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over
here instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible for all scenarios
except it is much easier if the split
the virtual dis into multiple files now
even if this makes porting virtual
machines easier from either system to
system or software to software let's say
if you want to switch from VMware to
Virtual box or vice versa the
performance takes a small hit it's not
huge but it's recommended to go with
storing the virtual Des as a single file
if you have no purposes of ever moving
the virtual machine even if you do it's
not a complete stop that it cannot be
ported it's just easier when using
multiple files but in order to get the
best performance out of the virtual
machine we can store it as a single file
over
here this is a summary of all the
changes that we made and all the
configurations that have been settled
until now now at this point of time we
have not provided the ISO file yet which
is the installation file for the K Linux
that we downloaded from this
website as of right now we have only
configured the settings of the virtual
machine so we can press on
finish and we have K Linux in the list
now to make the changes further we press
on edit virtual machine
settings the memory is supposed to give
the ram of the virtual machine so
devices with ram of 8 GB or below that
giving high amount of ram will cause
performance issues and the host system
if the memory has some amount of free
storage left let's say on idle storage
my Windows machine takes about 2 GB so I
have 6 GB of memory to provide although
if you provide all of the 6gb it'll be
much more difficult for the host system
to run everything properly so for this
instance we can keep it as 2 GB of
memory for the virtual machine instance
similarly we can use the number of
processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different different course we
can select them as
well hard disk is preset up as the SCSI
hard disk and it does not need to be
changed for the installation of this
operating system at
all CD ID DVD this is where the
installation file comes you can think of
the ISO file that we downloaded as a pen
drive or a USB thumb drive which is
necessary to install an operating system
to provide this you're going to select
use ISO image file you're going to click
on
browse go and go to downloads and select
the IMO file over
here select
open and we can see it is already loaded
up next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use natat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or land segments but those are
not necessary for
installation rest of them are pretty
standard which do not need any extra
configuration and can be left as it
is press okay and now we can power on
this virtual
machine in this screen we can choose how
we want to proceed with the
installation we have a start installer
option over here
so we're going to press enter on
that you're going to wait for the things
to load from the ISO
file um the first step in the
installation is choosing the language of
the operating system for this we can go
with English as
standard this is a location this will be
used for setting up the time and some of
the internal settings will which depend
entirely on the location of the user so
for this we're going to go with
India configuring the keyboard it's
always recommended to go with the
American English first many people make
a mistake of going with the Indian
keyboard if it is possible and it
provides a lot of issues later on so
it's always preferred to go with the
American English and if later we see
some necessity of another keyboard
dialect that is required we can install
it later but for now we should always
stick with American English as a
basic at this point it's going to load
the installation components from the ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect
Hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the ISO file we
want to write a host name for the system
this host name can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a land cable let's say if we
use the name
Kali domain name we can skip it for now
it's not necessary as such for the
installation this is the full name for
the user let's say we can provide the
name as simply learn as a full
name next we're going to set up a
username this username is going to be
necessary to identify the user from its
root accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one to
three now we have to choose a password
for the user now remember since this is
the first user that is being added onto
this newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator we can use whichever
password we like over
here and use the same password below and
press on
continue at this point it's going to
detect on the components on which the
operating system can be
installed like here there are multiple
options like the use entire dis use
entire disc can set up lvm this entire
disc can set up encrypted lvm for
newcomers it is recommended to just use
the first one since lvm encryption is
something that you can learn afterwards
when you're much more Hands-On with the
Linux operating system for now we're
going to use the use entire dis guided
installation and press on
continue when we set up the virtual
machine on VMware we had set up a dis
capacity that we gave up prose 20gb that
is the hard disk which is being
discovered here even though it is a
virtual dis on VMR it acts as a normal
hard disk on which which an operating
system can be installed so we select
this one and press on
continue here there is a multiple
partition system all the operating
systems that are installed have
different components one is used for the
a keeping of the applications one for
the files other for the RAM management
and other things for newcomers it is
always recommended to keep it in one
partition and we're going to select that
and press on
continue
this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of 1 GB used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with Linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine we can press on
finish partitioning and write changes to
disk and
continue it's just a confirmation page
as you can see it's WR that scsi3 is our
virtual hard disk of 20gb dis
capacity write the changes to the disk
we press yes and click on
continue at this point the installation
has started now this installation will
take a while depending on the amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quicker systems this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a
while since this is going to take some
time to install as it is being run on a
virtual machine with only 2GB of RAM
we're going to speed up this part of the
video so we don't have to waste any more
time just watching the progress
bar
now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating systems is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple
devices it's an interface to install
external applications which are not
installed by default let's say for
Google Chrome or any other browser which
can be used to browse the
internet at this point of time is ask us
to select a network mirror we're going
to select as yes and move forward with
this next it's going to ask us for HTTP
proxy which we can leave it as blank and
press it as continue
forward at this point of time it's
looking for updates to the Kali Linux
installation this will fetch the new
builds from the Kali server so the
installation is always updated to the
latest
version now that the package manager is
configured we have the GRUB boot loader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it ask install the GRUB boot
loader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press
continue remember the installation was
conducted on dev
SDA so we're going to select
installation of the gra loader on the
same hard disk that we have
configured we press this one and press
continue so now the graub boot loader is
being installed the graub is highly
essential because it it shows the
motherboard where to start the operating
system from even if the operating system
is installed correctly and all the files
are in correct order the absence of a
boot loader will not be able to launch
the OS
properly as you can see the installation
is finally complete so now we can press
on
continue and it's going to finalize the
changes now you can see K Linux being
booted up straight away it doesn't check
for the ISO file anymore since the
operating system is now installed onto
the virtual hard disk storage that we
had configured
before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up
before and we have the color system
booted
up and this is your homepage we can see
the installed applications over here
which are being used for penetration
testing by multiple security analysts
worldwide all of these come
pre-installed with K Linux and others
can be installed using the AP package
manager that we had
configured you can see a full name over
here and with this our installation of
the K Linux is complete hey everyone
it's no secret that the majority of our
internet usage is at the risk of getting
hacked
be it via unsafe messaging applications
or misconfigured operating systems to
counteract this void of digital security
penetration testing has become the norm
when it comes to vulnerability
assessment par security OS is an
operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a Linux distribution more cater
towards penetration testers specifically
parent security has layers of features
that we will be covering in today's
lesson let's take a look at the topics
for this
video we start by learning about what
par security is and why it should be
considered as a viable alternative next
to K Linux for penetration
testers next we take a look at the
minimum system requirements necessary to
obtain Optimum performance from an
installation of parot security moving on
we learn about some unique features that
make parot Stand Out Among the multiple
ethical hacking operating systems
available on the market and finally we
look at at the multiple ways that parot
security OS can be installed be it on a
single system or for portable
media so let's start out by learning
what parot security
is paratos is a Debian based Linux
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on debian's testing branch and
uses a custom Harden Linux kernel while
being founded in
2013 parro security contains several 100
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering it has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbies it features a distinct forens
six mode that does not Mount any of the
system hard diss or partitions and has
no influence on the host system making
it more stealthy than regular mode this
mode is used on the host system when
there is a need for executing forensic
procedures in software development a
rolling release is a paradigm in which
software upgrades are rolled out
constantly rather than in batches of
versions this ensures that the software
is constantly up to date rolling release
distribution such as parro security OS
follows the same concept providing the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as they become available on the
market the basic introduction to the
oper operating system out of the way let
us have a look at the bare minimum
system requirements necessary to be able
to run this operating
system first up we got a CPU requirement
which states that a 1 GHz dual core CPU
is the absolute minimum in order to use
baratos while multiple core systems will
provide more Optimum performance a small
beginner has been
included a very distinct thing to be
noted is that the operating system can
be installed on all variance of chipsets
be 32-bit 64-bit and the newly popular
armm portfolio of
devices unlike K Linux which requires
some amount of graphical acceleration
needed to display the operating system
correctly paratos has no such
requirements and can be used with the
leanest of
machines taking into account the ram
issue a minimum of 256 MB to 512 MB free
Ram provides the optimum usage
scenarios even when the OS is installed
on a hard drive storage media it should
theoretically occup by around 8 GB of
information which may extend up to 16 GB
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box when it comes to booting
options we have the option of going with
the Legacy BIOS settings or with the
more modern ufi settings these are just
some of the requirements for the
installation of parot security OS to
understand this process more vividly and
to learn how visualization can help
install an OS in our existing computer
please follow the link to a parate
security installation video linked right
above let's understand what some of the
things that make parro security unique
among all the other penetration testing
operating
systems along with all the giant catalog
of scripts par security has its own
custom hardened Linux kernel which has
been modified explicitly to provide as
much security and resistance to hackers
as possible as a first line of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as a second Gateway taking
care of malicious requests and dropping
them off this is particularly beneficial
since should there be a scenario where
the latest Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the parat development
team will most likely add in it out
first before passing it on as an
update if the custom hardened kernel
wasn't reasoning enough parid security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Gali Linux
users all the tools you found in Gali
are present in parat to us and then a
few extra ones for good measure this has
been achieved while keeping roughly the
same size of the installation file
between both operating
systems however it's not all
productivity points for parro OS they
provide a choice between two different
desktop environments the M desktop which
comes pre-installed by default and KDE
for those unfamiliar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a Linux
system being highly modular in nature
one can use Ki Linux or paratos while
adding another DT of environment which
they find appealing while kalii has only
a single option paratto has managed to
provide two optimized Wills with made
desktop and KD desktop ready made on the
website one of the primary advantages of
parat os over Kali is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it tently less dis space and computing
power to function properly with as
little as 320 MB of ram required
in reality parat OS is also designed to
operate successfully of a USB stick but
Kali leux does not work well from a USB
stick and is generally installed in a
virtual machine parat o can be seen as
more of a niche distribution if you're
searching for something lighter than K
Linux there are multiple ways to go
about with this
installation many people prefer to
install it directly onto a hard disk
where the parent security OS will
override whichever data the hard disk
already has now this is beneficial if
you want to preserve your data for the
long term but this might pose some
trouble to people who do not have a
spare hard disk or do not want to lose
their current installation of Windows
operating system another way to use par
security is by using the live boot but
whatever changes we make to the live
boot operating system those changes are
removed the moment we restart or shut
down the
system a very good Common Ground between
both these installations is
virtualization using virtualization
software like VMware or virtual box we
can install parad security on our
systems while simultaneously saving our
data and having the convenience of a
host machine such as a Windows operating
system in case things go
wrong to start the installation we first
need to get a ISO file for the par
security operating system this can be
found on the current
website pac.org
once we enter the website move into the
download
section
and select the get security Edition over
here par security OS has multiple
desktop environments to you to choose
from these desktop environments serves
as a different user interface for the
user for example right now we have the M
desktop and the KDE desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to
them for our example let's go with a M
desktop
we have two options either we can go
with the direct download or we can get
the torrent file for this example if you
press on the download
button and our download will start I
have already downloaded this file but
the ISO file provided over here will
serve as an installation it will have
around 4 and2 GB of space it will be
used to install this operating system in
VMware once the file is downloaded we
can close this and open VMware
Workstation
VMware can also be used as a player
version or the Workstation version if
you have much more familiarity with
using virtual box of virtualization
application we can use that as
well once the VMware is open we click on
file and select a new virtual
machine for the first time installation
we're going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one if you have
already installed multiple virtual
machine osses going with the advanced
option will give you much more control
over the hardware customization but for
now we're going to stick with the
typical
option moving on it'll ask us for a
source to where to install the operating
system from since we're going to use a
live ISO first we're going to select the
third option which will be I will
install the operating system later and
press
next as we already know parent security
is a debent derivative so When selecting
in the guest operating system type we're
going to go with Linux and the selection
we're going to choose whichever the
highest version of Debian is along with
a 64bit
OS we're going to click on next we're
going to name our virtual machine let's
say parent security
OS we're going to select the location
where we want to save the virtual
machine this will have all the hard disk
of the operating system installation
we're going to click on next for the dis
size we're going to specify how much of
the current memory are we going to
allocate this is the hard disk memory of
the operating system installation
whatever changes you make in the
operating system whatever applications
we install on the virtual instance will
all be stored in this amount of memory
while it is recommended to go with at
least 15 GB of storage we can go as high
as possible and we're going to select
the recommended 20gb as
written when given the choice of storing
the virtual disc as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that it
helps them stay portable people change
systems and sometimes they want to swap
their instances between the work and
their personal computer if there is no
portability in mind storing the virtual
dis as a single file gives the best
performance and should be the
recommended goto when installing for the
first time we click on next here and
it's going to give us a summary of the
settings we have already settled till
now we're going to press on
finish and there we go we have our
installation First Step
completed here on out we're going to
click on edit virtual machine
settings here we're going to have a look
at some of the requirements that the
parro security OS will need it is known
to be a memory lightweight operating
system but just to have the most Optimum
performance we're going to provide
around 2 GB of RAM from our host system
which is a Windows 10 machine when it
comes to the processors I'm going to
increase it to two and the number of CES
to two as well so giving out a total
four processor CES to the operating
system now this depends on what are your
computer rig and how much resources you
can justify so these need to be
customized according to the system at
hand hardest size has already been set
at 20gb and the rest of them are pretty
standard and we can go on one thing that
we need to make sure is selecting the CD
DVD IDE here we have to use a ISO image
file over here previously it should be
used physical drive and at Auto detect
we're going to use a use ISO image file
over here we're going to click on
browse we're going to go to where we
have downloaded the ISO file which is
over here and select
it press okay
here and we can now power on this
virtual machine
at this point of time there are two
options we can go with the try install
option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode to get a better user
experience we're going to go with the
try install mode specifically PR enter
and it's going to start the live boot
ISO meanwhile VMR has an
prompt over here where it will try to
install some VMware tools on it while
this is not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools so
that you can get some additional
features like drag and drop with the
host system and many more things for now
we're going to close this
prompt
as you can see this is the live boot ISO
of the Barett security operating
system currently it's running the M
desktop as we have downloaded in the
website the live boot ISO is necessary
to get a good feel of the operating
system there are many good Linux dros
that have this live boot option so that
you can give a try of the operating
system before installing permit
ently once you into the live board we
can start up with the installation using
the shortcut as you can see install
paret going to double click
it and this is a calaris installer
choose your language as American
English and press
next you can select your time zone
according to your
location
C and we can go
next at this point of time you have to
choose the correct keyboard now what
many people go get confused is choosing
their own language keyboard but people
must keep in mind is what keyboard the
laptop
provides most of the systems that come
pre-build provide the English US
keyboard so whatever keyboard you choose
make sure to type here and test that all
the buttons including the superscript
and the subscript buttons are working
correctly before moving forward with
this
step once you settled on the keyboard
that you need to install can go
ahead here it will ask you to select
storage device and the only option
you're are going to get is the amount of
hard disk storage you have given in the
virtual machine settings we have already
provided 20gb of storage we're going to
choose that and we're going to erase
this disk
manual partitioning can be useful when
you're going to install par Security on
an operating system or on a hard disk
where it is already including a Windows
OS for now we're going to select erase
disk and press next we're going to give
our full name Let It Be simply
learn you can give the name of the
computer and this is the username which
we will use to
login this is your root password that we
going to give over here the root
password of this Khali Linux will act as
the administrative access and it will be
necessary for making changes to the
system or installing an updating
software enter the password and repeat
it over
here you have the option to login
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this
disabled click on next this this is
another summary of the installation that
we going to move forward with have a
look that whatever changes we have made
is according to your requirements and
once everything is checked we can press
on
install click on install
now and we're going to let it complete
the
work as you can see the installation of
parent security is now completed we're
going to make sure that we have the
restart Now button over here disabled
I'm going to click on
done we're going to shut down this live
boot
ISO going to click on
menu turn off the
device and shut
down we're not restarting straight away
because if you remember correctly in the
virtual machine instance settings we had
given it an ISO
file please remove the live medium and
press enter to continue we can just
press enter to
continue and it's going to shut down now
to move on we're going to click on edit
virtual machine
settings going to CD DVD and we're going
to use physical drive now we're going to
remove it from the iso image file
because the installation has already
been completed and we don't want to use
the same ISO file again and again by
using physical drive over here it's
going to detect the 20 GB hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it going to
press
okay and we're going to power on this
virtual machine for
testing make sure this you click s over
here
this is the grub menu at this we get
different choices for example which
NVIDIA drivers off or with some other
Advanced options more often than not
we're going to choose the first option
and press
enter if you remember clearly we did not
get the option of try install or a
terminal run just like we did in the
live boot ISO since this is running
straight from the 20gb hard drive
storage it's going to start the OS
directly
now with the login screen you can see a
username over here as we provided in the
installation we're going to enter our
root
password and press
enter and this is a currently working
desktop of the par security operating
system we can open the terminal over
here
and we're going to try a root password
and
installation to install any software
we're going to use the keyword Pudo
AP install and Neo
fetch we're going to use the root
password that we used to log
in going to press y for
yes this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of Hardware requirements
that we had
provided now that we have installed NE
fetch we can write the command new
Fetch and this is going to give us some
information about our
installation you can see the OS name as
parro OS 4.11 is running on a VMware
host it's the kernel versions and some
of the other information like the number
of packages installed the current shell
version resolution of the VMware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once and some other things
you can see the memory is supposed to be
1951 mbes which is supposed to equal
around 2 GB of RAM usage that we had
provided K Linux and parro Os are two
popular penetration testing
distributions while these operating
systems each have unique offerings the
overall Choice can differ between
Personnel thanks to the various tools
and Hardware specifications today we
will look at both these distributions
and settle on the perfect choice for
each type of user let's go through the
agenda for this
video we will learn about K Linux and
pirot security Os from scratch while
understanding their primary selling
points as a Linux distribution catered
towards penetration testers
next we know about some features of
these operating systems that stand out
of their
package finally we directly compare K
Linux and Par security OS thereby making
a clear-cut conclusion on which OS is
perfect on a per requirement
basis so let's start by learning about K
Linux from a ground
level K Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open-source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering K Linux is a multiplatform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and
hobbies among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian Opera system Dean has
been a highly dependable and a stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the K
Linux
desktop while the operating system can
practically modify every single part of
our installation the networking
components of K Linux come disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a more
profound element of security control to
the most enthusiastic of
users now let's take a look at parad
security operating
system parad security OS is a Debian
based Linux distribution with an
emphasis on security privacy and
development it is built on the demian's
testing branch and uses a custom Harden
Linux
kernel par security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards tasks
such as penetration testing computer
forensics reverse engineering and
security research it is seen as a
generally lightweight distribution that
can work under rigorous hardware and
software
specifications it features a distinct
forensics mode that does not Mount any
of the systems hard diss or partitions
and has no influence on the host system
making it much more stealy than its
regular occurrence this mode is used on
the host system to execute forensic
procedures
a rolling release is a paradigm in which
software upgrades are rolled out
constantly rather than in batches of
versions and software development this
ensures that the software is constantly
up to date a rolling release
distribution such as Pate security OS
follows the same concept it provides the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as soon as they become
available with a basic introduction to
the operating systems out of the way let
us take a look at the unique features of
both K Linux and parro security
OS the latest version of Ki Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a significant number of tools
that either simply did not work or
duplicated other tools that provided the
same and similar
functionality the K Linux team comprises
a small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code bases to external assets
dramatically reduces the risk of source
contamination which can cause scal Linux
users worldwide a great deal of damage
as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Al includes proper
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for their job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since arm-based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more prevalent and inexpensive
the development team knew that Khali's
armm support would need to be as robust
as could manage with fully working
installations Kali Linux is available on
a wide range of armm devices and has
armm repositories integrated with the
mainline distribution so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution let's take a look at some
of the features of parat security
operating system
now along with the giant catalog of
scripts parad security OS has its own
Harden Linux kernel modified explicitly
to provide as much security and
resistance to hackers as possible in the
first line of
defense the configurations in the
operating system Act is the second
Gateway taking care of malicious
requests and dropping them off this is
particularly beneficial since should
there be a scenario where the latex
Linux kernel is causing some particular
issue the paratos development team will
most likely iron it out first before
passing it on as an
update
if the custom hardal kernel wasn't reent
enough paret security developers managed
to install more hacking tools and
scripts to ensure a smooth transition
for the Kali Linux users all the tools
you find in Kali are present in parent
TOs and a few extra ones for good
measure and this has been achieved while
keeping roughly the same operating
system size between both of
them however it's not all productivity
points for pirate OS they provide a
choice between two different desktop
environments mate which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE for
those unfamiliar with Linux terminology
you can think of desktop environments as
a main UI for a distribution being
highly modular in nature one can use
parro security OS while adding another
desktop environment that they find
appealing while K Linux has only a
single option par security has provided
two optimized bills with made desktop
and KD desk
stop one of the primary advantages of
parro os over Kali Linux is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes significantly less dis space
and computing power to function
correctly with as little as 320 MB of
ram required in reality paratto is
designed to operate successfully off a
USB stick but K Linux does not work well
from a USB Thrive and is generally
installed in a virtual machine paratos
is more of a niche distribution if
you're searching for something lighter
than
kalux features are great but what about
Performance Real World metrics let us
compare both these operating systems
directly with respect to their Hardware
specifications and usability in the end
we can decide on what distribution is
fit for each type of
user for a first point of comp
comparison let's take a look at the ram
required for Optimum performance of the
operating system which is highly
essential when trying to crack hashes or
something of similar nature ramme usage
is a very important facet while khux
demands at least 1 GB of RAM par
security can operate optimally with a
minimum of 320 MB of
RAM for correctly displaying graphical
elements Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parro security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user
side once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using the live boot
isos they take up a minimum amount of
hard dis storage both of these operating
systems have a recommended dis storage
of minimum of 20 GB in K Linux and a
minimum of 15 GB in parro security so
they can install all the tools necessary
in the ISO
file when it comes to the category and
the selection of tools K Linux has
always been the first in securing every
single tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry par
Security on the other hand has managed
to take it up a
notch while specializing in Wireless pen
testing par security makes it a point
that all the tools that K Linux provides
has been included in the iso while
simultaneous ly adding some extra tools
that many users will have to install
from third party sources in K
Linux being a decade old penetration
testing distribution K Linux has formed
up a very big Community with strong
support signature par Security on the
other hand is still growing and it is
garnering much more interest among
veteran penetration testers and ethical
hackers a primary drawback of K Linux is
the extensive Hardware requirement to
perform optimally it requires higher
memory than par security it also needs
graphical acceleration while demanding
more virtual hard disk Storage parro
security on the other hand was initially
designed to run off a USB drive directly
thereby requiring very minimal
requirements from a hardware perspective
like just 320 MB of RAM and no graphical
acceleration needed this means parro
security is much more feasible for
people who are not able to devote
massive resources to either their
virtual machine or on their laptop hard
disk
directly with the comparison done
between both of these operating systems
let's take a look at the type of users
both of these are cater
to one can go with K Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years if they have a powerful system
which can run K Linux optimally without
having to bottleneck performance and if
they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners one can decide to go with
parro security if they want to go with a
very lightweight and lean distribution
that can run pretty much on all
systems it also has a lot of tools
pre-installed and some of them are not
even present on G
Linux it is much more suitable for
underpowered DS where users do not have
a lot of Hardware resources to provide
to the operating system and thereby it
is much more feasible for people with
underpowered laptops or no graphical
acceleration compared to K Linux par
secuity desktop environment is also
relatively easier to use for new
beginners for people who are just
getting into ethical hacking par
security does a relatively better job of
introducing them to the operating system
and to the various toools without having
to dump them into the entire intricacies
simply learn offers postgraduate program
in cyber security find the complete
course details from the link in the
description box with the world moving
towards the next generation of computer
hardware the software side of things
still has a lot left to be discovered
with the majority of laptops coming with
Windows PR installed many users are
devoid of the Linux operating system
experience which is more resource
friendly than than the mainstream
operating systems it can be attributed
to the difficulty people used to face
when installing a new operating system
like Linux in the old days however a lot
of these issues are fixed nowadays
thanks to the big names like Debian and
Ubuntu who have been instrumental in
making Linux based operating systems as
userfriendly as possible but which one
of them is better for you let's take a
look at the topics to be covered today
as we answer this question for
you we start by learning about the
operating systems from a Layman's
perspective and uncovering the basic
offerings of both
entities next we cover the unique
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
how they stack up against each other and
other industry
counterparts moving on we take a look at
some pointers before installing each of
these operating systems and the
respective download
links finally We compare the contrasting
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
infer the kind of users each OS caters
to
so let's start by learning about ubu and
Debian in
general ubu is an open- Source free
Linux distribution it is an operating
system for cloud computing in accordance
with support with open stack Ubunto is
developed by the canonical community and
it is freely available also canola
limited is responsible for the funding
of Ubuntu basically Ubuntu is released
every 6 months
free support is available for 9 months
after every release and long-term
support which are the LTS is released
every 2 years the first release of
Ubuntu was in October
2004 you must have heard about Ubuntu no
matter what it is the most popular Linux
distribution overall not just limited to
servers but also the most popular choice
for Linux desktops it's easy to use
offers a good experience and comes
pre-installed with essential tools to
get a head start of course Ubunto
managed to simplify the Linux experience
years back and that is the reason why it
is still so popular even with several
impressive Linux distributions available
right now every new release is more
polished and comes loaded with new
features and
improvements thanks to its huge user
base a number of software vendors have
made the applications compatible with
one2 while the catalog may not be as
extensive as Windows the options are
still well curated more importantly the
advantage of Linux based operating
systems is the ability to use free and
open- Source alternatives to Major
proprietary software by lacking some
Polish and overall featur set most
alternatives are enough to get the job
done for majority of the users the
never-ending Community Support also
helps in troubleshooting should things
go wrong at any point in
time the default desktop environment in
ubu is gome or a Unity the unity is a
modern desktop environment with a
powerful Search tool for finding all
your applications and documents with its
base setup as no it integrates well with
common applications such as audio
players video players and social media
there are a few other desktop
environments for open to as well with
unity as its Flagship
environment Dean on the other hand is a
free operating system for your computer
which started in 1996 and is maintained
by global
contributors if the operating system a
set of basic programs and utilities that
make you computer run its core is the
kernel the kernel is the most
fundamental program on the computer
Debian uses the Linux kernel a
completely free piece of software which
is started by Linus trowal and supported
by thousands of programmers worldwide a
large part of the basic tools that fill
out the operating system come from the
gnu project and those tools are free as
well Debian is the mother of Linux
distributions beginners always wonder
why this not so good-looking Dro is so
popular inside the Linux developers
Community especially when there are a
lot of modern distributions that are
easy to use and have beautiful UI later
on they found out the power of Debian
after using a bunch of distributions
from other developers you'll be
surprised to know that almost all other
popular consumer level dros are based on
Debian even ubu it is so stable and
featur Rich that the developers find it
easy to build their dros based on Debian
rather than building it from
scratch Debian is run and maintained on
its GitHub repository thanks to
contributions from developers worldwide
the major decisions are taken up on the
repository issues tab leading to
CommunityWide feedback and a holistic
approach to open source development of
the Debian operating system thanks to
this variety of personnel the source
code of Debian comprises around 70
different programming and scripting
languages Debian supports all kinds of
graphical environments ranging from full
feature desktop environments to lighter
Alternatives and EMA minimalist Window
Man managers Ubunto ships with unity
desktop by default where the package
manager can install the gome environment
if needed while also including cinnamon
lxd xfc KDE and mate on the other hand
Dean gives you the choice of choosing
which desktop environment you want from
the get go by providing ISO files for
each desktop environment
individually now that we understand
where both these operating systems stand
let us take a look at some of the best
features offered by each of these
distributions ubu is the closest thing
to a household name among desktop Linux
distributions it is a great distribution
to start with and it's even a great
distribution to keep using after you're
more experienced if you're happy with it
it is user friendly in a lot of ways it
provides a simple desktop has an easy
installer and provides a checkbox during
the installation process that will
automatically install Flash plugins and
various codes that you will need for
multimedia support there's an additional
drivers tool that will detect closed
Source or propriety drivers that might
be necessary to get all your Hardware
working and easily install them for
you one2 is produced by canonical and
their friends it is run as an open
project to enable others with diverse
ideas to benefit from all the work the
developers do to deliver the world's
best open platform still canonical is
responsible for delivering six monthly
Milestone releases
and regular LTS releases from Enterprise
production news Enterprises can count on
canonical to support secure and manage
Ubunto infrastructure and devices with
more than 500 employees in over 39
countries the company underpins the
critical infrastructure for thousands of
businesses and millions of obuntu users
around the
world Unity desktop was originally
developed by canonical and introduced
earlier for Netbook computers with
Ubuntu 10.10 then it went on to be the
default desktop environment for uban 2
eventually it has been dropped by
canonical and replaced by gome however
it has made a comeback after uban to
18.04 while being completely stable the
HUD and Global menu hold up just fine
with major applications such as lib
office Thunderbird and other web
browsers that means that the unity
desktop works as it is supposed to while
making you more productive while some
desktop environments have a steep
learning curve Unity is very intuitive
for new users in spite of deviating from
the traditional start menu format that
the windows users are generally
accustomed
to the calamaras installer is a
framework by design it is very
customizable in order to satisfy a wide
variety of needs and use cases calamaras
aims to be easy usable beautiful
pragmatic and more important
distribution agnostic calamaras includes
an advanced partitioning feature as well
which supports for both manual and
automated partitioning operations it is
the first installer with an automated
replace partition option which makes it
easy to reuse a partition over and over
for distribution
testing coming to Debian it is a
community distribution through and
through it's governed by a board of
elected developers it has its own
internal structure and laws and just
about everyone working on it is a
volunteer making it completely Community
Driven it is maintained and developed by
programmers and developers all around
the world this form of development
ensures continuity if one of the
developers decides to stop working on
the project another developer might come
in and take place and keep the project
going on it is completely free of
centralized control and this is also one
of the reasons for an undecided stable
release cycle Debian Sid is the
permanently unstable development version
of Debian it is where the latest
versions of programs are being
considered for inclusion in the deban
release cycle are uploaded and and test
it because it has no official install
media and the few net boot images that
are built often don't work even people
who are willing to risk using a
development version may have trouble
installing it however it Still Remains
the best place to test new features that
have not yet made their way onto the
stable
Branch Debian has only free and open-
Source software in its repositories this
is mostly ample for users except for
users who use Hardware that only has
proprietary drivers these repositories
work well in most cas es it is possible
to add other rep as well that have pro
priy software if that is the
requirement Debian Standard Version is
very stable as software and libraries in
it go through rigorous testing the
stability makes Debian a perfect server
OS and it's also the same reason why
average user shy away from using Debian
as their primary OS on
desktop this is also one of the reasons
why many developers use Dean as a base
for their derivative one of which is
also
Ubuntu now that we are aware of each
distribution's unique features let's
take a look at how we can go ahead and
install these operating systems and
where we can get the downloadable
images when it comes to ubu ubu has
dropped the support for 32-bit systems
currently it supports only 64bit devices
and armm devices installation is easy
with the calamaras framework coming into
ISO pred default and the latest ISO can
be downloaded from the link being shown
on the screen right now in the case of
dbn the support for multiple range of
devices is still present that can also
include 32bit systems and other smaller
devices which are not
modern even though it does not use the
calaris installer even downloading the
ISO file can be a bit hectic for newer
users considering this is a distribution
aimed at developers and intermediate
users finding the right link can be
difficult because of which we have
mentioned the link on the screen below
where you can get the latest ISO
depending on which desktop environment
you choose to go
with with the installation out of the
way let's take a direct comparison of
the features between both ubu and
Debian Debian is a Community Driven open
source Linux distribution and is
primarily aimed to be robust capable and
most importantly free
on the other hand ubu is also and free
and open source like Debian but it's
backed up and developed by a canonical
which is a corporate
company Debian and uban 2 are both
fundamentally fast regarding performance
as Debian comes bare minimum and is not
bundled or prepacked with additional
software and features it makes it super
fast and lightweight at least when
compared with UB 2
directly both Ubuntu and Debian use the
same AP software packaging management
system but provide a different software
repository Debian is more like promoting
freedom of choosing free software thus
it does not include any proprietary
software by default you can always
install the paid versions but you have
to enable it manually ubun to focuses on
usability including all the software
including free paid open source closed
Source Etc Ubunto also introduced a
universal package management system
called Snap it will be used across dros
and thus prevent more drro based
software fragmentations
as the dean distri does not contain any
proprietary blobs there might be some
problems with drivers and firmware that
means Debian lacks some of the essential
proprietary firmware by default but the
users can enable the repository and
install it manually like other page
software on the other hand UB 2 does not
care how much whether it's paid free
open source or clone source so it
includes as many drivers and firmware as
possible UB to also lets you install and
configure the necessary dri and firmware
automatically during installation or
afterward if you are a gamer then you
will probably be concerned with the
latest software drivers and Hardware
support while Debian can potentially
provide that it is likely that you might
end up breaking your installation as
mentioned before ubun to supports
certain proprietary packages as well
which often consist of graphic drivers
which are essential to gaming Debian
focuses on the open-source aspect of the
software hence it can be a well-known
fact that with Gamers Ubuntu and some
other distributions like popos have been
working much better regarding both
software and Hardware
support regarding the audience they
cater to both Ubuntu and Dean have their
pros and cons Ubuntu is a very good
distribution for amateur users with
little to know experience and if they
want to have the latest versions of
packages and applications at all times
on their
systems it is also for users who do not
want a lot of customizability in spite
of unity being very customiz a desktop
environment it is also perfect for users
with newer Hardware since it comes
updated with all the latest graphical
devices and their respective
drivers Debian on the other hand is
cater towards a little bit of
experienced users who can fix some minor
bugs on their own or with minimal
Community Support it also is for users
who want to support an open source
approach rather than an operating system
which is devoid of any contribution from
other end and is primarily backed by a
corporation it also doesn't favor gaming
since it does not guarantee
compatibility with all the newest
graphic cards or even Wi-Fi cards in
some
cases however due to the low memory
overhead Dean is very useful for people
who are looking to run home servers or
even corporate environments where
running servers on Debian will provide
much more use data protection is of
Paramount importance in today's world
the vast amount of data flow between
corporations and consumer needs to be
secured considering that they're
entrusted with a lot of belief a company
can spend millions of dollars on the
most secure servers but it takes a
single hacker to ruin all the Goodwill
between the organizations to prevent
these malicious attacks many automated
security systems have been developed but
none of them have been as used as IDs
platforms which are also known as
intrusion detection systems welcome to
this introductory lesson on intrusion
detection systems so let's go through
the topics that we are going to cover
today we start the basic definition of
ideas from a Layman's
perspective moving on we cover the
multiple types of intruders that seek to
access confidential information without
any
authorization next we cover the basic
ways to detect intrusion signatures from
the perspective of a network
administrator we then take a look at the
different types of ideas systems that
can be used in corporate environments
today a small explanation of the two
types of protection is Then followed by
an introduction to some of the most
well-known ideas tools on the market
so let's get started with what is an
IDs an intrusion detection system is an
app or device that monitors inbound and
outward Network traffic continuously
analyzing for activity changes and
patterns and alerts an administrator
when it detects unusual behavior an
administrator then reviews alarms and
take action to remove the threat for
example an IDs might inspect the data
carried by Network traffic to see if it
contains node malware or other malicious
content if it detects this type of
threat it sends an alert to your
security team so they can investigate
and remediate it once your team receives
the alert they must act quickly to
prevent an attack from taking over the
system to ensure that the IDS doesn't
slow down Network performance the
solutions often use a switched Port
analyzer or a text access port to
analyze a copy of the inline data
traffic so that they do not meddle with
the actual traffic
however they do not block threat once
they enter the network as intrusion
prevention systems do regardless of
whether you set up a physical device or
an IDs program the system can recognize
attack patterns with network packets
monitor user Behavior identify abnormal
network activity or ensure user and
system activity do not go against
security
policies the main goal of an ideas is to
detect the anomalies before the hackers
complete the objective once the system
detects a threat the IT team is informed
and the information is passed on given
the requirement for understanding
context an Enterprise has to be ready to
make any ideas fit its own unique needs
expert advised what this means is that
an IDs cannot be a one- siiz fits all
configuration to operate accurately and
effectively and this requires a Savvy
ideas analyst to tailor the ideas for
the interest and needs of a given site
and knowledgeable train system analyst
are SC the trick with ideas is that you
have to know what the attack is to be
able to identify it the IDS has always
had the patient zero problem you have to
have found someone who got sick and died
before you can identify it it can
usually go for two types of protection
active protection and passive in a
passive system the idas detects a
potential security breach logs the
information and signals an alert in a
reactive system or an active system the
ideas responds to the suspicious
activity by logging off a user or by
reprogramming the firewall to block
Network traffic from the suspected
malicious
source so now that we understand what an
ideas is let us go through the different
types of intruders IDs platforms must be
aware of to understand the type of
intruders let us go through a scenario
we have the servers which are protected
by the ideas Platforms in place so let's
say a hacker tries to breach the system
from outside the organization this can
be done using multiple attacks like dos
attacks injection attacks Etc the
category of individuals that are not
authorized to use a system but still
exploit users privacy and confidential
information using different techniques
are known as
masqueraders a masquerader is an
intruder that is an outsider who does
not have direct access to the system and
aims to attack unethically by stealing
data or
information however there is another
Intruder who is theoretically harder to
detect and approv than a masquer these
are the people within the organization
who want to weak the security defenses
be it for corporate Espionage or to Aid
other
masqueraders the category of individuals
that are authorized to use a system but
misuse the granted access and privilege
these are individuals that take undue
advantage of the permissions and give
access to them and this category of
intruders are known as misasa misers are
people that are insiders and have direct
access to the system which they aim to
attack unethically by stealing data or
information let us now go through some
of the ways the IDE platforms can detect
intrusion before it is too late
intrusion detection systems primarily
use two key methods one is signature
based intrusion and the anomaly based
intrusion signature based intrusion
detection is designed to detect possible
threats by comparing the given Network
traffic and log data to existing attack
patterns these patterns are called
sequences and could include bite
sequence which is also known as
malicious instruction sequences
signature based detection enable you to
accurately detect and identify possible
loan attacks anomal based intrusion
detection is the opposite it's designed
to pinpoint unknown attacks such as new
malware and adapt to them on the Fly
using machine learning machine learning
techniques enable an intrusion detection
system to create baselines of
trustworthy activity which is known as a
trust model then compare new behaviors
to verify trust models false alarms can
occur when using an anomaly based ideas
since previously unknown yet legitimate
Network traffic could be falsely
identified as malicious activity now if
you combine both of those you have the
hybrid intrusion detection they use
signature based and anomaly based
intrusion detection to increase the
scope of your ideas this enables you to
identify as many threats as possible a
comprehensive intrusion detection system
can understand the evasion technique
cyber criminals use to trick and ideas
to thinking there isn't an attack taking
place these techniques could include
fragmentation low bandwidth attack
patent change evasion and many
more we can now take a look at the type
of protection offered by IDs
platforms there are a couple of phase
that can be set up so let's go through
each
method the first is a network-based idas
the sensors are deployed at strategic
points within the network such as within
the DMZ or at the Network's parameter
the sensor can monitor individual
packets of inbound and outbound traffic
to and from all devices on the network
it analyzes them for malicious activity
and depending on the network
architecture and amount of traffic
involved multiple instances of network
based ideas may be necessary the second
category is host based intrusion
detection systems or
HIDs an agent runs on all servers
endpoints and devices in the network
that have access to both the internet
and the internal Network intrusions
identified by analyzing operating
specific activities like the
modification of the file system registry
or Access Control lists and by
monitoring system application logs as
well they augment network based idea
systems by detecting animalus traffic
which originate within the organization
or from the host that is being monitored
for example a host infected with malware
that is attempting to spreaded to other
internal host is an issue that a network
based ideas could potentially fail to
detect the third variant is a cloud
based intrusion detection
system because of the internet facing
nature of the cloud on premises ID
Solutions are not necessarily optimized
for
monitoring for example network based
sensors need to be deployed within the
cloud at an environments Network
perimeter and yet a cloud service
provider may or may not have a way to
facilitate this cloud-based servers use
purpose-built cloud sensors that use
cloud service provider application
programming interface or cloud service
provider apis to get as much visibility
as possible into your Cloud
environment now that we understand the
different types of ideas deployment
tactics let us go through some tools
that excel in this field offering
top-of-the-line implementations in a
corporate and consumer
environment the first tool being covered
is the solar wind security event
manager the solar wind security event
manager is designed to integrate
real-time log data from across your
infrastructure enabling it to act both
as a network based idea system and a
host based idea system the solution can
let you discover all kinds of malicious
attacks and help you protect your
network from harm it is also designed to
enact both signature based and anamal
based intrusion detection by comparing
sequences of network traffic against a
set of customizable
rules next we have the macafe life safe
Mac life saafe is an intrusion detection
system designed to bring a real-time
threat awareness to your physical and
virtual networks it uses signature based
intrusion prevention and anomaly based
intrusion detection along with emultion
techniques to spot and and identify
malicious activity maafe is also built
to correlate threat activity with
application usage which can further
prevent network issues stemming from
cyber
attacks next we have bluma bluma is a
security information and event
management platform built to enact
threat detection and responses across
your cloud and on premises environments
it is designed to continuously monitor
your it infrastructure for suspicious
activity and misconfigurations both of
which could result in data leaks and
compliance breaches it enables you to
respond to an attack in progress and
stop malicious actors in their tracks
monitoring usage of corporate data and
access to privilege information had been
a daunting task before the Advent of I
am encompassing numerous apis single
signon Frameworks and data handling
policies IM IM has established itself as
a key component of every it department
but how does it enforce these rules and
who are the key benefactors of these
policies what about the advantages of
these Frameworks and the workflow of
these systems we are here today to
answer these questions let's take a look
at some of the topics to be covered
today we start by learning about IM am
that is identity and access management
from a surface level so as to put a
clear idea of what it is next we cover
the general workflow and process of how
IM am Works moving on we cover some of
the tools that find the place an AM
framework and are crucial
components finally we go through some of
the advantages of the IM learning what
makes them a lucrative deal for
organizations so let's get started by
learning about IM am from a surface
level
perspective identity and access
management or IM am is a set of
processes policies and tools for
defining and managing the roles and
access privileges of individual Network
entities to a variety of cloud and on
premise applications the users can
include customers Partners employees
devices like computers smartphones
routers Etc the core objective of IM
systems is one digital identity per
individual or item once the digital
identity has been established it must be
maintained modified and monitored
throughout each users or devices access
life cycle access and user are two vital
IM Concepts access offers to the actions
permitted to be done by a user like view
cre create or change a file users could
be employees Partners suppliers
contractors or even customers
furthermore employees can be further
segmented based on their roles IM
systems are designed to perform three
key tasks identify authenticate and
authorize meaning that only the right
person should have access to computers
Hardware software apps any it resources
etc for the entry of new users or the
changing of the roles of existing users
the list of access privileges must be up
to date all the time IM functions
usually fall under it departments or
section that handle cyber security and
data
management now that we understand the
importance of I am in today's cyber
security sphere let us understand the
process of this framework we have
multiple components that Aid this
process let's start by going through
each of them
individually principle is an entity that
can perform actions on an awsc Source or
any Cloud management system
a user a role or an application can be a
principal it's always the principal who
raises a concern to access or modify
data on servers serving as the first
point of contact in the IM am
workflow authentication is the process
of confirming the identity of the
principal trying to access the product
the principal must provide s credentials
or required keys for authentication this
step can be further enhanced by multiple
authentication factors and Googs among
other things
once the identity is confirmed the
principal has the ability to view the
data behind the wall of security and
take the necessary
steps when it comes to requests a
principal then sends a request to the
cloud management system specifying the
action and which resource should perform
it in this step the user can ask to
modify delete edit or affect other users
in this particular buget of organization
by changing the data or the
information when it comes to
authorization ation it carries out the
rest of an organization identity and
access management processes once the
user has been authenticated users are
granted authorizations according to
their role at an organization the
practice is referred to as role based
access control or
rbac authorizations determine a roles
resources and level of access in the
network these items may include systems
applications file shares printers and
more for example an accounting
department employee who regularly works
with payroll software must be authorized
to do such if authentication resembles a
passport these are the things your
digital identity can access with it
while authentication is fully
straightforward authorizations and their
management are far more challenging
authorizations consist of complex set of
rules and policies and groups which are
permitted explicitly configured per user
account with the working of IM
Frameworks out of the way let's cover
some of the tools that these systems
work on
SSO is an IM tool that enables a user to
log into one an organization's
properties and automatically be logged
into a design set of other
properties for example when you log into
Google you automatically logged into
your Gmail and your YouTube accounts
similarly for users single sign on
reduces fiction since they don't have to
keep track of different credentials for
every application for organizations SSO
helps in collecting valuable insights
about user behavior and preferences
since it attacks them as they move from
one application to another connected by
one single
login next is multiactor authentication
or
MFA implementing multiactor
authentication is crucial to protect
organization data from malicious
intrusions and virtually every IM
platform offers some form of
MFA however it's equally crucial to
customize MFA with the appropriate level
of security for example in business to
consume scenarios you need to consider
ux and try not to create unnecessary
friction for users who don't want to be
subjected to heightened scrutiny every
time they log in for Workforce you may
want a more stringent MFA since the
consequences of an unauthorized party
gaining access to your private Network
can be so devastating a modern IM
solution will allow you to implement MFA
only when it's needed this can be
accomplished through set up
authentication or adaptive
authentication in which users only
trigger MFA if they're trying to access
of data or their behavior is flagged as
risky in the past few years identity has
become the preferred Gateway for hackers
to break into systems Brute Force
attacks credential stuffing attacks and
even highly targeted fishing campaigns
are all attempts by hackers to break in
through a company's front door which is
the login box the multiple ways IM
systems can help detect and mitigate
these malicious attacks I am Solutions
detect attacks when monitoring signals
such as the velocity of traffic
detection of login p patterns that
differ from a user's routine use of a
breached password use of devices and IP
addresses with a poor reputation among
other things these are some of the most
widely used tools when it comes to IM
Frameworks but why do we go through
setting up so many tools and
firewalls let's go through some of the
advantages of using IM systems in both
corporate and consumer
environments IM solution helps identify
and mitigate security risks you can use
IM to identify policy violations or
remove inappropriate access privileges
without having to search through
multiple distributed systems we can also
leverage IM to ensure that security
measures are in place to meet Regulatory
and auditing
requirements IM am provides a common
platform for Access and identity
management information you can apply the
same security policies across all the
operating systems and devices used by
the
organization the IM framework can help
you enforce policies related to user
authentication privileges and validation
and attend to the privilege crep
problems IM simplifies signup and user
management processes for application
owners end users and system
administrators it makes it simple to
provide and manage access and PR most
user
satisfaction IM Services can also lower
operating costs using Federated identity
Services means you no longer need local
identities for external users this makes
application Administration easier
cloud-based IM Services can reduce the
need to buy and maintain on premise
infrastructure so importance of a cyber
security certification first and
foremost when I see a certification I
look at it from three different aspects
the first is the training itself which
allows me to gain the knowledge which
allows me to understand the aspects of
security or whatever the certification
is there for the second aspect is the
exam itself how do I need to prepare
myself for the exam and how do I need to
approach the exam how do I need to
ensure that I pass in my first attempt
and the third aspect is is the
certification itself which allows me to
be eligible to apply for a particular
job rule so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have that pre prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific rule uh for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into managerial or
advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
cred uh certifications can be classified
in three different aspects the first one
being the foundational level then the
managerial level and the advanced level
uh in the previous video we just had a
small overview here we are going to
discuss about what the certification
covers how the exams are conducted and
uh the price points for each and every
exam so let's start with the
foundational certifications we start off
with CCNA which is the basic
certification for networking so the CCNA
routing and switching certification
basically it helps you build your
networking career you will join an
organization as a networking engineer
where you can help the organization
establish their routing uh the pathing
of how data packets will travel across
the network this certification covers
all the basic concepts that you require
to understand networking the basic
requirements for this certification are
that the candidate must have a
bachelor's degree but apart from that
there are no other prerequisites so it's
just that you need need a bachelor's
degree and then you can apply uh you can
study for this you can undergo a
training and then you can attempt the
exam uh the certification provider
obviously is Cisco so the knowledge that
is limited to this training and
certification is for Cisco devices only
the exam fees for this certification is
approximately
$325 the exam when it is conducted uh it
has around 50 to 60 odd questions which
need to be answered in 90 minutes the
type of questions that you're going to
get is multiple choice questions where
you have a question and four answers and
you have to choose the correct answers
among those drag and drop where you have
to click on an object and drag it to its
appropriate Place probably a
architectural diagram and you have to
let's say pick on a router and place it
into a particular uh position if you
place it correctly you answer the answer
the question correctly otherwise it's
wrong and a simulator where you where
there could be a configuration you need
to configure it in a particular Manner
and then check whether the configuration
is correct or not the pass Mark is
around 800 to 850 out of a possible
th000 marks so each question will have a
different weightage depending on the
depth of the question depending on the
difficult level of the question or the
difficulty level of the question which
uh would then count towards your marks
and if you score 800 2850 that's when
you clear the exam the job roles as we
have discussed over here would be more
more on the network administrator side
or network engineer side depending on
the level of experience that you have
the salaries that are expected from this
job job roles in the US are around
$55,000 to $90,000 annually the next one
is the comcha certification called
Security Plus comcha is also a global
certification Authority for uh infosec
courses so this certification teaches
candidates on how to secure applications
networks and devices it focuses on
Hands-On practical skills in the field
of network security I have trained
people on this certification myself so
uh I know this certification is quite
Hands-On it deals with the concepts to
the core it helps you you understand the
concepts and then in the Practical
Hands-On demo uh you need to execute the
Practical yourself so that uh you can
gain that knowledge the recommended
level for a candidate to attempt this
training would be at least around 2
years of experience in the it sector in
addition if you have already been
certified for Network plus certification
from comia which is the Baseline
networking certification this is also a
preferred way to go for this
certification as said comcha is the
certificate provider and the exam fees
for this certification is3 $39 the exam
is quite simple 90 questions in 90
minutes that's 1 minute per question it
sounds like a lot of time but believe me
the questions can be a little bit
confusing can be a little bit lengthy so
you will require all those 90 minutes to
answer those questions especially when
they're tricky and that technical in
nature the questions would be multiple
choice and performance- based the pass
Mark for this exam is around 750 points
out of a possible 900 the job profiles
for this kind of a certification is when
you want to apply for for a security
analyst position or a security Engineers
position where you're going to analyze
some data to understand and figure out
what problems are ongoing in the
organization uh the average annual
salary of this uh person would be around
$72,000 then comes the CH or the
certified ethical hacker training from
EC Council now this is a very well-known
course and also uh EC council is a
global certifying Authority very well
accepted across a lot of countries uh
this is an offensive certification so
here you're basically trying to become a
penetration tester you're taught how to
hack you're taught how to attack a
particular organization from ethical
hacker perspective so the job profiles
that you'll be looking here are of a
pentester where you go into an
organization you test their security
controls or you test their devices find
out flaw flaws within them and then
provide recommendations of how to plug
those flaws or mitigate those flaws and
improve the security of that
organization it is recommended that you
have 2 years of experience at least in
networking or security for these uh to
attempt this kind of trainings and
certifications again a basic
understanding of networking maybe a
little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary uh before
attempting this certification the
certification provider is EC Council and
the exam fees for this certification is
$500 so the exam here would be $25
questions which needs to be attempted in
4 hours and you will only get multiple
choice questions in here now for CH
there are two exams one is the multiple
choice questions and the second is a
practical exam where uh you need to
solve some given problems to you in a
IAB scenario and if you are able to
solve them properly you then get
certified for CH practical the cut off
varies from 65 to 85% depending on the
questions that you have answered and the
weightage associated with each and every
question as said the job roles would be
as a penetration tester a security
engineer and your salaries would start
from around $90,000 annually then comes
the CND or the certified Network
Defender also from EC Council now this
is more on the network defense site so
here again the job rules would be where
you uh where there's a network that you
have and you're going to try to secure
the network and the communications that
are going to travel over the network so
you need to be a network administrator
network security engineer or uh in a
similar profile to understand how
networks work and then you're going to
attempt to secure those networks the
certificate provider again is EC Council
and the the certification is placed a
little bit below C so it becomes Network
defense then C where you're going to
become a penetration Tester the exam
fees for this certification is
$350 the exam the exam is of 100
questions to be answered in 4 hours
again it's just a multiple choice
questions so you get a question with
four options you answer the correct one
and you move on to the next question the
pass percentage again varies from 60 to
85% depending on the questions answered
and the weightage of that question job
rules to be applied Network defense
technician CND analyst or a security
analyst from a network perspective
salaries would range from $65,000 to
$75,000 per anom then comes the forensic
investigator course which is exactly
what it is digital forensic investigator
this will help you understand how
computers work where data is stored and
how you can retrieve that data to
investigate a crime that has uh taken
place so the candidate must have at
least 2 years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data the location
where that data is stored how databases
work how those databases store those
data and so on so forth this
certification is sought after mainly in
the law enforcement areas but there are
a few corporates that offer forensic
investigation as a service especially
when a corporate gets compromised and
they want to uh conduct their own
investigations the certification
provider for this is also EC Council and
the exam fees are $500 this is an
advanced level certification so uh
understanding of applications networks
and operating systems is a must before
you attemp this the exam is quite
similar 150 questions in 4 hours again
it's just a multiple choice question
exam the cut off again is from 60% to
85% depending on the questions and the
weightage of each and every question job
rules it security specialist network
security pro the job roles foreign sake
investigators law enforcement agenc
genes security Specialists homeland
security jobs and your salaries would be
around $88,000 and above all right now
let's talk about the managerial level
certifications kit stands for control
objectives for information and related
Technologies it's a certification that
will give a candidate and in-depth
knowledge of the framework which kit is
all about and the framework helps you
manage and govern Enterprise it
environments now this is Advanced
certification so around 8 years of
managerial experience is suggested
before you you attempt the kobit 5
certification to understand all the
aspects and to help you implement the
framework properly the certification
certificate provider is isaka the exam
fees is around
$175 now this is a small exam 50
questions but in 40 minutes so you
really have to be on your toes you have
to know the knowledge there's a very
limited time to think and you have to be
fast in your answers the past percentage
is 50% the job roles associated with
this certification would be to uh when
you apply for a information security
manager or as a security consultant or a
cyber security manager and your roles
and responsibilities would be to govern
the uh it space that the organization
owns so all the servers desktops the
network the data flows the databases
everything and how it needs to be
managed and how it needs to be governed
in a secure manner annual salaries would
be around $100,000 plus then the cism
also called as sism it stands for
certified information security manager
and as the name suggests it's a security
manager certification it helps the
candidate in understanding the
relationship between business goals and
information security so now you're going
into the space where you're not only
technical in nature but you also have to
understand the business needs the goals
of the business and you have to align
the information security of your
infrastructure along with the business
needs and the business goals so it is
your inputs that are going to go to the
management to see if the infrastructure
is aligned to the business goals or if
the infrastructure or the business goals
need any fine-tuning around 5 years of
work experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the 5 years
the candidate must have a background as
an information security manager for 3
years so you have some experience as a
manager uh you have implemented those
things yourselves which will give you a
better understanding and then you
attempt the certification again
providing by isaka and the exam fees for
isaka members is
$575 for non-members it is
$760 the exam is where you have to
answer 150 questions in 4 hours uh quite
a bit of time but questions are going to
be uh scenario based questions where
they're going to give you a lot of
scenarios you have to think about it and
you have to give the most probable and
the correct answer for that particular
scenario the pass Mark is 450 out of 800
your job profiles should be either a
risk manager or a risk consultant
analyzing the business requirements to
the infrastructure security that uh that
you have and to identify if there any
risks associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around $88,000 and above then the cisa
or the cisa the certified Information
Systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls uh in
Information Systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
5 years of work work experience in the
field of Information Systems auditing
control or security is necessary now
here the question would be what's the
difference security is where you're
technical in nature you have done let's
say a vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ipss data loss
prevention systems uh maybe even uh UTM
and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that everything is
in place you're compliant with let's say
uh ISO 2701 guidelines or the policies
that you have created yourself and
everything is working in order so it's
more of a checklist where you're going
to just check everything is in place and
you're conforming to standards this
certification is also provided by isaka
and the exam fees for isaka members are
$575 whereas non isaka members will have
to pay $760 for the certification $150
questions again in 4 hours multiple
choice questions scenario based so you
have to really understand this real
world scenarios of where what controls
and what audit mechanisms should be in
place pass Mark is 450 out of 800 your
job roles would be mainly becoming an
auditor or a senior auditor a director
for information security information
audit manager or a Information
Technology consultant where you provide
Intelligence on how the company should
Implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103,000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as crisk uh
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
Information Systems controls for an
organization this is one of the most
sought after certifications as far as
risk management is concerned in Europe
and in us if you have this kind of
certifications you automatically qualify
for a risk manager or a security risk
manager or a information security
consultant kind of a role you should
have a minimum of three years of
experience in the field of is controls
that means information security control
R you should have knowledge about
Fireballs you should know about how to
mitigate risks how to identify risks in
the first place risk analysis risk
management and after which you're going
to implement security controls to
mitigate that risk or bring it to
acceptable levels at this point in time
you will also be responsible to create
policies revolving those risks and how
you want to calculate those risk and
treat those risks in their life time
certificate provider again is isaka $575
for isaka members $760 for non isaka
members for the exam fees a similar
question 150 questions to be answered in
4 hours multiple choice based on
performances so they may give you a
scenario where you have to perform a
risk analysis and provide a report and a
solution based on your findings again
the pass Mark is 450 out of 800 the job
profiles Associated as discussed earlier
are the it risk management professionals
where they're going to identify risks
treat those risk calculate analyze maybe
do a business impact analysis to certain
how uh the organization is going to be
affected and then you will also be
looking at compliances as far as these
job roles are concerned average annual
salary would be 119,000 and above moving
on to advanced level certification now
this is where we come across the cissp
or the cisp certification certified
information system security professional
this is the gold standard of all
certifications if you have this
certificate it's you can basically be
assured of a job in the IT world now
just to qualify you'll have to have 5
years of experience in the information
uh security field there are eight
domains that are specified by cissp and
you have to prove that you have
knowledge and you have work experience
of around 5 years in at least two of
those domains if you do not have those
kind of experiences you can still
attempt the exam but you become an
associate of ISC Square which means that
you've get 6 years to accomplish the 5
years of uh experience requirement for
this certification
before taking up the cisp certification
it is suggested that the candidate
clears all the intermediate level
certifications not all but some of them
in fact I have seen people do the other
way around they qualify for cissp they
give the exam once your cisp the cisa or
CES some CIS or cism exams are way
easier to crack but you need to have
that kind of experience I have seen
people with 15 years of experience and
more fail at this certification in the
first attempt the certificate provider
is IC Square the the exam fees is
$699 like I said this certification is
where most sought after the gold
standard in fact there is hardly any
other certifications after this that you
might want to do the questions now the
exam has changed if it is the English
version that you're giving it's 150
questions to be answered in 3 hours if
it is the non-english exam that you're
attempting then it is 250 questions in 6
hours it's a marathon and if you're
opting for the 6- hour exam you need to
plan it really well it sounds really
easy but the questions are quite tough
they're scenario based and the answers
are quite confusing as well you would
get multiple choice questions you would
get drag and drop and you might get
simulators as well uh the pass Mark is
700 out of 1,000 but each question has a
different weightage so uh it depends on
which questions are asked of you and
which questions you've answered
correctly the job rules associated with
this certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so so
information security manager risk
manager system uh information system
security officer the ceso role the ciso
Chief Information Security Officer any
role that you might think of as a risk
from a risk compliance strategy could be
achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is
$108,000 for this certification
technology has become more intertwined
with our daily lives hence it is no
surprise that the need for skilled cyber
Security Professionals is on the rise
cyber security is a lucrative field and
there is a dir of skilled cyber Security
Experts therefore currently a career in
cyber security is something you should
consider if you're looking for an
interesting job role on that note hey
everyone welcome to yet another exciting
video by simply learn which will take
you through the top 10 highest paying
cyber security jobs for 2022 but before
we begin if you're new here and haven't
subscribed already make sure to hit the
Subscribe button and the bell icon for
interesting Tech videos every day so
let's let's get started at number 10 we
have the job role of a cyber security
analyst cyber security analysts are
professionals who keep a constant check
on any threat and monitor the company's
Network for potential vulnerabilities
they react swiftly to restore protection
if compromised they identify and correct
flaws uncovered in the company's
applications programs Security Systems
computer networks and more cyber
security analysts even recommend ways to
improve the business business's overall
security and communicate the specific
measures to be taken they compile
ongoing safety reports document security
issues and measures taken to resolve
them now let's have a look at the salary
of a cyber security
analyst according to glor a cyber
security analyst in the United States
earns about
$80,000 per anim and in India you can
earn nearly 6 lakh rupees
annually next on a list we have the job
role of a network engineer a network
engineer is a person who understands the
structure and network Essentials of the
entire organization at a macro level
they design and maintain any network
that supports the company's life cycle
and growth opportunities Network
Engineers take charge of the
configuration and installation of
network devices and
services they also collaborate with the
security team and ensure network
security through the implementation of
to tools and procedures in line with
them they monitor Network performance
and ensure reliability and
availability according to glassor a
network engineer in the US earns over
$85,000 per anom and in India the
average salary is 4 lakhs annually
moving on the next job role on our list
is that of an ethical hacker ethical
hackers are Network Security Consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do they are also known as white
hat hackers they scan the network and
systems for vulnerabilities before a
black hat hacker would ethical hackers
probe and test their network using
various penetration tools and software
additionally they also design new
penetration tools and document the test
results according to pay scale in the US
a certified ethical hacker earns around
$96,000 on an annual average basis and
in India they make around 5 lakh rupees
per anom moving to our next job role we
have malware analyst a malware analyst
analyzes malicious software that
includes BS worms and Trojans to
understand the nature of their threat a
malware analyst has a dual mentality by
being both Forward Thinking and reverse
thinking moving on to the
responsibilities of a malware analyst
firstly they use tools and expert level
knowledge to help decide what kind of
malware they are dissembling and if they
have encountered this particular kind of
malware before you will use Dynamic
malware analysis tools to achieve
insight into software attacks secondly
they also uncover hidden indicators of
compromise that should be blocked and
keep an organization software updated to
protect against the latest malware
threats according to glasto in the US a
malware analyst can earn about
$97,000 and the average salary for a
malware analyst is around 5 lakh rupees
in India
up next we have another very interesting
job role that is information security
analyst an information security analyst
is an expert who plans implements
upgrades and scrutinizes security
protocols to safeguard an organization's
computer networks and
information these professionals play a
vital role in the public private and
nonprofit business sectors because they
Shield a company's sensitive and
fundamental information they use data
encryption firewalls and other relevant
security tools and applications to cover
and protect transfers of secret digital
information information security
analysts perform risk assessments Audits
and tests to ensure the proper
functioning of data processing
activities and security
measures as per glass door the national
average salary of an information
security and list is around
$99,000 per anom in the states and as
per indeed in India you can earn nearly
7 lakh rupees per
anom let's have a look at the next
highest paying cyber security jobs that
is cyber security engineer a cyber
security engineer helps to design and
Implement methodologies to secure the
organization's cyers space they also
help in testing and monitoring systems
frequently to make sure that all of the
systems are up to dat and work perfectly
to defend the
information their troubleshoots security
and network problems and ensure that the
organization's data and infrastructure
are protected by enabling the
appropriate security controls cyber
security Engineers also conduct tests
and scans to identify any
vulnerabilities in the network and
system talking about the salary in the
United States a cyber security engineer
earns over
$101,000 per anim as per pay scale the
average salary for a cyber security
engineer in India is nearly 7 lakh
rupees moving on to the next job role we
have senior security consultant a senior
security consultant protects their
client Network through regular
situational
assessments senior Security Consultants
are required to carry out an assessment
of security networks to sport A System's
vulnerabilities strengths and
weaknesses following which they guide
different it teams in strengthening
their security by helping them pick the
right Solutions like new techniques or
tools they also create preventive
measures against future cyber
attacks according to indeed the average
annual salary of a senior security
consultant in the states is around
$104,000 and in India it is nearly 12
lakh
rupees next we have the role of an
application security engineer
application security Engineers work with
product managers and developers to plan
and Implement security releases in order
to understand any vulnerabilities Within
products they carry out threat modeling
tests Dynamic tests and Security reviews
following this they optimize a given
products efficacy they ensure that every
step of the software development life
cycle follows best security practices
they also help in testing the
application against security risks
before
release according to glast store in the
US an application security engineer
earns around
$110,000 on an annual average basis and
in India they make around 9 lakh rupees
perom moving on to our next job role we
have security architect a security
architect researches and plans the
security elements for their firms they
formulate company procedures and user
guides they designed robust security
structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks additionally
they also approve the installation of
VPN routers and
firewalls according to glass door a
security architect in the US makes a
handsome sum of
$150,000 a year on an average and in
India they make around 20 lakh rupees
perom and finally at number one on our
list we have the role of a chief
information security officer
ciso cisos are senior level officers in
an organization their duty is to ensure
the safety of the information they
develop Implement and maintain
information security and risk management
programs additionally they also interact
with stakeholders and regularly brief
them with information security
concerns according to glasto the average
annual salary of a chief information
security officer in the states is a
whopping
$195,000 and in India it is1 19 lakh
rupees perom
so those were the top 10 highest paying
cyber security jobs for
2022 now let's have a look at the
companies hiring cyber Security
Professionals here we have deoy net app
KPMG Bosch HP Samsung CGI and GE to name
a few in this series we are going to
discuss about the interview questions
that will be asked to candidates uh in
the cyber security field we are going to
look at multiple options over here and
we're going to discuss various fields in
which these questions will be asked in
this video we are going to look at 10
different questions on networking then
we'll have 10 more questions on software
and programming another 10 questions on
operating systems and applications 10
questions on cyber attacks and then the
finally 10 questions on cryptography so
we're going to discuss over 50 odd
questions each in these different fields
which will help you crack your
interviews as far as cyber security is
concerned let's start off with
networking questions let's start off
with question one what is the OSI model
explain the different layers of the OSI
model OSI largely is a theoretical model
uh utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created and how
they are being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the tcpip the
transmission control protocol over
Internet Protocol software suite so OSI
is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model that describes how applications
are going to interact via the computer
network there are seven different layers
that we need to understand they are as
follows so in this diagram there are
these seven different layers we start
off from the bottom first is the
physical layer the data link layer
Network layer transport layer session
layer presentation and application when
uh such a question is asked in an
interview it is not only that we
identify these seven layers explaining
what the OSI model is in the first place
we then try to identify these seven
layers and we give a brief description
about each and every layer if there are
any additional questions they will come
after uh this basic
question so let's start off with the
physical layer this is the lowest layer
of the OSI model now this is where any
and every physicality of your computer
comes into the picture so it could be an
uh network interface card it could be an
RJ45 or or a CAT 5 cable anything that
allows data to be transmitted physically
from your machine to another machine
next comes the data link
layer so on the data link layer as far
as networking is concerned we just need
to understand that data packet is
encoded decoded into bits at this layer
this is also the layer that deals with
Mac addressing so the physical address
of every network interface card which is
the MAC address which is utilized to
Route data package over the network this
is where the Mac address resides on the
data link layer the next layer is the
network layer here datagrams are
transferred from one to another the
function of this layer are routing and
logical addressing the moment we talk
about routing and logical addressing IP
addresses come into the picture IP
version 4 IP version six so Network
layer will deal with IP addressing and
the routing of those packets then comes
the transport layer this is the layer
responsible for end to end connections
that automatically signifies that this
is where TCP and UDP will be working TCP
stands for transmission control protocol
UDP for user datagram protocol TCP is a
connection oriented protocol whereas UDP
is a connection L protocol these two
Protocols are utilized to establish
connectivity between two machines TCP is
a more reliable method of connectivity
because there are a lot of packets that
are sent across to verify that the data
has been sent data has been received and
so on so for whereas UDP is a connection
L protocol where data is just dumped
without verifying whether the receiver
actually receives that data or not so in
a nutshell on the transport layer TCP
and UDP make their appearance and this
is where that functionality lies then
comes the session L this control signals
between the computer it establish
maintains and terminates connections
between processes so in the transport
layer we talked about TCP and UDP UDP
being a connection less protocol where
data is just transmitted without
verifying whether the receiver received
that data or not whereas TCP we studied
is more of a reliable protocol does
there are different packets signals that
will be sent across to verify that data
has been transmitted it has been
received properly and then the next uh
segment of that data is being sent so
those control signals are established
using the section layer so the three-way
handshake of TCP the acknowledgement
package and uh those kind of packets
will be taken taken care of on the
session layer of the OSI
model then comes the presentation layer
the presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right MIM
or encoding that is being utilized the
utf8 character set that we utilize for
presentation encryption mechanisms all
of these work on the presentation layer
and finally comes the application layer
where the application itself uses a
particular protocol so that the other uh
machine on the receiving end the
application on that machine will be able
to understand what the communication was
about right so in a
nutshell if if I start from up top the
application layer will deal with any of
the data that the application uh is
generating so maybe an user input you're
logging in you're typing the username
password all that data will be
constructed let's say into an HTTP or
https format that's where your
application layer comes into the picture
then the formatting of which into
utf8 uh and the encryption of which
would be done at the presentation layer
then the transport layer and the session
layer would kick in to establish a TCP
session do the three-way handshake
establish that connectivity IP
addressing would be done on the network
layer Mac addressing would be done on
the data link layer and when everything
is ready on the physical layer the
packet will be sent out at the receiving
end the packet will be received on the
physical layer and then all these layers
will be reversed and finally at the
application layer the data would be
presented to the application who would
then execute it and showcase it on the
screen of the
recipient so this is the way you want to
explain this question you want to be
very concise precise about what you're
explaining you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete
with the layers you just want to give
the basic functionality want to
demonstrate that you understand what the
OSI layer is how the computer functions
and you want to move on from there if
the interviewer has any further followup
questions they will ask those specific
questions so that's question one moving
on to the question two question two is
Define unicasting multicasting and
broadcasting now this is a question
which can be very lengthy but again most
of your interview questions are designed
design that way it's basically to
understand how much conceptually you are
aware about these Technologies so you
have to be very concise don't go uh
rattling about technology too much but
in a concise manner just try to explain
what these things is so when data is
being transmitted over a network it can
be trans transmitted either in one of
these particular manners it can either
be a unicast multicast or a broadcast so
what is
unicost unicast is when a message is
sent from a single user user to a single
receiver so one to one right so uh one
machine talking to another machine and
nobody else so measure Point too
Communications one point to one the
point if you have to send information to
multiple receivers then you will have to
send it using
multicast right so this is where your
multicast networking comes into the
picture so in our case uh let's assume
it's a network where there are uh
there's a Class C Network approximately
255 odd machines and Within These there
are two machines that want to talk to
each other if they want to talk between
each other it would be a point too
communication where they will utilize
unicast where only these two machines
will have visibility of that
conversation and the other machines will
not even realize that this conversation
is taking place if one machine wants to
talk to multiple machines then the
multicast comes into the picture as the
name suggests in this mode of
communication data is sent from one or
more more sources to multiple
destinations multicast uses the internet
group management protocol also known as
the igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines uh are
subscribed to those particular groups
and whenever a message needs to be sent
through those groups it will be
identified by the MMP protocol and then
that particular message will be sent to
those multiple machines that are members
of those particular group
and then comes the broadcast the third
method is known as the broadcast as it
says it is going to broadcast to all so
this is one to all that is communication
between a single user and it is going to
be sent to all the machines in that
particular
Network right so the three ways unicast
is one to one multicast is one to many
and broadcast is one to all then
question number three what is DNS DNS
stands for domain name system it is like
the internet's phone book that is
responsible for mapping the domain name
into its corresponding IP address and
let me give you an example over here
whenever we go and open up let's say a
browser a Google Chrome browser we type
in w.google.com
and then we press enter and magically
Google comes in front of us the website
rather now how does the computer know
who Google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand Google
Google and words like that computers
don't computers deal with binary zeros
and ones right and as far as Internet is
concerned they will only deal with IP
addresses and Mac addresses so how does
a computer know how to find google.com
and where is it located so the moment we
type in in the browser window in the
address bar google.com and press enter a
DNS query is generated automatically by
the browser where a packet is sent to
our DNS servers asking
what the IP address is so in short DNS
resolves domain names to their
corresponding IP addresses there is a
DNS server which will have this index a
database of all the domains associated
with their IP addresses if one
particular DNS server does not have that
information that you're looking for it
may query another DNS server who may
have that particular response so the
first thing is when you type in domain
name it gets result with the DNS it
identifies the IP address corresponding
to that particular domain name and thus
allows the computer to route that packet
to the particular server where that
domain name resides so in this scenario
if you look at the screen on the local
PC you have typed in cyers security.com
there's a DNS resolution that a query
that goes to the DNS server what is the
IP of cyber security.com the DNS server
looks it up in its particular uh
database if it has the corresponding IP
address it will then respond back the IP
address is
2521 after which the packet is sent off
to cyers security.com moving on to the
question number four what is a
firewall now this is a very good
question and normally a very basic
answer that I've ever heard is that a
firewall is a hardware and a software
firewall but that's the functionality of
a firewall that is what how you can
install a firewall but there are
different types of firewalls and there
is a specific functionality that
firewall is created for right so
firewall is either a hardware or
software but its responsibility is for
blocking either incoming or outgoing
traffic from the internet to your
computer they secure a network so
essentially the firewall will allow a
connection to happen or disallow a
connection to happen it won't go beyond
that that's the basic functionality of a
firewall okay so based on the
configurations that you have done based
on the rules that you have created on a
firewall it will then based on those
rules identify whether some traffic is
allowed in that Network or some traffic
is to be blocked from entering that
Network so as the screen shows the
firewall rules will analyze whether the
traffic is good if yes it will allow if
the traffic is bad it will block the
traffic and not allow that connection
from happening in the first place now
there are a few common types of
firewalls that also need to be included
in the answer to this question and the
first one is a a packet filtering
firewall these are the most common types
that you will come across which analyze
packets and lets them pass through only
if they match and established security
rule set now here people do get confused
when we say that we analyze packets
people think that these firewalls will
analyze the contents of that packet
which is not correct when the definition
for a packet filtering firewall says
that these firewalls analyze packets it
means that they are only analyzing the
source and destination IP addresses port
numbers and the protocols that are
mentioned in those packets these
firewalls do not have the capability of
De packet inspection or DPI as it is
known if that capability comes into the
picture you're basically looking at an
intrusion detection system or an
intrusion prevention system in today's
world called as a NextGen firewall okay
so a packet filtering firewall
essentially will only analyze data
packets for its source and destination
IP addresses port numbers and the
protocol that is being utilized it will
then map that information to the rules
that are there on the firewall and based
on those rules it will either allow that
connection to happen or disallow that
connection from
happening the second type of is a proxy
firewall these firewalls filter Network
traffic at the application Level So when
you say application Level they work at
the layer seven of the OSI model packet
filtering firewalls since we have
mentioned that they work on IP
addressing and port numbers will work on
the network layer of the OSI model also
on the transport layer because they also
look at protocols proxy firewalls will
work at layer 7even which is the uh
application layer of the OSI model and
we'll deal with application Level
protocols such as htdp https FTP SMTP
and so on so
forth and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall uh these
filter packets are the network transport
and application layers so they basically
do the job of the first and the second
type of firewalls
the packets are compared to known uh
trusted packets but now the first
question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type one and type two firewalls
like packet filtering and pro proxy
firewalls that is because that is how
the firewalls have evolved we started
off with the packet filtering then we
added functionality to it and so on so
forth so if a question comes what is a
firewall you start off with the option
saying it is a hardware or software this
is the responsibility the functionality
of a firewall is to allow good traffic
and disallow bad traffic based on the
rules that have been configured on the
firewall and then you got basically
three types of firewalls packet
filtering proxy and stateful multilayer
and just include a brief description of
each of these firewalls if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to no more then
moving on to question number five what
is a VPN VPN is also called a virtual
private Network it is a connection
between a VPN server and a VPN client so
it basically creates a encrypted tenel
between the client and the VPN server
which is then utilized to secure the
connections that you're making with the
internet so as you can see in the
diagram the user has a VPN client
installed on the machine the VPN client
then creates an encrypted tunnel to the
VPN
server and through this tunnel encrypted
data is transmitted which can then be
processed by the VPN server uh sent to
the internet information can received
can be received back by the VPN server
the VPN server will encrypt that data
back and send it back to the user so if
there's a man in the middle attack that
is happening or a hacker trying to Eaves
drop on the communication mechanism they
will not be able to do so because of the
encrypted Tel it is very difficult to
decrypt this or hack through this
encrypted tunnel the it is possible but
it is is very difficult to achieve that
moving on to question number six what
are the advantages of distributed
processing now before we go into
advantages of distributed processing we
first have to understand what is
distributed processing so it is a term
which describes various computer systems
that use more than one processor to run
an
application here multiple computers
across different locations share the
same processor the advantages of
Distributing processes are as follows
but before we go into the advantages
distrib Ed Computing is basically where
multiple machines will pull their
resources together to run a singular
application so an application that has
multiple resources and can scale up and
scale down as and when required the
advantages are that it can be very uh
very useful in data recovery for example
raid where you're striping data on
various hard disks it is reliable it is
cheaper lower cost can be achieved and
it is easy to expand because of the
scalability factor that we just talked
about if there is loss of data in one
computer it can then be recovered by
another interconnected computer and one
of the examples would be blockchain in
today's world right what is blockchain
that this data is uh created live and
stored on a connection of computers so
if one of the computers goes offline the
other computers in that network will
still have that data and they the
blockchain will still function without
any issues the second point a glitch in
one machine does not affect the
processing as there will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain several cost-effective mini
computers are used instead of costly or
Mainframe machines so instead of having
a server bank I can have multiple
machines connect interconnected together
and they can function in that particular
blockchain or for that particular
distributed processing
mechanism depending on the amount of
data processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is
tcpip tcpip or transmission control
protocol over Internet Protocol is a set
of communication protocols that are used
to interconnect networking devices on
the internet this protocol defines how
data should be transmitted over the
Internet by providing endtoend
Communications so essentially if you
want networking to be established on
your machine you will need TCP IP
without TCP IP there will be no work
groups there will be no domains
basically your interconnectivity will go
for a toss tcpip is a software that once
installed on your machine will then
interact with the hardware which is your
network interface cards and then your
switches wires cables and all those
through protocols that have been already
pre-configured in it so within the tcpip
suite of softwares you will have all the
protocols all the functionality of the
OSI layer and each and every protocol
that works on each and every layer will
be predefined and pre-configure to work
in a particular manner the Internet
Protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the TCP
you're talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the IP will then
deal with the routing of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient so the TCP I model is the
compressed version of The OSI model the
seven layers will get converted into
four layers the network access layer
internet layer transport layer and
application layer going on to question
eight what do you mean by ip config and
if config both of these are commands the
first one on a Windows machine the
second one on a Linux machine so ip
config is known as the Internet Protocol
configuration this is a command that is
used on the command line interface of
Microsoft Windows to view all the
adapters and the configuration of each
and every adapters for their network
interfaces so as you can see on the
right hand side side in the command
prompt screen if uh once you type in the
IP config command on the C prompt and
press enter it will give you a list of
all the adapters that are there so you
can see wireless land adapter local area
connection the media is disconnected it
doesn't exist at the bottom you'll see
the Wi-Fi connection wireless landan
adapter and it can give you the IP
version 6 IP address IP version 4
address the subnet mask and the default
gateway so this is the configuration
that allows the machine to know on what
network is on what is the default
gateway for communicating to the
internet what is the subnet mask so how
many computers may exist in that
particular Network and what is the IP
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well if have config is the
same thing on a Linux Mac or Unix
operating system so the command will
also give you the list of interfaces and
the configuration of each and every
interface it is used to configure
control the TC cpip network interface
parameters from the command line
interface it allows you to see the IP
address of these network interfaces so
here you can see uh
the wlp1
19s the IP address being 192 168
43215 subnet Mark being
255.255.255.0 with the broadcast being
1921 16843 255 question n what is the
difference between a domain and a work
group this can be a very interesting
question and can be a very lengthy
question at the same time a work group
is nothing but a decentralized network
where you have interconnected multiple
machines together and each machine acts
in its own individual capacity thinks of
itself as a server right so a
decentralized network you every user
manages the resources individually on
their PC so local users on their own PCS
managing uh the network shares what can
be shared from that particular machine
what data should be shared should not be
shared to whom it can be shared with and
so on so forth it is good if you got a
small network uh a few machines alog
together uh and you want them to
interact with minimal management effort
right so each computer each user will
decide what they want to allow other
users to see on that particular Network
and all of them would be connected over
a land a local area network either a
wireless or a wired one so if you look
at your home Wi-Fi right now that is one
of the the best examples of having a
work group The Domain on the other hand
is a centralized Network model so in a
corporate environment whenever you go
there and you got a domain based
username and password which when entered
onto a particular machine gives you
access to the entire network or whatever
applications and whatever resources have
been allocated to you that is where the
domain comes in so it it also uses a
single sign on mechanism for all the
resources that are that are to be made
Available to You whereas in a work group
you're a local user only meant for that
particular computer right so coming back
to the domain it is an administrator
who's going to manage the entire domain
and all of the resources connected to
the domain the resources could be
switches routers servers data stores
applications web servers Mail Exchange
servers and so on so forth so all of
these are administered by an
administrator through the domain it is
the most reliable and the optimum
solution for a large Network where
multiple users are going to interconnect
and share that data amongst each others
right the computer can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a VPN you can connect to your corporate
Network authenticate in and get access
to whatever resources you are allowed to
access whereas in a work group you have
to be a part of that Network to access
that particular network if you change
your location you go and connect to
another Wi-Fi you will lose access to
your previous Wi-Fi then the last
question for the networking uh section
what is data encapsulation in networking
data encapsulation refers to the process
of adding headers and trailers to the
data the data link layer binds each
packet into a frame that contains the
hardware address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation we have talked about how
data that has been created by the
application layer would have a header
and a trailer that will give the various
informations of where that data needs to
be sent so the hardware address which is
the MAC address comes into the and get
added to the header and the IP addresses
port numbers and all of those things
would then be added to this uh trailers
as well so that the data can be then
routed to the intended recipient of that
particular
communication with this we end the first
10 questions in networking and in this
video we are going to look at software
and programming so we're going to look
at the first 10 questions first question
being how do you keep a computer secure
now this is going to to be a very
generic question so you want to put your
best foot forward and you want to
identify the most common methodologies
on how we can keep a computer secure so
when we talk about computers the first
thing that you want to talk about is
authentication mechanisms where you want
multiactor authentication or two-way
authentication to ensure that your
accounts are kept secured now if you
look at using passwords depending on how
passwords are being stored by the
application uh password attacks can be
possible either a Brute Force attack or
a dictionary base attack uh or even
password guessing attacks are possible
to mitigate those kind of attacks you we
need multiactor
authentication to ensure that accounts
are kep secure now even if we are using
multiactor authentication we also want
to look at secure passwords which means
that the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks and
a Brute Force attack or a dictionary
attack is is just not possible so we
want to randomize our passwords we want
to create a complexity where a password
meets standards such as uh meet has at
least one lowercase one uppercase
character has numerics and special
characters and is randomized is not
based on a dictionary word doesn't
contain usernames email addresses phone
numbers or anything that is personal to
that particular user third keep regular
updates which means that there will be
patches that will be released for the
application for the software that you're
utilizing download the patches install
them on a regular basis to ensure that
you are secured against the most recent
attacks that have been
identified install a good
antivirus could be a Internet Security
Suite which will have an antivirus
intrusion detection system a firewall uh
and will help you protect yourself
against Ransom Wares malwares and any
script based attacks also have a
specialized firewall on your system
could be a host-based firewall or a
network based firewall to ensure that uh
attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions in place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices have anti-
fishing softwares installed as well to
ensure that you are not getting any spam
mails even if you do you're able to
identify that and not fall pre or victim
to those spam mails fishing attacks are
generic where they are directed towards
individuals uh and they pray on the
cility of that particular individual so
our Nigerian frauds or the lotteries
that we in on a regular basis of
hundreds of million dollars uh those
messages the emails that we received
they are all fishing emails where uh
they're basically prone to victimize the
user and then Rob them of money or
install some malware or do some some
other malicious activity if you want to
enhance encryption about data that you
have stored on your devices or on your
or that is accessed by your software or
being transmitted by your software use
encryption encrypt your data whether it
is at rest whether it is in motion or
whether it is at use does reducing data
leakage and data loss uh possibilities
and finally and the foremost secure your
DNS DNS is the domain name server which
is utilized
by computers to resolve domain names to
IP
addresses if a DNS poisoning attack is
possible where your DNS settings have
been modified by an attacker and you're
redirected to a malicious DNS server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application which may
have a malware or a malicious software
as a payload also you don't want people
to know your DNS servers and the queries
that you're making so you want to use
secure DNS or uh DNS over https to
encrypt your DNS queries as
well so in a nutshell if you follow
these eight steps your devices your
computers your applications are going to
be as secure as possible the next
question discuss security related
aspects between cc++ and Java now this
is an open-ended question it depends on
which level you're giving an interview
on but you're looking at it from a
fresher perspective or a less experienc
perspective and thus these are some of
the aspects that we want to look at and
the comparisons between CC C++ and Java
so the five aspects that we're looking
at are Pointers code translations
storage allocation
inheritance and overall Security based
on cc++ and Java so when we say
pointers we are looking at how we going
to uh uh we are using pointers and uh
stacks and heaps to point to functions
and how we exit those functions and how
those functions are then Rec called into
the next function so C supports pointers
it is most secure C++ also supports
Point pointers but it is a little bit
less secure than C Java it is not
supported taret access is given to
memory allocation and thus it is the
least secure as far as pointers are
concerned when we look at code
translations C is able to compile but it
is not secure same with cc++ but in Java
it is interpreted language and it is
abstracted and secured in storage
allocation in C we use maloc and uh cck
memory allocation uh Which is less
secure because it does not have internal
checks on verifying what memory is
allocated and the user input that is
being compiled or that is being input to
that memory right thus this can allow
buffer overflow errors uh to creep in
because of the uh non-verification of
the input data so it is the least secure
in cc++ it uses new and delete options
and is comparatively secure but Java
uses a garbage collector and thus is the
most secure as far as storage allocation
is
concerned when we talk about
inheritance the most secure is
cc++ C has no inheritance so it's not
secure in C++ it is supported does it is
the most secure whereas in Java there's
multi- inheritance that is not supported
and does is comparatively secure
overall the most secure out of all these
based on these five aspects is
Java the least secure is C and the mid
level is C++ moving on to question 13
what are the different sources of
malware now malware stands for malicious
software right malware is basically a
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload of atosan
virus pyware key logger or some
malicious software that is going to have
a negative impact impa on security of
your particular device so the question
here is what are the different sources
of malware we want to identify the most
common sources through which malw infect
end user devices in today's world and we
can start with popup ads so most of the
websites if you're visiting untrusted
sites if you're being redirected to
sites that you don't know about there'll
be a lot of pop-ups coming your way
where it says you're the 1 millionth
visitor to this site please click here
to download your gift
or it will say uh congratulations on
winning a particular product for
visiting this page and so on so forth
there are some instances where you can
see a banner which is flashing at you on
top of the page and says that there are
eight uh infections that have been
identified on your computer click here
to download an antivirus to clean the
infections so all of these
popups are there as a social engineering
attack as a fishing attack to make
gullible people click on those links and
download those malwares now the software
that is posing as a security software
itself can be a malicious software which
is going to install a Trojan or a virus
or a bot on your machine compromising
the security of that machine the second
is removable media USBS and humans have
a fascination with USBS so if you find a
USB lying around it's a free USB you get
excited about it and you want to take it
home you want to plug it into a machine
and see what's on the USB worst case
scenario you format it and you got a
free USB to utilize higher the capacity
the better but that is one of the most
easiest way people use malwares to uh to
be deployed on unsuspecting users if
there is a USB lying around why would
why would somebody want to forget a USB
it's most likely planted over there as a
social engineering attack so that a gble
person is going to pick it up plug it
into their device if the device is not
secured enough it is going to install
the malware right uh then documents and
executable files this is where your
viruses and uh all those scps in so
let's say you're surfing on the internet
you're looking for a software uh and you
find the software on a particular
website you do not verify the trust
worthiness of that site and you just
download and install that software now
that software could be a malware as well
thus if you're surfing on the internet
you're downloading files from different
locations you have to research the
website you have to research the source
to ensure that it is trustworthy and
only then are you going to download and
execute those files does internet
downloads as well and when we say
internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrent uh
we go to uh dark the dark web or the
Deep Web and we searching for other
softwares especially uh those who are
researching security right we always
want we always on the lookout of new
softwares and we're always on those
forums which may not be so much
trustworthy
and we just download those files and
start installing them that is a very bad
scenario right so you have to be very
careful what you're downloading from the
internet your antiviruses your uh anti-
fishing uh mechanisms your threat
intelligence mechanisms uh have those
mechanisms installed and you want to
verify where your downloads are coming
from then your network connections if it
is a P2P connection it is a local area
network connection or a metropolitan
area network you have to verify who
which devices are connected to your
machines and you have to validate those
connections before you want to trust
those devices and before you connect to
them if you on a public Wi-Fi you
probably don't want to connect to a
public Wi-Fi in the first
place then comes email
attachments there are so many
attachments that come across in today's
world most of them in a zip format or a
RAR format uh some of them come as
document files where there are macros
here within them macros are scripts that
are recognized by Microsoft Office files
right and then finally there are these
malicious advertisements that we go find
online right uh Let It Be Facebook let
it be WhatsApp let it be uh any social
media platform that you go or even your
search engines their job is to display
ads their job is not to verify whether
the ad is legit or not it is for us as
consumers to be careful and validate
that ad and verify whether it is a
genuine ad or not so just don't start
clicking on uh any of the ad trusting uh
the platform that you're on be uh be
sure that you are investigating that ad
so these are the most common sources of
malware and the end
user will always get infected by one of
these mechanisms moving on to question
14 how does email work now this is a
very uh can be a comp Lex question uh
but we have to keep it as simple as
possible and we have to identify that
there are uh two
servers both of them either using SMTP
where which is the simple message
transfer protocol where uh in this
scenario John wants to send an email
thus they've got an email client
installed on their machine which is
connected to the mail Exchange Server
which has a DNS server which Maps the
routing and uh which Maps The Exchange
Server and inboxes so when John composes
that message and clicks on send John
should be connected to a Mail Exchange
Server where the email is sent through
that particular person's inbox so John's
inbox will then uh be validated and that
email will then be sent through the DNS
server uh through the internet and will
be received by the recipient mail server
so at this point in time John also
requires the recipients
email address so in this case this is
Jack so Jack something.com would be uh
the email address so while John is
composing uh the two field will have
Jack's email address the from field will
have John's email address the subject
field will have uh whatever they want to
convey as a message the message body
will have the message itself and then
when uh John clicks on send it will go
to their Exchange Server The Exchange
Server will then validate the Inbox and
identify where that inbox is located for
Jack and then through the internet it
will be sent to the uh to the mail
server of Jack the mail server will then
identify the proper inbox that it that
that email needs to be sent to and it
will store that email in that particular
inbox when Jack opens their computer and
accesses their inbox this email from
John will be already waiting for them
and they can respond to it the same way
John had sent that email if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know
more moving on to question 15 what are
the types of threats a company can face
right and this is where your threat
modeling comes into the picture so
you're looking at softwar you're looking
at operating systems and the company
comes and asks you uh what are the
threats that are most likely that a
company will face so on a broader scale
the threats that a company will always
face would be classified as natural
threats man-made threats technical
threats and a supply system threat so a
natural threat would be an act of God
which is outside the control of human
beings could be uh storms or any natural
occurrences like volcanoes uh
thunderstorms flooding earthquakes fire
and so on so forth so anything that is
natural so it depends on the geographic
location that you are in and what kind
of climate that area faces and you need
to identify the immediate threats and
prepare for them so if it is flooding
that you're looking at uh and you want
to look at an office uh uh and the
possibility of the office getting
flooded is real you probably want to
take office at a higher floor so that
the threat of flooding is minimized for
fire we always have a fire drill where
we practice our fire mechanism so that
we can evacuate all humans as soon as
possible and then worry about the
technicalities of it under any
circumstances under any threats humans
will always have the first priority and
then everything else comes in man-made
threats are where man themselves are a
problem so strikes lockouts hackers
theft uh War rioting all of those are
man-made threats uh which we ourselves
cannot be in control of but we need to
plan for them and we need to have uh a
business continuity plan or a disaster
equ plan for any of these threats that
have been identified then come the
technical threats technical could be
software bugs operating system bugs
application bugs that uh that come with
the applications that we have or a
hardware failure where a server crashes
a hard dis crashes maybe uh the
processor stops working the motherboard
stops working Ram gets corrupted uh any
of the technical
aspects stopping uh stop functioning
does creating a break in the business
can come under technical right so uh
anything to do with
computers let's say a server failing or
a patch that is not installed on a
particular software those would come
under technical threats and then the
supply system the supply system are your
environmental threats which dep depend
on your supply chain fa uh failures what
is a supply chain for office to function
there are a lot of dependencies that
office goes through through right there
are a lot of other vendors that suppose
that support and provide critical
infrastructure non-critical
infrastructure for the office to
function for first and foremost
electricity without electricity nothing
is going to be powered on and you're not
going to be able to function so if there
is an electricity service provider and
if there's an electric outage that's
that comes under Supply system so that's
a supply chain failure where the vendor
that provides electricity to you has
failed in providing the that particular
service and now you need a business
continuity or a disaster recovery plan
so you probably have an inverter or you
already have a power generator plant
that is going to generate your own power
and Supply it to your system right there
could be short circuits because of
fluctuation in the electricity uh maybe
the internet service provider fails and
your internet cashes so you have a
backup line for the internet from a
different vendor right and so on so
forth maybe your Hardware vendors who
are supplying you servers desktops
laptops and whatnot they fail because
they they are facing a strike or they go
bankrupt and suddenly you can no longer
purchase Hardware from your vendor
because they no longer are in business
so that's a supply chain failure so any
of these Systems Failing would also come
under threats so under a broad category
these are the first four threats that
you need to identify and then you can
elaborate by providing more scenarios
based on the experiences that you have
had towards each and every of these
threats so natural threat where you may
have had experience where there would
have been let's say a flooding uh or any
natural disaster which caused a problem
for the continuity of your particular
business so identify each and every
example for each of these threats and
provide that as an example in the
interview what is blackbox and white box
testing so when you are testing a
software or you're testing your
infrastructure there are two different
tests that you can conduct the first one
is a blackbox the second one is a white
box in a blackbox test there is no
knowledge that is shared with the tester
so let's say you're a ethical hacker and
you have been awarded a contract by an
organization to test their current
application that they have developed now
they're not going to give you any
information they're not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an IP address and a
port number where the application is
hosted and now you have to fire in your
own queries and try to figure out what
the application is try to gather
information see what uh what information
can be gathered in the first place and
based on that you're going to figure out
your way identify vulnerabilities and
see if any of those vulnerabilities can
lead to an security incident so without
any knowledge zero knowledge of the it
infrastructure or the source code that's
a blackbox attack or a blackbox test a
white box test on the other hand is
where full knowledge of the it
infrastructure or the source code is
shared so the ethical hacker has
complete knowledge and based on the
knowledge they are then going to test
out the system to see if there are any
flaws that they can identify right so
why would these two audits be important
because the first one a blackbox audit
emulates the attack of a Outsider a
external hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to figure their way
in whereas a white box attack can
emulate the attack of an Insider so a
dis employee within that organization
misusing their access controls or the
access rights
to make uh unvalidated profits right so
somebody who's corrupt who has been
bribed who wants to sell out company
Secrets based uh so they're going to try
to find out Vol abilities try to steal
data and try to sell it on the uh gray
market right so a white box would
emulate a internal attack a black box
would emulate an external attack moving
on to question 17 what is use case
testing now use case testing is a
functional test and and it is also a
blackbox test right what is a functional
test it tests the functionality of a
particular software once it has been
created why is it a blackbox test
because the user doesn't know what the
functionality is they just want to find
out each and every scenario and try to
see what that scenario generates as a
response they are not sure whether that
is the appropriate response that should
be generated or not they're just trying
to find out the response that is going
to be generated after they fire off a
query so this technique is used by
testers to get the test scenarios to
exercise the whole system from start to
finish so let's say it's a login
mechanism for an application right now a
user at this point in time the tester
since it's a blackbox testing will know
that it is a login mechanism they will
not know the details of what logging
mechanisms are being utilized so they
wouldn't know whether uh input
validation is done they wouldn't know
where the output encoding is done they
wouldn't know how the CGI calls are
being made they will not know how the uh
queries are handled at the server side
and how the database is going to treat
that particular query so they have no
idea whether the SQL injection attacks
are possible and so on so forth so for
them with whatever input they're going
to try to insert for that login
mechanism that's a functional blackbox
test the functionality mean whether the
login mechanism works and based on the
type of inputs that they're going to put
in whether it creates an unwarranted
output whether they can bypass the
mechanism or they can uh hack into the
system because of some of the flaws that
were left behind right another example
here is a software made for users to use
for documentation the testers will test
all the cases that the user can do so
can the user view a document can they
add new documents can they edit
documents and can they delete documents
so this
functionality will depend upon the
access controls that have been granted
to a particular user so for this
particular user the tester at this point
in time they would not know whether
they're an administrative user or they
are a regular user they'll just try to
do all of these and then write the
responses saying I was able to view I
was able to add I was able to edit and I
was able to delete now the result will
be then sent to a manager the manager
will look at the results and then based
on the actual access controls that were
supposed to be there for this particular
user then we'll try to identify whether
this is an acceptable case or whether
there were any flaws within this case
moving on to question 18
what is static and dynamic testing now
this is again in application testing
static testing is done in an early stage
of development life cycle now software
development life cycles there are
multiple of those what are these life
cycles there are different stages in
which a application is uh
created and provided to the customer so
your first stage would be determining
the scope of the application determining
the hardware requirements for that
application then creating a flowchart
for that application a functional chart
for that application and then maybe
start coding then an architect comes in
test the code verifies the code then the
testing phase comes in then the security
testing phase comes in and then the user
acceptance testing comes in but in every
stage at the very earliest of All Stage
a static test will always be started to
see whatever code has been developed
whatever uh scope has been developed
whether that scope is going to be
correct or not this will include walk
throughs and code review what is a
walkth through a walkth through is going
through documents that have been
generated and trying to find faults in
the documented Journey that has been
that has been created so far so let's
say somebody has created a workflow or a
flowchart for a program how the
functions are going to be called and how
they're going to be executed so walk
through would be where uh all these
responsible people will walk through
that particular flowchart and find out
any flaws within that and then Rectify
them if there is any code that has
already been written this code will be
reviewed manually and any flaws within
that code would then be identified
static testing will always be 100%
accurate in a very short amount of time
because it is immediate uh you have
created it and then the expert is going
to test it to see whether everything is
fine or not right it is all about
prevention mechanism so since you're
doing it at the Inception itself if you
find any flaw it gets immediately
repaired so this is about preventing
vulnerabilities from creeping into that
application at a later point in time
whereas Dynamic on the other side is
done at the end of the development life
cycle so you have generated the
application everything is ready now you
want to do Dynamic testing includes
functional and non-functional testing
functional testing is where the
application itself is being tested the
functions to see that all the parameters
that are given to the application are
functioning properly non-functional
testing would be where security
parameters uh administrative parameters
all of them are being verified right
this this is where your test case
scenarios come in and uh you're going to
test each and every scenario by
generating inputs and analyzing the
output that the application is going to
give you Dynamic testing is all about
cure so here you're going to identify
vulnerabilities report them to the
management and the management is then
going to figure out a way of patching
those vulnerabilities so that they can
be mitigated moving on to the next
question what are the test levels in
software testing so as for as software
testing is concerned there are four test
levels module testing integration
testing system testing and the final one
is acceptance testing so in the testing
phase of your development life cycle the
first thing is a module test you're
going to check your routines your sub
routines your subprograms procedures
that have been written in a program so
all your functions all your uh
mechanisms for that application are
going to be tested when you go into
integration testing the software may
have been integrated with multiple
softwares there may be different API
calls coming in maybe a third party
software on which you're uh depending
upon to supply for information so all of
these integration of various softwares
various apis are tested to ensure that
they are functioning properly and there
are no flaws errors or mistakes left
behind in the integration of all of
these
softwares then the system testing is
where the entire system so including the
hardware including the software right it
starts from the installation so now the
software is complete we know which
Hardware we are going to support for it
we start by installing the software and
see whether the installation is going to
be completed properly if there are any
errors in the installation process
itself then once it is installed the
performance of that particular
application the uh write speeds the read
speeds on the hard disk uh the
transaction speeds that the application
is capable of the network dependencies
that the application may have all of
those would come under system testing
and then the acceptance testing which is
basically a quality assurance exercise
that the application meets the client's
requirements so the client in the first
stage would have given the scope of what
needs to be achieved in the acceptance
testing you're verifying that that scope
has been met and the client requirements
have been met and you can assure the
client about the functionality and the
performance of that particular
application coming to the last question
in this uh software programs what are
the value steps to resolve issues while
testing so in the previous scenarios
where we have started testing now if you
find out a when you execute a particular
use case and then you find out a flaw
what would be the steps that you would
utilize to address those particular
flaws in those tests the first step will
always be record then you're going to
report it and then you're going to
introduce a Control process for it so
when you say record you're going to
create logs and you're going to try to
resolve all the problems that have
happened now when you say resolve you're
not going to recorde the application but
you're going to test the system again
and again to ensure that whatever is
being recorded is
accurate and all the logs all the error
mechanisms all the dumps all of those
that have been generated due to this
particular log or due to this particular
error are being captured so that they
can be reported to the higher level
managers so the next step is once you
have uh once you have accumulated all
these logs and Records you're going to
report them to the higher level managers
who are then going to investigate it and
go back to the developers trying to
figure out the best way to mitigate
those particular flaws so the report
writing needs also also needs to be
accurate uh it needs to be to the point
uh it needs to detail what the problem
was it will document all the steps that
there were that you took all the inputs
that you put in and it will also record
all the error errors and it will also
record all the mechanisms that were
utilized and the uh errors that were
generated and that report will be given
to the higher level managers who can
then forward it to the developers who
based on those reports can start their
troubleshooting and then the control
mechanism comes in you're going to uh
Define the issue management process so
this process needs to work in a
particular manner where you're doing a
test you're recording whatever is
happening you're creating a report out
of it you're sending it to the
management the management will then take
the those reports study them take it to
the developers the developers will test
based on their criterias they might
interact with the testers at that point
in time to identify particular flaws and
then they might want to record that
application or develop a patch which
once installed will mitigate that
particular flaw and then it can come
back to the testing phase again where
you can repeat those tests and validate
that the flaw is no longer existent so
these are the three steps that would be
uh utilized for testing
purposes and that brings us to the first
10 questions on the software platform in
the next video we'll be looking at
operating systems and applications the
first question is on virtual memory what
exactly is virtual
memory for a computer we have two types
of memory we first is the primary memory
which is your random access memory which
is also known as a volatile memory and
the secondary memory is your hard disk
where your data is stored permanently
but for a computer when it has let's say
a 4GB memory or a ram as in this
scenario on your screen it is going to
replicate that and is going to create
another 4GB of virtual memory on the
hard disk and it is going to use it in
tandem along with the
ram so if the ram is insufficient the
processor is going to utilize the 4GB of
the virtual memory that is created on
the hard disk and it is going to swap
data from the ram to the hard disk this
can also be known as a page file
or a swap file the next question is what
are different scheduling algorithms now
the context for this question is you're
talking about a Prof processor and we
talking about how processes are going to
be fed to the processor and how the
processor is going to treat these
processes so the first is first come
first serve so the process which
requests the CPU first gets the CPU
allocation first now whenever there are
processes that are being run by
different applications they make request
for some CPU time now in first come
first serve the first service or the
first process that is going to request
some processing time will get that much
allocated to them they will run through
the process first and then the next and
the next and so on so
forth the second one is the shortest job
first this is the process where the
shortest execution time for that process
is calculated and that process is
selected first for the
CPU then there is priority scheduling
this schedulers selects the task to to
work as per priority so there would be
some tasks that are marked with high
priority some would be normal and some
would be low So based on this high
normal or low priority uh all the
processes will be classified high
priority will be dealt with uh first
then the normal and then the least
priority the fourth option is multiple
level cues where processes are assigned
to a queue based on the specific
property like process priority the size
of memory Etc so it will be classified
based on the attributes given to that
particular process and uh multiple cues
will be created and then based on the
attributes the processes will be uh
processed by the
CPU then shortest remaining time the
process will be allocated to the task
Which is closest to its completion so or
you look at it this way the process that
will take the least time to complete its
processing would be chosen first
and then the round robin method where
each process comes in turn gets an equal
share of time so if there are 10
processes each process will be allocated
a certain amount of time after which the
next process will be processed and so on
so forth and it will continue in a round
drop in fashion till all the processes
get
executed so in short six different
scheduling algorithms depending on how
you uh how the operating system deals
with it
the next question is what are the steps
involved in hacking a server or a
network so this is more of ethical
hacking question you're looking at
devices and for uh and the interviewer
asks you uh what kind of steps are
involved what are the activities that
you would do in hacking a server or a
network now there are no specific steps
that you would Define because every hack
is going to be unique but it has a hack
can be classified in five different
steps which are quite generic right so
the first step will always always be the
recognizance step also known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting uh
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase the attacker gathers
all the evidence all the information
that is possible about the targets that
they want to attack so here you're
trying to get to know the victim so you
can launch specific attacks towards them
you want to identify what operating
system utilizing what IP addresses Mac
addresses the versions of the operating
systems and applications the patch
levels find out vulnerabilities find out
whatever information is possible find
out the information about the uh person
who's using those computers so you can
launch social engineering attacks and so
on so forth so the first step is all
about gathering enough information based
on which you can launch further attacks
once you have that information comes the
second phase which is known as the
scanning phase this is more of a
technical phase so you have uh in the
first step you have got your IP
addresses domain names maybe even
Network maps and you have identified
which devices are available now in the
scanning phase you're going to identify
live
devices and then you're going to scan
them for open ports processes protocols
Services you're going to identify
vulnerabilities you're going to
enumerate them to identify more
information from them thus at this point
in time you will have identified a
certain set of vulnerabilities or a
certain set of security Loop holes that
you can
misuse once you have identified
those you're going to the next step
which is the gaining access St in this
you're actually going to execute your
attacks based on the viabilities that
you have found and you're either going
to gain access to that particular system
by installing a rosion or destroy the
system by installing a virus or install
a spyware or a key logger whatever you
wanted to achieve so in the gaining
access phase you would have have based
on the knowledge that you have gain in
the first and the second phase you're
going to launch your attacks and you're
going to try to gain access to that
particular
device then the next step is where
you're going to maintain that access now
that you have hacked into that device it
is not necessary that you will always be
able to get access to that device uh
suppose you have cracked the password of
that particular user and the user
changes that password after a few days
your attack is worthless so what you're
going to do here is you're going to
maintain your access so this is
where it is assumed that you want
repeated access to that device and thus
you're going to install a key logger or
a Trojan or some mechanism which will
still allow you to get access to that
device without the knowledge or the
authorization of that particular user
and finally the last step is where
you're going to cover Your Tracks so
whatever activity that you have done so
far will have created logs and will have
created information based on which the
victim will come to know that they have
been compromised and and may be able to
trace that activity back to you so to
prevent the user or the victim from
realizing that they have been hacked and
to prevent them to discover who has
hacked them you want to cover your
tracks by deleting logs and any
references that point to that particular
activity you're going to hide the files
that you have created so you have
installed a droan or a key logger these
will create files and directories you're
going to hide them so that they are not
discovered you're going to hide
processes that have been created you're
going to try to hide all that activity
that you have done so that to conceal
the actual attack and preventing the
user from realizing that they have in
compromised so these are the five steps
that will be involved in hacking a
server Network application or any
Computing device you'll come across the
next question refers to what are the
various sniffing tools now this is a
network based attack where you're trying
to capture data package that that are
being transmitted over the network and
then you're going to analyze them to see
if you can capture any sensitive
information like usernames passwords
Bank details or anything of that sort
now these tools will also depend on
which operating system you're utilizing
for example MSN sniffer would work on
Microsoft uh operating systems eer cab
would be based on Linux and so on so
forth so on the screen you'll see six
different sniffing tools that work on
different operating systems wire shockk
is uh something that is common both on
Windows and
Linux uh it is used to analyze Network
in details it is the defacto tool that
you will come across in most of your
ethical hacking trainings in most of
your organizations when they want to do
uh data
captures now data capturing or packet
capturing is not only done by hackers to
gather more information but it is also a
known troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and network
administrators to analyze any issues
that may be going on in the network
right so the first tool you see on the
screen is wire Shar like we stated is
available for Windows Linux uh as well
then there is TCP dump which uh again
has the same capability of wire shark
but is a command line version whereas wi
shark also has a GUI a graphical user
interface TCP dump is available on Linux
MSN sniffer it's a very old tool uh when
we had MSN Messengers uh MSN Messenger
is no longer there but Microsoft does or
did have AIC Microsoft message analyzer
Tool uh which they have stopped
development since 2015 uh but that's
another tool that is specific for
Microsoft operating systems from
Microsoft that can be installed to
gather more information then you got eer
cap which is a tool to launch man in the
middle attacks data capturing and is is
essentially a Linux command line based
tool then D sniff is another password
and network capturing tool which can
help you capture data packets
prominently a Linux uh uh two same with
eer this is a graphical tool which will
allow you to uh capture data data
traffics and map protocols and identify
which IP addresses have been
communicating with what essentially all
of the tools have similar functionality
except that uh some have additional
functionality like launching man in the
middle attacks or uh capturing or having
specific filters that will help you
identify and troubleshoot some network
issues that you may be facing moving on
the next question what is an operating
system now this is a very difficult
question to answer because uh we
normally when we want to answer this
question we start off with the
functionality of an operating system
right uh we try to describe what Windows
does or what Linux does or what Mac OS
does and then we trying to figure out
what an operating system is in the first
place but an operating system
essentially as the slide says is a
software program that provides a
platform for computer hardware to
communicate and operate with the the
computer software so it is basically an
enabler for human interaction with the
hardware that you have if you take the
operating system out of the question
it's just some Hardware which cannot
interact with you but essentially when
you have operating system like Microsoft
Windows or Linux or Mac you're ENT
essentially installing a instruction set
on that particular device which will
allow you to
interact and manipulate the hardware to
do whatever you want that Hardware to do
right essentially uh when we talk about
uh drivers for your various devices like
a driver for your land card or for your
sound card or for your graphics card
which allows you to tweak these cards uh
for functionality right it allows us
input and output
functions uh for example the basic
example you open up Microsoft Office
Products like Microsoft world or Excel
and you get a GUI on the screen uh which
you can interact with you got a keyboard
and you type on that keyboard and the
computer knows what you're typing and
reflects those actions on the screen by
showcasing it on that particular uh
Excel file or a word file so how does
the computer know what to do or what
you're exactly intending to do at this
point in time it is all the operating
system that is providing you all these
Services analyzing what your inputs are
and then based uh on the programming it
is going to execute that and show it to
you on the screen right some of the most
common commonly used operating system
are Microsoft Windows you have them in
desktop as well as server variants Unix
Linux again Linux has desktop and uh
servers You Got U 2 in Linux red hat and
so on so forth and then you got Mac OS
uh for uh Apple related components the
next question what is the difference
between micro kernel and micro kernel
now the first thing we need to know is
what is a kernel kernel is the heart of
the operating system that allows that
input and output to happen it allows
those drivers to be set up so that the
hardware can interact with the software
and we can then instruct the uh software
and the hardware both to function in a
particular manner so there are two types
of kernels micro kernels and a macro
kernel micro kernel is something that we
normally use micro kernels are for uh
operating systems that use processes
directly handled by the processor the
micro kernel is very small inside
uh micro kernel is large because it
basically is the entire image of the
operating system the execution for a
micr kernel is slow the micr kernel is
going to be faster because it is more
evolved there's a lot of programming
involved extendability
micr kernels are easy to extend micro
macr kernels are hard to extend as far
as security is concerned if a micr
kernel crashes it takes everything down
with it the entire operating system is
going to crash but in case of a micr
kernel it is only that particular
process that is going to get affected
micr kernel there is a lot of coding
involved macro kernel less coding is
involved examples of micr kernels would
be Symbian OSS most popularly used on
yester your phones nokas if you remember
those uh QX and so on so forth macro
kernels your Linux or BSD operating
systems essentially use macro kernels
next question what are the different
types of operating systems so as you can
see on the screen five types of
operating systems batched OS distributed
operating systems time sharing
multi-program and real time what are
batched operating systems the computer
operator places the jobs coming from
input devices into batches so consider
this not from a desktop perspective but
from a server perspective where these
devices are used by organizations to
compute and to crunch some processes
that is going to make some business
sense out of it so when there are
multiple processors coming in multiple
jobs that are going to be scheduled a
batched OS is going to place these jobs
in batches and they're going to Crunch
those based on the uh inputs that have
been given by these operators
distributed OSS where there are multiple
computers which are interconnected and
are communicating through networks so in
a corporate environment you don't use
one single computer to do everything you
got a Data Center and the data center
will have a cluster of servers where
they're going to share some resources to
Crunch one particular task right so
that's where your distributed OSS come
into the picture then you have time
sharing OSS where you're renting some
time so time sharing OS minimizes the
response time example in today's world
Cloud right uh you go onto the cloud you
have a virtual service over there uh you
schedule something you schedule a job
over there it is uh it is executed and
for that time being that operating
system Services your particular request
and provides you that particular
job any application that you see online
that is executed for example Facebook
from a consumer perspective uh could be
a time shared
experience then multiprogrammed OS the
operating system uses CPU scheduling to
separate jobs so you're scheduling the
CPU to complete certain jobs in this
particular Manner and in realtime OS the
operating system gives maximum time to
critical operations so it ID ifies the
priority of these operations it knows
the high priority items the medium low
priority items and based on that it is
going to execute these critical
operations and get the job done moving
on to the next question what is the
difference between logical address space
and physical address space now when
you're looking at address spaces this is
where applications come into the picture
and when you execute an application it
is going to create a particular address
in the memory where it is going to
create a buffer to store its own
information so that it can be provided
to the processor processed and then can
be returned back to the application as
an output right so as far as definitions
are concerned a logical address is
generated during running of an
application or a program a physical
address is a physical address or a
physical location on the memory module
itself right visibility you can view a
logical address because it is programmed
into a computer so if I'm looking at uh
C C++ and I'm using maloc or memory
allocation uh that's where the logical
address is going to be created where a
buffer is going to be created for that
program and whatever the user input is
going to be it's going to be stored in
that buffer but whereas physical address
is concerned this logical address will
be created on a physical store or a
physical memory module which will have
its own addressing mechanism thus you
you can see the memory module but you
cannot see the specific address on that
particular memory module but as far as a
a logical address is concerned while
you're programming or you're debugging
the application it will show you the
logical address that has been created
the start point and the end point of The
Logical address that has been created
for that particular program it it can be
shown in a debugging
environment right address space logical
and physical address is physical like
this case it's the memory module itself
you can access only the physical address
on that particular memory because
logical addresses can be viewed but you
cannot access them physically uh
generation uh The Logical addresses are
generated by the CPU uh during the
processing time whereas physical
addresses are generated or computed by
the memory management unit or the mmu
that you have on your
computers and as far as logical
addresses they will always V they are
variable whereas the physical address is
always going to be constant looking at
the next question what is the difference
between logical address space and
physical address space so moving on from
the previous question to this The
Logical address is a address created by
the CPU for the processes that need to
be addressed and that need to be stored
as a buffer in the uh physical memory
whereas the physical memory itself is
going to be a address that is going to
be there on the physical part of that
memory which is uh which is going to be
assigned to it by the mmu then the next
question discusses uh shells so what
shells are used in Linux now what is a
shell shell is the command line
interface that we utilize on a Linux
machine so the terminal window as we
call it is a shell and there are
different variations of a shell based on
what lineu operating systems you're
using the desktop operating systems that
you use uh or the server operating
systems in real in today's world that
you're going to use normally will always
have a bash shell which is the first
shell that you see on the screen known
as a bone again shell it is a default
for line distribution so as far as end
consumers regular consumers are
concerned it is always going to be a
bash shell a bone again shell that
you're going to utilize for scripting
and to execute regular commands but when
it comes to high level programming or it
uh comes to specialization tasks then
you got the rest of these uh shells that
you can utilize for example the ksh
known as a con shell is used for high
level programming which supports
associative arrays and built-in
operations the Cs H or the C
shell uh has different functionality
like spelling Collections and job
controls the zsh or the Z shell provides
unique features like file generation
startup files and fish friendly
interactive shell which provides
features like Auto suggestions and
configuration so all of these have
different functionalities depending on
what uh usage that you have for that
particular shell the most common shell
like I stated is the bash shell that
you'll always come across in your
desktop lineup operating system systems
then looking at the next question what
are the process States in Linux now what
is a process process is basically a
service that is running for a particular
application for that application to
function right uh this process is going
to direct user input to the processor
process it get that output back to the
application execute it and then show it
onto the graphical user interface for
the user so in Linux there are five
states for a process first is the ready
phase now in ready in this state the
process is created and it is ready to
run so it is waiting uh it is waiting
for input it's ready uh the application
is executed the running is when the
process is being executed itself blocked
or weight is when user input is being
looked upon so it's waiting for user
input so that it can do the processing
completed or terminated it has completed
its execution or was terminated by the
operating system for some reason or the
other so this is when things have
uh the processing has been completed and
then last state state is zombie where
the process is terminated but the
process table still holds the
information or maybe it is waiting for
the kill request before it gets
terminated so these are the five states
for a Linux process to be in and that
brings us to the 10 questions in the
operating system and application space
in the next video we'll be looking at 10
more questions on cyber attacks
interview questions based on cyber
attacks
let's start off with the first one the
first question is what is SQL injection
SQL stands for structured query language
which is a language that is used by most
of your databases or your relational
databases uh the the variations of your
database would be MySQL Microsoft SQL
Oracle
SQL you'll have IBM databases all of
these databases you utilize the
structured query languages to interact
with the applications now all of these
databases have their own syntax so
you'll have to study most of these
databases based on which applications
and which databases you want to provide
security for but as the name suggests
SQL injection viability or a structured
query language injection viability is
where a user can maliciously inject a
SQL input or a SQL statement in a query
and send it to the database and aoke a
respon responds up of it so this
varability is not specifically to the
database it uh the varability lies more
in the application and the coding of
that application so when the application
receives a query which it needs to be
forwarded to the SQL uh database we need
to configure at the application Level of
what queries are allowed and what
queries are not allowed so there are
different various aspects of how to
manage a SQL injection varability but
the basic flaw lies in the application
where uh invalidated input is accepted
and sent forward to the database where
the database might confuse it into an
executable statement and thus create a
response that was not warranted there
are various types of SQL injections uh
as shown on the screen inband SQL
injection where you can look at an error
based or a union based injection a blind
SQL injection where it is either Boolean
based or a Time based attack and then an
outof bound SQL injection essentially
you're looking at databases and you're
looking at application security where
you want to encourage secure coding
practices so in unvalidated input is
mitigated then the next question is what
is spoofing now in spoofing you're
basically assuming the identity of
another person so here the attacker
pretends to be some other person or an
organization and sends you an email that
appears to be a legitimate email it
looks almost genuine it has been con
instructed to replicate what a genuine
email would have been and it is very
difficult to spot a fake one there are
different ways to identify whether an
email is genuine or not but that's for a
different video moving on to the next
question what is a distributed denial of
service attack or a Dos attack now
generally a denial of service attack is
an attack where legitimate users are
prevented access to the resources that
they legitimately can access right so
for example if it is a bandwidth based
attack the attacker consumes the
bandwidth of the network in such a way
that there is no more bandwidth left for
legitimate users to access the network
now a single device may not be able to
generate that much amount of uh traffic
to consume the bandwidth of a youth
server thus the attacker will construct
a botnet and through that botnet they
will launch a distributed denal service
attack to the Target victim right so a
botnet uh there are two terms that we
want to look at over here the first term
is a bot and the second one being the
botn net itself bot is a software that
once installed on a victim's machine
allows the hacker to uh send remote
commands to that machine that will make
it do generate some
activity once we have enough machines uh
on which such Bots have been implemented
the collection of these machines would
be known as a botnet so an attacker
would then instruct this entire botnet
to start generating data traffic to be T
to be sent to the targeted Network or to
the targeted server which will then bog
down the server thus crashing it and
preventing users from accessing that
particular resource the next question is
how to avoid ARP poisoning or ARP now
first let's understand what ARP is ARP
stands for address resolution prot
protocol which is a protocol used by
computers to communicate over the
network once your computer boots up it
starts a discovery process of
identifying its neighbors so if I'm in a
particular subnet my machine will
proactively send out ARP request and
address resolution protocol to find out
which other machines are within the same
network and which are live once it sends
out a query a live machine will respond
to that query along with its Mac address
this information is then stored in what
is known as a ARP table or an ARP table
on the machine's cache so whenever my
machine now wants to send out a packet
to this particular machine it will go to
the ARP table it will identify the IP
address and the associated Mac address
it will print that onto the data packet
as a destination uh IP and destination
Mac and send that packet across to the
switch the switch will then identify the
MAC address and send the packet to the
relevant machine that is connected to
that particular switch now to confuse
the switch into sending it to a
different machine AR poisoning attack is
created this attack is generally
launched to create a man in the- Middle
attack now to prevent this AR poisoning
from happening in the first place there
are three different aspects that we can
utilize first we can use packet
filtering which will fil filter out and
block packets that have the same Source
address data so you have identified some
malicious IP addresses and you want to
block out some IP addresses so you're
using a packet filter firewall where you
have instructed the firewall to filter
out certain
packets originating from particular
range of IP addresses this firewall and
this technique will then block those
kind of packets coming in second keeping
away from trust relationships
organizations will develop protocols
that do not depend on trust
relationships
and thus you want to keep this protocol
away from there once you have created a
trust
relationship uh these machines should
not be sending out ARP requests to other
machines in the first place since uh the
trust relationship has has been defined
and these machines know whom to
communicate with such kind of protocols
should then be disabled or you can use
an ARP spoofing software so there are
some there are softwares out there that
will look for ARP spoofing and prevent
that from happening in the first place
so if somebody has sent out a spoofed
ARP packet that packet will be picked up
by this software and it will be
mitigated of network visualizers like
glass wire antiviruses like so force uh
they have inbuilt capabilities of
identifying op spoofing attacks and
mitigate them in the first place in the
next question we're going to discuss
what is
ransomware now ransomware is a type of
malware that blocks victims to access
personal files and demands Ransom to
regain access there are three categories
before we go into the categories let's
just revisit what ransomware is let's
start with the word malware malware is a
malicious software that poses as a
legitimate software but has a payload
that will have a security impact on your
machine so in this instance uh viruses
Trojans all of these can be classified
under malv so can Ransom w a troan is a
software that will give you a backd door
access to to particular device a virus
will do some destructive activity on
that device a ransomware will basically
encrypt the data of that particular user
from on that particular machine thus
rendering that that data inaccessible to
the users themselves and in turn we'll
demand a ransom to provide access to
that particular data so the three types
of ransomwares the first one is
scareware which uses social social
engineering to cause anxiety or the
perception of a threat to manipulate
users into buying unwanted software so
this prays on the gullibility of humans
where you can see a popup appearing on
your screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked or there is a virus on your
machine and then instructs you to
download a particular software to
mitigate that particular virus now the
malware will be in this software that
you will be downloading and then a
ransomware will be installed and your
data will be encrypted screen lock
uh we locking users computers by
preventing them from logging in and
displaying an official looking message
you will see a screen saver once you
boot up which prevents you from
accessing the login page so it will not
allow you to log to your own machine but
it will give you a warning that your
data has been encrypted and you need to
connect to a particular email address
and send bit send Bitcoins over there uh
to get a decryption key to access your
own data and then the encrypting
ransomware displays a message demanding
payment in return for the private
asymmetric key which is needed to
decrypt the symmetric keys for encrypted
file so once your files have been
encrypted you might just have a blank
screen in front of you where you'll
receive a warning message uh where it
instructs you to pay up a ransom in
Bitcoins or in some cryptocurrency to
some particular digital ewallet which is
not traceable and once you make that
payment they will send you the
decryption key and then you can access
your data if getting your learning
started is have the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more then talking
about the next question what is the
difference between an active and a
passive Cyber attack now when we talk
about cyber attacks Cyber attack is a
activity that is caused by a malicious
user who wants to try to get access or
do some security incidents on the
victim's devices so there are two ways
that can happen it's either in an active
manner or a passive manner in an active
manner the Intruder attempts to disrupt
a Network's normaly modifies data and
tries to alter the systems resources so
this is more active where the attacker
will proactively uh try to destroy the
network so that Communications fail or
they might try to modify the data where
using a ransom where they can encrypt it
or they might delete that data using a
virus or steal that data using a Trojan
or they might even alter the data uh so
that it is no longer trustworthy whereas
in a passive attack the Intruder
intercepts data traveling through a
network here the Intruder EES drop but
does not modify the message so they're
just listening in they're just observing
what is going on they're not
manipulating the data they're not
stealing anything it's just that they
are monitoring the activity that's going
on then the next question what is a
social engineering attack now social
engineering attack is a people-based
attack the victim here is the Human by
itself the vulnerability also lies in
the the human it may be executed through
a computer but end of the day the gabil
is of the human so it is the art of
manipulating people so that they end up
giving up confidential information now
we always read in the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out right because they shared
the OTP with someone or they shared a
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people will fall
prey to this attack and share sh this
kind of personal information to unknown
people that is where the social
engineering attack comes in creating
that scenario which will ensure that
these people give out this confidential
information now there are three
categories in this attack well the first
one is a fishing attack second is a
spear fishing attack and a third is a
veiling attack now fishing attack is
basically a generic attack it is
targeted To The World At Large whoever
Falls pre to that attack will be a
victim
whereas a spear fishing attack is a
targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into spear
fishing where you analyze the victim you
try to figure out what their
vulnerabilities are and you tailor make
or you customize the attack to that
particular vulnerability once you have
that attack you launch it against those
people those people will then fall prey
to this attack and availing attack is
where you're
attacking uh top level Executives so the
se- level Executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people uh so any of these
people when they're attacked it will be
known as a veiling attack next question
what is man in the middle attack now
this is something that we had touched
base when we talked about ARP where the
ARP poisoning attack needs to be
executed to leverage a man in the middle
attack now in the man in the middle
attack the attacker attacking computer
takes the IP address of the client
unaware of this the server continues to
communicate with the attacker now if you
remember in a previous question we have
also talked about spoofing so in this
scenario a attacker has spoofed their IP
address to replicate themselves as a
genuine client and now with that
spoofing in mind they might either
through a r poisoning attack or just
because of the spoofed IP address become
a man in the middle that means that they
are now e dropping on the conversation
between the actual client and the server
by posing themselves as a server in this
scenario the attacker is now a go
between between the client and the
server and can ear drop and can copy the
data if they want they can modify the
data as well so as as you can see on the
screen the attacker becomes man in the
middle which means that they are now EES
dropping on the conversation that is
happening between the client and the
server the next question who are black
ad hackers and whad hackers the main
thing is the differentiation between a
blackhead hacker and a whiteed hacker
now a blackhead hackers are skilled
individuals who illegally hack into a
system the motive behind such an attack
is mostly for monetary gain these
individuals are known also known as
security crackers now if you look at
your criminal hackers those who have
malicious intent those who do hacking
for the intent of personal gain or for
the a matter of disruption the main
thing that blackhead hackers lack is
authorization they are not authorized to
do the activity that they are about to
do and they're going to get unauthorized
access to devices or to data which is
going to cause losses to the
organization involved whereas on the
other side a whad hacker are are also
known as ethical hackers these are the
individuals who discover vulnerabilities
in a computer
network and they help the organizations
mitigate these vulnerabilities they help
the organizations defend themselves from
blackhe hat hackers so the main
difference between these two types of
hackers a black hat and a white hat is
the intent and the authorization so
blackhe hat hackers will have malicious
intent they will try to personally gain
from that attack from by finding out V
abilities they also will not have
authorization to conduct whatever
activity they are doing whereas on the
other side whad hackers will be hired by
organizations they will provide
authorization for certain activity that
the whad hacker can do to find out those
vulnerabilities once those
vulnerabilities have been find out found
out by the whad hacker they will report
it to the management and guide them in
implementing security controls to
mitigate those vulnerabilities the main
difference between a black hat and a
white hat is the authorization and the
intent the next question what are honey
Poots now honey Poots are a very
interesting device that can be
introduced in a network uh these
basically are decoy servers that are
implemented in a network to attract the
attention of a attacker it is there to
lure an attacker uh into uh attacking
that particular device thus creating a
security blanket blanket for the rest of
the devices so if an attacker has been
able to bypass a firewall and is now
trying to scan a particular Network when
this Scan they will come across various
devices that are there in the network
they will then proceed to do a avability
scan on these devices the honey poot at
that point in time will provide as an or
prove as an attraction to these
attackers because it will demonstrate
some vulnerabilities to the hacker which
will divert their attention so these
vulnerabilities are simulated on these
devices these actually do not exist but
the moment the attacker then starts
interacting with the honey poot the
honey poot will identify that as a
malicious traffic and will warm the warn
the administrator about a possible
attack that is going on the
administrator will then investigate
through the honey pod of what activi is
going on and then reconfigure the
security controls to block the attacker
or mitigate the attack itself right so
it is more of a decoy server uh that
will showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities to an attacker thus to
lure them and Safeguard the rest of the
network these are the 10 questions for
cyber security in the next video we'll
be talking about cryptography the first
question Define cryptography encryption
and decryption now
cryptography is used by Security
Professionals to scramble data into
non-readable format uh which is used in
securing that
information so it involves converting
data from a readable format into a
non-readable format and then reversing
it back to rable format again for
example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like a unreadable
format now if you look at this word that
it has been scrambled into it would be
very difficult
for a human to figure out what the
actual word was now in this scenario we
have taken an algorithm where we have
made a shift of the alphabet where we
have added two alphabets to the current
one so C + 2 becomes e o + 2 becomes q m
+ 2 becomes o so we have done a shift of
two and thus the key over here for this
algorithm is the alphab plus two so any
person who figures that out will be able
to unscramble this and convert this back
into readable text the fact of
scrambling a readable text Data into
something that is unreadable by using a
particular key is What cryptography is
all about now as we discussed the
decryption again is uh replacing the
alphabet and taking it further back by
two characters so e minus 2 becomes c q
- 2 becomes o o - 2 becomes M and so on
so forth so anybody who knows this key u
the shift
key anybody will able to decrypt this
particular character so this depends on
the user if I want to utilize alphabet +
5 then the spacing the shifting of that
character will be the fifth character
from that particular character and so on
so
forth the next question what is the
difference between Cipher text and clear
text Cipher text refers to the text
which is rted and totally
undesirable the message received after
decryption is known as clear text this
text is comprehensible so the word
computer is clear text that means that
it has not been treated to any
cryptographic measures it is what it is
intended to be however if the moment we
encrypt it that means we scramble it
into unreadable text by using any of the
algorithms that we'll be looking at that
text is known as a cipher text and
without the key this this becomes
unreadable the clear text as discussed
is the plain word that we have utilized
we using the English language in this
instance so the plain word computer is
the clear text once we add the
encryption layer to it uh we get the
cipher text to
it moving on to the next question what
is a block Cipher this refers to the
method of encrypting the plane message
block by block the plane message is
broken down into fixed size blocks and
then encrypted now a block Cipher is
normally used for data that is stored so
a data that is stored on a hard disk and
we want to encrypt that data that is
known as block encryption or a block
Cipher so a block Cipher is an algorithm
that will allow you to encrypt data that
is stored onto a hard disk so in this
example we've got plain text which is 64
bits in size and we have added a layer
of encryption to it so plain text plus
the key that we have studied in the
previous questions and then the
scrambled data out of it which is
unreadable and thus encrypted then the
next question what is public key
infrastructure now the public key
infrastructure is a set of policies
which secures the communication between
a server and a client it uses two
cryptographic keys public and private so
the infrastructure itself is a set of
policies people procedures and
techniques which are standardized in
nature and are globally accepted which
allow us to use digital certificat
to encrypt data and decrypt the data at
the other end we use a symmetric
encryption over here which means that we
are used two keys one is a public key to
encrypt and the private key to
decrypt the other part of encryption is
a symmetric encryption where the same
key is used to encrypt and the same key
is used to
decrypt now in a public key
infrastructure uh like I said we have
standardized that so in in the
standardizing part of it these are the
various players that have been def in
the public key infrastructure the first
is this user or the sender in the
scenario the one who requires this
digital signature to digitally sign a
particular transaction or a
communication a registration Authority
with whom they're going to register for
that particular key the certification
Authority who issues that key the
verification Authority who validates the
uh key itself and the recipient who's
going to be the other party of that
particular transaction so how is this
you
ized a sender or the user who requires
this digital signature will request or
apply for a digital signature with the
registration Authority the registration
Authority would validate the genuinity
of the user so they might do some uh
identity verification or uh proof of
residence or something like that once
they've identified the person and they
have validated the information they will
then send the request to the
certification Authority stating that the
sender has been validated and we can and
the certification Authority can issue
the digital certificate to the
particular
user they will send the public key to
the sender which will be utilized by the
sender for a further transactions so
when the sender is going to sign some
data and uh wants to send it across to
the recipient they will use the public
key to sign it and send it across the
recipient will then validate with the
verification authority to see if the
data the sign data is correct or not now
while the certification Authority sends
the public key to the sender the
certification Authority updates the
private key with the verification
Authority so whatever is signed by the
uh sender uh received by the recipient
and they want to validate it they will
send it back to the verification
Authority the verification Authority
will validate using the private key once
the private key is validated it will
then send the okay signal back to the
recipient does allowing the
validation of that particular
transaction if the signature is tampered
with or is not the verification
Authority is not able to validate the
signature it will then send a denial
message back to the recipient and the
transaction will not go through so the
pki enables trusted digital identities
for people so the pki grants secure
access to digital resources based on the
infrastructure that has been created and
the core of the pki is a certification
Authority which ensures that the
trustworthiness of the Digital Data is
ensured so going back to the previous
slide these are the key players that
have been standardized in the uh public
key infrastructure the certification
Authority is the authority that issues
the digital certificates the validation
Authority is the one who validates that
uh digital certificate moving on what is
RSA RSA is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for secure
data transmission it stands for r Shamir
and Adelman now these are the three
people who have created this algorithm
rondre West ADI Shamir and Leonard
Adelman who are the inventors of this
technique it is a asymmetric
cryptography algorithm which works on
both public and private Keys hence the
encryption key is public and the
decryption key is kept private now as we
have discussed earlier symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography symmetric
cryptography is where the same key is
used to encrypt and decrypt whereas
asymmetic cryptography is where there
are two keys to encrypt and decrypt the
algorithm what are the few alternatives
to RSA now RSA is an algorithm that is
used for encryption there are a lot of
other algorithms that can be utilized uh
to alter or to scramble data depending
on your requirements so in the previous
question we have studied and we have
talked about what RSA is it stands for
uh R Shamir and AD the three creators of
that particular algorithm but there are
a lot of alternatives to this algorithm
depending on how secure you want that
data to be and some of them are listed
here on your screen Duo security OCTA
Google Authenticator and last pass last
pass is a password
manager so is Duo security Google
Authenticator is something that we all
utilize it is an application that we can
download and store on our mobile devices
and we can set that up to authenticate
ourselves with certain portals so it
issues a unique ID to us
which once utilized will allow us access
to those particular portals OCTA is an
identity manager where you have you have
created different digital identities and
you have assigned them certain
permissions and based on your
authentication mechanisms OCTA will
allow or disallow access to those
different applications or different
portals as you have configured it so all
four are authorization authentication
mechanisms which can be used as
alternatives to RSA if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to no more next
question what are the prime objectives
of modern cryptography and this is a
very important question because we've
we've so far looked at what cryptography
is and what public infrastructure is but
what is the achievement out of it why
are we utilizing it and what do we want
to uh gain out of it so the main and the
prime objectives of modern cryptography
are uh as follows uh mentioned on your
screen the first one is
confidentiality the second one is
non-repudiation third one is
authenticity and the fourth one is
integrity now if I go back to the first
one confidentiality uh that is where I
want to uh keep data confidential that
means it will only be visible to the
authorized users right so here I have
created a list of people who have deemed
as authorized users and have created a
digital identity to them and have given
access controls to those people now that
is how confidentiality is ensured so uh
when we want to keep data confidential
we create a list of users who we are
going to allow access to certain
resources and we are going to Define
what access controls are to be utilized
what access are allowed whether they got
an administrative access or user level
access and only those authorized users
are going to be uh able to access this
resources that is how we maintain
confidentiality the next one is
non-repudiation non- reputation is the
prevention of denial of having being a
part of a particular transaction so in
the publicy infrastructure that we
discussed where a digital signature was
utilized to sign a particular
transaction and then sent to the
recipient the sender would not be able
to deny of having gen originated that
transaction because it was using their
digital certificate thus non reputation
comes into the picture uh one more
example that we we can have here is uh
on our mobile phones when we use SMS
short messaging service and we send a
message to uh to another person the
person when they receive a message the
number is validated by the service
operator and Does the sender cannot uh
deny having sent that message the sender
at the same time can have a delivery
report sent to them uh from that the
message was delivered to the inbox of
the recipient and thus if the recipient
denies having received that message that
delivery report becomes proof of having
uh that message being delivered to their
inbox thus both the parties cannot deny
of have a of being a part of that
particular
transaction then comes the part of
authenticity now in confidentiality we
have created a digital identity assigned
it to a particular person and we have
given them digital signatures where they
cannot deny having being a part of that
transaction but authenticity is the part
where they try to prove that they are
who they claim to be so if I claiming a
digital identity I have to prove that I
am that person who I'm Who I'm trying to
claim to be and an example to that is
when we go to our gmail.com websites it
first asks us what is our username our
username is normally our email address
which identifies the account that we are
trying to access right so this account
is confidential because it is only
authorized for a particular person and
once they identify themselves by
identifying the email address that's
when the authentication part comes into
the picture where it asks for the
password now it has never ever happened
that we just go on to the gmail.com type
in a password and then it figures out
which account we are talking about so
the first step is always the
confidentiality part where we identify
which account we are talking about and
then we try to authenticate as the owner
of that particular account by providing
the appropriate password to that account
if both of these match only then do we
get access to that account and we are
able to make uh whatever transactions we
want to make now when we are making
those transactions non reputation comes
into the place where all our activities
also being logged so we have identified
our account we have authenticated
ourselves by providing the password so
the proof is there that it is us who are
trying to access it and then whatever
activity we do send an email receive an
email delete something attach something
all of those activities are logged and
stored as proof of what actions have
been done so tomorrow if we deny having
sent that email gmail can still prove to
us through those logs that the that that
activity was done by
us and the fourth part is in Integrity
which ensures that the data received and
sent and the re uh sent by the sender
and received by the recipient has not
been modified while in uh motion so the
Integrity part is the trustworthiness of
that data that that data has not been
modified by any hacker or any other uh
entity and is still trustworthy so these
are the four Prime objectives of modern
cryptography once I have scrambled that
data
using my public uh signature it is only
my private signature that is going to
decrypt it right uh using these
mechanisms I will be able to achieve all
these four aspects of cryptography and
security next question what is safer now
safer stands for secure and fast
encryption routine which is also a block
Cipher as we have discussed pre
previously block Cipher is a cipher that
is used to encrypt data that is stored
so it has a 64-bit block size and bite
oriented algorithm uh safer encryption
and decryption procedures are highly
secure this technology is widely used in
applications like digital payment card
so when you're using your a digital
payment gateway to make transactions so
you have you have gone onto an online
portal you want to purchase a particular
item and then it takes you to another
payment Gateway where you have to fill
in your credit card information
sensitive information like your uh
expiry dates CVV information and then
the OTP or the password that you have
created for your particular account now
all of these need to be secured or
highly secured based on PCI DSS which is
the payment card industry data security
standard so these standards ensure that
certain Protocols are utilized to attain
that level of security safer is one of
those block ciphers that is used under
the digital payment Gateway
infrastructure next question how does
the public infrastructure public key
infrastructure work now we have already
discussed this in the previous diagrams
uh we have identified the key players
the certification Authority the
registration Authority the end user who
requires the digital certificate the
validation Authority who's going to
validate it and then the recipient the
end user with whom the transaction is
going to be uh conducted so the first
Point here is uh the request for the
digital certificate is sent to the
registration Authority they validate it
and then they okay to the certification
Authority who then process the request
and the digital certificate is issued to
the person who has requested it so when
the person wants to conduct that
transaction they use that uh digital
certificate to sign that transaction
with the end user the end user validates
that with the validation Authority and
once validated the transaction goes
through and now the last question what
is the Blowfish algorithm it is a 64-bit
symmetric encryption algorithm so this
is an algorithm that uses the same key
to encrypt and the same key to decrypt
the same secret Keys used to encrypt and
decrypt the messages here the operations
are based on exclusive ORS and additions
to on 32bit Words the key has a maximum
length of 448 bits now this is a little
bit technical uh you might not want to
go this technical in an in an interview
question you just need to identify what
the algorithm is used for so whether it
is a Sy algorithm which means it uses
the same key or a asymmetric algorithm
where it uses a public key to encrypt
and a p private key to decrypt uh thus
the Blowfish algorithm is just one more
algorithm which uses symmetric
encryption to encrypt and decrypt data
algorithms that we have seen RSA and the
others that we have discussed as far as
the interview questions are concerned
what we need to remember is uh which
algorithms are symmetric which
algorithms are asymmetric what do
symmetric algorithms do and what do
unsymmetric asymmetric algorithms do and
we also look at block ciphers and stream
ciphers block ciphers are utilized to
encrypt data that is stored stationary
data data at rest and stream ciphers are
utilized for data in motion while
they're being streamed so SSL and TLS is
another algorithm that comes into the
picture when we looking at streaming
data so here we wrap up cyber security
course for beginners if you have any
questions add it in the comment section
and our experts will be happy to help
stay tuned with simply learn for latest
updates in cyber security thanks for
watching staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
Computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
Channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here